I'M WALKING THE HALLWAYS OR ON
THE SENATE FLOOR I'M WEARING A
MASK. PEOPLE WEAR MASKS BECAUSE
CDC HAS SAID QUOTE SIMPLE CLOTH
COVERINGS. SLOW THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS AND HELP PEOPLE WHO
MAY HAVE THE VIRUS AND DO NOT
KNOW WHAT FROM TRANSMITTING IT
TO OTHERS. UNFORTUNATELY THIS
SIMPLE LIFE SAVING PRACTICES
BECOME PART OF THE POLITICAL
DEBATE. THAT SAYS THIS IF
YOU'RE FOR TRUMP YOU DON'T WEAR
A MASK IF YOU'RE AGAINST TRUMP
YOU DO. THAT'S WHAT I'VE
SUGGESTED THAT THE PRESIDENT
OCCASIONALLY WEAR A MASK. EVEN
THOUGH IN MOST CASES IT'S NOT
NECESSARY FOR HIM TO DO SO. THE
PRESIDENT HAS PLENTY OF
ADMIRERS. THEY WOULD FOLLOW HIS
LEAD. IT WOULD HELP END THIS
POLITICAL BAIT DEBATE THE
STAKES ARE TOO HIGH FOR THIS
POLITICAL DEBATE ABOUT PRO
TRUMP ANTI TRUMP MASS TO
CONTINUE. AROUND HERE SENATORS
AND STAFF WHERE MASS BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT TO MAKE EACH OTHER
SICK FOR EXAMPLE I WAS EXPOSED
TO COVID NINETEEN. BY PRE
SYMPTOMATIC STAFF MEMBER ON MY
WAY TO DULLES AIRPORT AND AS A
RESULT HAD TO SELF QUARANTINE
FOR TWO WEEKS. SENATE POSITION
TELL ME THAT ONE REASON I
DIDN'T BECOME INFECTED WAS
BECAUSE THE STAFF MEMBER WAS
WEARING A MASK AND THAT IN THE
PHYSICIAN'S WORD. GREATLY
REDUCED THE CHANCES OF AN
EXPOSURE. IT'S ALSO A PRETTY
GOOD WAY TO MAKE A STATEMENT I
LIKE TO WEAR MY- PLAID MASK.
DOCTOR FELT SHE USES HIS MASTER
DEMONSTRATORS LOYALTY TO THE
WASHINGTON NATIONALS. SENATOR
KAINE IS EITHER A COWBOY OR A
BANDIT I'M NEVER SURE WHICH- IF
YOU WANT COLLEGE FOOTBALL TO
RETURN THIS FALL HERE'S WHAT
COACH PHILLIP FULMER OUR
ATHLETIC DIRECTOR OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF TENNESSEE SAYS.
IF YOU REALLY REALLY WANT TO
SEE SOME FOOTBALL THIS FALL
WHERE MASK THAT MIGHT HAVE MORE
INFLUENCE THAN ANYBODY ELSE IN
TENNESSEE. UNITED STATES IS IN
THE MIDST OF A VERY CONCERNING
RISING COVID NINETEEN CASES IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS IN MANY
STATES. THE EXPERTS IN FRONT OF
US HAVE TOLD US THAT WASHING
OUR HANDS STAYING APART AND
WEARING A MASK ARE THREE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT WAYS TO CONTAIN
THE DISEASE AND SLOW THE SPREAD
OF THE VIRUS. I'M GRATEFUL
RULES COMMITTEE THE SERGEANT AT
ARMS PRESS GALLERY THE
ARCHITECT OF THE CAPITOL TO
CAPITOL CAPITOL POLICE ARE
COMMITTEE STAFF BOTH DEMOCRATIC
AND REPUBLICAN- CHUNG CHEC AND
EVAN GRIFFIS ON ALL FOR THEIR
HARD WORK TO KEEP US. SAFE NOW
SENATOR MURRAY AND I WILL EACH
HAVE AN OPENING STATEMENT THEN
WE'LL TURN OUR WITNESSES WHO WE
THANK FOR BEING WITH US TODAY
EACH WILL HAVE FIVE MINUTES
WE'D ASK YOU TO SUMMARIZE YOUR-
YOUR TESTIMONY IN. FIVE MINUTES
AND THEN THE SENATORS WILL HAVE
A CHANCE TO ASK FIVE MINUTE
ROUND OF QUESTIONS WE HAVE FULL
PARTICIPATION TODAY IT LOOKS
LIKE. SHOULD BE AN INTERESTING
MORNING. AMONG THE CASUALTIES
OF THIS DANGEROUS AND VERY
SNEAKY COVID NINETEEN VIRUS ARE
THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
STUDENTS WHO WERE SENT HOME
FROM SCHOOL AND COLLEGE ON
MARCH. ADD TO THE CASUALTIES
THE TEACHERS WHO ARE PREPARED
TO TEACH REMOTELY AND THE
WORKING PARENTS WHO SAID THEY
HAD CHILDREN AT HOME AND WHO
ARE PREPARED TO HOME SCHOOL AT
THE LOST FOX SPORTS SEASONS ON
THE ONCE IN A LIFETIME
GRADUATION OPPORTUNITIES THEN
THERE WERE UNPRECEDENTED
DILEMMAS FOR ADMINISTRATORS IN
AN ADEQUATE SCHOOL BUDGETS.
BEING SENT HOME FROM SCHOOL
DOESN'T RANK WITH THE SICKNESS
AND THE DEATH OF THE VIRUSES
COST UNITED STATES AS OVER TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION CASES OF THE
VIRUS IN OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DEATHS ACCORDING
TO JOHNS HOPKINS WELL STATE'S A
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO TAKE
ACTION TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE
NOTHING THOUGH WAS MORE
DISRUPTIVE TO AMERICAN LIFE.
AND NOTHING WOULD HEADED BACK
TOWARD NORMALCY MORE RAPIDLY
THAN FOR THOSE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND SIX
THOUSAND COLLEGES TO RE OPEN
THIS FALL. EARLIER THIS MONTH
THIS COMMITTEE HEARD FROM
COLLEGE PRESIDENTS AND SCHOOL
LEADERS ABOUT THEIR PLANS FOR
SAFELY REOPENING THIS FALL.
THIS HEARING IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR AN UPDATE AND HERE FROM THE
NATION'S TOP HEALTH EXPERTS ON
HOW HEADMASTERS. PRINCIPALS
SUPERINTENDENTS CHANCELLORS IN
COLLEGE PRESIDENTS CAN OPEN
THEIR SCHOOL SAFELY JUST A FEW
WEEKS FROM NOW. THIS COMMITTEE
LAST HEARD FROM TODAY'S FOUR
WITNESSES ON MAY THE TWELFTH
WHEN THREE OF THE FORMER
QUARANTINE AND MOST OF THE
SENATORS WERE PARTICIPATING.
VIRTUALLY THAT WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST VIRTUAL SENATE HEARINGS
IN HISTORY AND SURELY THE BEST
WATCHED. EVERY NETWORK CARRIED
THE TWO AND A HALF HOURS OF
STATEMENTS AND QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS FROM SENATORS. THE
QUESTION BEFORE THE COUNTRY
TODAY IS NOT WHETHER TO GO BACK
TO SCHOOL OR COLLEGE OR
CHILDCARE OR WORK BUT HOW TO DO
IT SAFELY. EVEN THOUGH COVID
NINETEEN IS NOT IN GENERAL. HER
YOUNG CHILDREN IN COLLEGE AGE
STUDENTS NEARLY AS MUCH AS
OLDER AND MORE VULNERABLE
AMERICANS THERE IS SOME HEALTH
RISK. BUT IN MY VIEW THE
GREATER RISK IS NOT GOING BACK
TO SCHOOL. GUIDANCE FOR
REOPENING SCHOOLS FROM THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICIANS. TELL SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS THE FOLLOWING.
OUR ACADEMY STRONGLY BELIEVES
THAT ALL POLICY CONSIDERATIONS
FOR THE COMING SCHOOL YEAR
SHOULD START WITH THE GOAL OF
HAVING STUDENTS PHYSICALLY
PRESENT IN SCHOOL. THE CABINET
CONTINUES THE IMPORTANCE OF IN
PERSON LEARNING IS WELL
DOCUMENTED. THERE IS ALREADY
EVIDENCE OF NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON
CHILDREN BECAUSE OF SCHOOL
CLOSURES IN THE SPRING OF
TWENTY TWENTY. LENGTHY TIME
AWAY FROM SCHOOL AND ASSOCIATED
INTERRUPTION OF SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES OFTEN RESULTS IN
SOCIAL ISOLATION MAKING IT
DIFFICULT FOR SCHOOLS TO
IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS IMPORTANT
LEARNING DEFICITS. AS WELL AS
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT PHYSICAL
OR SEXUAL ABUSE SUBSTANCE USE
DEPRESSION AND SUICIDAL
IDEATION THIS IN TURN PLACES
CHILDREN AND ADOLESCENTS AT
CONSIDERABLE RISK OF MORBIDITY.
AND IN SOME CASES MORTALITY.
BEYOND THE EDUCATIONAL IMPACT
AND SOCIAL IMPACT OF SCHOOL
CLOSURES THERE'S BEEN
SUBSTANTIAL IMPACT ON FOOD
SECURITY AND PHYSICAL ACTIVITY
FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
THERE'S THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF. PEDIATRICIANS DR LLOYD
FISHER THE INCOMING PRESIDENT.
OF THE MASSACHUSETTS. CHAPTER
OF THE ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICIANS
TOLD REPORTERS WHILE FOR MOST
CHILDREN COVID NINETEEN IS NOT
HAD THE DEVASTATING AND LIFE
THREATENING PHYSICAL HEALTH
EFFECTS EFFECTS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED IN ADULTS. THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THEIR
EDUCATION MENTAL HEALTH AND
SOCIAL DEVELOPMENT HAS BEEN
SUBSTANTIAL ON COOL. NOTHING
CAN TAKE THE PLACE OF THE DAILY
FACE TO FACE INTERACTION OUR
CHILDREN EXPERIENCE WHEN
ATTENDING SCHOOL IN PERSON DR
FISHER SAID. MANY AMERICAN
COLLEGES OVERALL CONSIDERED THE
BEST IN THE WORLD WILL BE
PERMANENTLY DAMAGE EVEN CLOSED
OF THEY REMAIN IN BROWN
UNIVERSITY PRESIDENT CHRISTINA
PAXSON IS WORDS. GHOST TOWNS.
WHICH DANIELS THE PRESIDENT OF
PURDUE WROTE IN A WASHINGTON
POST OP ED. QUOTE FAILURE TO
TAKE ON THE JOB OF RE OPENING
WOULD NOT ONLY BE ANTI
SCIENTIFIC BUT ALSO AN
UNACCEPTABLE BREACH OF DUTY. SO
TODAY IN ADDITION TO HEARING
MORE ABOUT THE CONCERNING RISE
IN CASES IN HOSPITALIZATIONS IN
SOME STATES. I'D LIKE TO ASK
OUR WITNESSES AND THEIR
STATEMENTS OF RANCHERS TO
QUESTIONS TO PUT YOURSELVES IN
THE PLACE OF ONE OF AMERICA'S
APPROXIMATELY FOUR EIGHTEENTH.
SUPERINTENDENTS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OR THE PRINCIPAL OR
HEADMASTER A ONE OF A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
SCHOOLS OR IS PRESIDENT OR
CHANCELLOR OF ONE OF SIX
THOUSAND COLLEGES. AND HELP.
THEM ANSWER THE QUESTION OF HOW
TO RE OPEN SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES
SAFELY. SO DOCTOR FELT SHE
OPENED IN YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT OR ANSWERS TO
QUESTIONS YOU'LL SUGGEST STEPS
THE SUPERINTENDENT MIKE TAKE TO
OPEN SCHOOLS SAFELY AND NOT
ONLY HOW TO KEEP CHILDREN SAFE.
BUT KEEP SAFE THE ADULTS
TEACHERS PARENTS GRANDPARENTS
WITH WHOM THEY COME IN CONTACT
DOCTOR HANS. WILL THERE BE
TREATMENTS OR MEDICINES THIS
FALL THAT WILL HELP SPEED THE
RECOVERY FROM COVID NINETEEN OR
REDUCE THE POSSIBILITY OF DEATH
I BELIEVE THE FEAR OF GOING
BACK TO SCHOOL OR GOING
ANYWHERE THESE DAYS. IS IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE OF THE FEAR
OF SEVERE ILLNESS OR EVEN DEATH
IF THAT RISK CAN BE LESSENED BY
NEW TREATMENTS IT SHOULD
INCREASE CONFIDENCE IN GOING
BACK TO SCHOOL. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO COMMEND DR HAN IN THE WORK
THE FDA DID TO GET TESTS ON THE
MARKET QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO
HELP UNDERSTAND THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS SINCE THEN FDA HAS
WORKED OUT. WHICH TESTS HAVE
NOT WORKED AS WELL AS THEY
SHOULD AND TAKEN STEPS TO
REMOVE THEM FROM THE MARKET
THAT'S WHAT'S SUPPOSED TO
HAPPEN IN THE URGENCY OF A
PANDEMIC. EDIBLE JR WALK LAST
YEAR YOU SAID YOU EXPECTED
THERE TO BE FORTY TO FIFTY
MILLION DIAGNOSTIC TEST
AVAILABLE. EACH MONTH BY
SEPTEMBER. IS THAT STILL TRUE
AND EXACTLY HOW DOES THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT GO ABOUT MAKING SURE.
IT GETS THOSE TESTS AND WHO
PAYS FOR THEM WHAT ARE THE
PROSPECTS IN THE SHARK TANK. AT
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH THE FEDERAL BE NEW
RELIABLE AND INEXPENSIVE TEST.
SO WE CAN HAVE EVEN MORE
WIDESPREAD TESTING AND DR
REDFIELD. YOU'RE CONTINUING TO
WORK ON UPDATED GUIDELINES
ABOUT GOING BACK TO SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE SAFELY. AND OUR CDC
EMPLOYEES GOING TO BE AVAILABLE
IN OUR STATES TO HELP WORK WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO DEVELOP
THEIR PLANS AND WHAT ADVICE DO
YOU HAVE ABOUT THE ARRIVAL OF
THE FLU SEASON THIS FALL. AT
THE SAME TIME AS COVID NINETEEN.
THIS IS A LOT TO DISCUSS BUT
THERE WILL BE TIME DURING THE
NEXT TWO AND A HALF HOURS TO
ANSWER MOST OF THOSE QUESTIONS
LET ME QUICKLY HIGHLIGHT THREE
AREAS THAT HAVE COME UP IN OUR
FOR EARLIER HEARINGS THIS
MONTH. THAT I THINK NEED
CLARIFICATION FIRST ON CONTACT
TRACING NO DOUBT CONTACT
TRACING IS CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT
IDENTIFIES THE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED. SO THAT
PEOPLE WHO DON'T SO THAT THEY
DON'T IN TURN EXPOSE SOMEONE
ELSE ACCORDING TO AN NPR REPORT
ON JUNE EIGHTEEN. STATES HAVE
ALREADY HIRED AT LEAST THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND CONTACT TRACERS
STATE OFFICIALS AND JOHN
HOPKINS CENTER FOR HEALTH
SECURITY. ISSUE WERE ISSUED A
REPORT ESTIMATING THE NEED FOR
AS MANY AS ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CONTACT TRACERS SEVERAL REPORTS
SUGGESTED CONGRESS APPROPRIATE
MONEY TO PAY FOR THOSE TRACERS.
THE REALITY IS CONGRESS ALREADY
HAS. ON APRIL TWENTY FOURTH
CONGRESS APPROPRIATED ELEVEN
BILLION WHICH HAS BEEN SENT TO
STATES AND TRIBES FOR THE
EXPENSES OF TESTING. THAT
LEGISLATION EXPLICITLY SAID THE
MONEY COULD BE USED FOR CONTACT
TRACING. THIS IS IN ADDITION TO
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
MILLION FROM THE FIRST
EMERGENCY APPROPRIATIONS
LEGISLATION ON MARCH SIX THAT
COULD BE USED FOR CONTACT
TRACING. AND THAT'S IN ADDITION
TO THE MARCH TWENTY SEVEN
LEGISLATION IN WHICH CONGRESS
APPROPRIATED A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS I MEAN
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION IN THE
CARES ACT FOR STATE'S. A TEAR
TO AND- TO USE FOR COVID
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE. THE
CARRIAGE ACT ALSO INCLUDED THE
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS TO STATE'S BUT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF THAT ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
HAS NOT BEEN SPENT. EVEN THOUGH
IT IS ALL DESIGNATED FOR.
EXPENSES RELATED TO COVID
NINETEEN WHICH INCLUDES CONTACT
TRACING FOR EXAMPLE TENNESSEE'S
GOVERNOR HAS TOLD ME HE'S
RESERVING AS MUCH AS A BILLION
OF THAT. SO THAT HE COULD
DETERMINE WHAT FLEXIBILITY HE
HASN'T SPENDING THE MONEY
WASHINGTON STATE HAS NOT SPENT
AS MUCH AS ONE POINT TWO
BILLION. MISSOURI STATE
TREASURER SAYS THEY'VE NOT
SPENT ABOUT A BILLION.
ACCORDING THE REPORT BY STATE
HEALTH OFFICIALS AND JOHNS
HOPKINS AN AVERAGE SALARY FOR A
CONTACT TRACER WOULD BE A
LITTLE MORE THAN THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS ADDS UP
TO ABOUT THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CONTACT TRACERS. SOUL THE POINT
IS CONGRESS HAS ALREADY SENT TO
STATE'S. PLENTY OF MONEY TO
HIRE ALL THE CONTACT RACERS
THAT ARE NEEDED SECOND WHO PAYS
FOR THE TESTING. THE CURES ACT
CONGRESS VOTED TO MAKE ALL
COVID NINETEEN TESTS AVAILABLE
TO PATIENTS AT NO COST. THIS
MAN INSURERS WOULD COVER
DIAGNOSTIC TESTS WHICH DETECT
WHETHER A PERSON IS CURRENTLY
INFECTED WITH THE VIRUS. AND
ALSO ANTIBODY TESTS WHICH
INDICATE WHETHER A PERSON IS
HAD COVID NINETEEN IN THE PAST
AND NOW MAY HAVE SOME
PROTECTION IN THE FUTURE. I'D
MINS FROM THE LABOR DEPARTMENT
TREASURY DEPARTMENT AND CENTERS
FOR MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
SERVICES SAID LAST WEEK. THAT
INSURERS ARE ONLY REQUIRED TO
PAY FOR TESTS WITHOUT PATIENT
COST SHARING IF A DOCTOR ORDERS
IT. I AGREE WITH THAT BUT GIVEN
THAT THE CDC SPECIFICALLY
RECOMMENDS DOCTORS ORDERS. YES
IN TWO SITUATIONS WHEN A PERSON
HAS SIGNS OR SYMPTOMS OF COVID
NINETEEN OR RECENTLY HAD
CONTACT WITH CONTACT WITH
SOMEONE KNOWN OR SUSPECTED TO
HAVE COVID NINETEEN. WHO PAYS
FOR THE TESTING AT OTHER TIMES
I BELIEVE CONGRESS WILL NEED TO
TAKE ACTION TO FURTHER CLARIFY
WHO PAYS FOR THE TESTING AND
OTHER TIMES FOR EXAMPLE THE
SCHOOL MAY WANT TO DO RANDOM
TESTING. PERHAPS YOU SHOULD
MAKE AN ARRANGEMENT WITH THE
STATE TO PAY FOR THAT OR
PERHAPS CONGRESS PLEASE PROVIDE
MORE MONEY TO PAY FOR THAT. IT
WOULD AUTOMAKER WANTS TO TEST
ALL OF ITS EMPLOYEES AT THE
PLANT EVERY TWO WEEKS PERHAPS
THE AUTOMAKER SHOULD PAY FOR
THAT OR PERHAPS THE STATE.
WOULD WANT TO PAY FOR THE- THAT
NEEDS TO BE CLARIFIED. FINALLY
THE FLU SHOTS CDC IS SAID MORE
PEOPLE NEED TO GET FLU SHOTS
THIS FALL SO HEALTH CARE
WORKERS CAN BETTER DISTINGUISH.
BETWEEN COVID NINETEEN IN THE
FLINT. CITY SAYS A PRIORITY IS
FOR ALL CHILDREN. OVER THE AGE
OF SIX MONTHS TO BE VACCINATED
FOR THE FLU SO THEY DON'T
BECOME SICK. AND PASS IT TO
MORE VULNERABLE. POPULATIONS
WHO HAVE MORE SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES. ON JANUARY TWENTY
FOURTH SENATOR MURRAY AND I
HOSTED OUR FIRST BIPARTISAN
BRIEFING ON CORONAVIRUS. AT A
TIME WHEN THERE WERE ONLY FOUR
CASES IN THE UNITED STATES.
SINCE THEN THIS IS COMMITTEE
HAS HAD FOR MORE BRIEFINGS.
TODAY IS OUR EIGHTH HEARING ON
CORONAVIRUS IN US PREPAREDNESS.
LAST WEEK'S HEARING WAS ABOUT
STEPS TO TAKE THIS YEAR. ALL
OUR EYES ON THE BALL. TO BETTER
PREPARE FOR THE NEXT PANDEMIC.
I'VE ISSUED A WHITE PAPER
OUTLINING FIVE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR CONGRESS TO PREPARE
AMERICANS FOR THE NEXT PANDEMIC.
AND THAT PAPERS RECEIVED MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SUBSTANTIVE COMMENTS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AFTER ALL SENATORS
HAVE HAD A CHANCE TO ASK THEIR
QUESTIONS I WILL CONCLUDE THE
HEARING BY ASKING OUR WITNESSES
IF THEY HAVE TWO OR THREE
SUGGESTIONS ABOUT STEPS
CONGRESS SHOULD TAKE. THIS YEAR
TO DEAL WITH THE NEXT PANDEMIC.
MOST OF WHICH WILL ALSO HELP
WITH THIS ONE. BUT THIS HEARING
IS ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS NOW. IS
ADMINISTRATORS PREPARE TO
REOPEN SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES.
EXPERTS UNDERESTIMATED THIS
DANGEROUS AND SNEAKY VIRUS AND
THERE IS STILL MUCH WE DON'T
KNOW ABOUT. BUT WE DO KNOW THE
BASIC STEPS TO TAKE. TO REOPEN
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES AND TWENTY
TWENTY BEFORE THERE IS A
VACCINE. AND THOSE ARE THESE
SOCIAL DISTANCING WEAR A MASK
WASH YOUR HANDS. YES CONTACT
RACE AND ISOLATE THOSE
EXPOSURES SICK AND HOPEFULLY BY
THE FALL THERE WILL BE
TREATMENTS TO MAKE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE DISEASE
LESS SEVERE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM OUR DISTINGUISHED
WITNESSES HOW SCHOOL LEADERS
AND COLLEGE PRESIDENTS CAN
SAFELY RE OPENED ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
SCHOOLS IN SIX THOUSAND
COLLEGES. AND ALSO LEARNING THE
LATEST DEVELOPMENTS ON TESTING
AND TREATMENTS THAT WE CAN
EXPECT DURING THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY BEFORE VACCINES. ARRIVE
SENATOR MURRAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU TO
ALL OF OUR WITNESSES FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY AND OF
COURSE THANK YOUR STAFF FOR
SETTING UP THE TECHNOLOGY SO WE
CAN HOLD THIS HEARING SAFELY. I
WANT TO GET TO THE POINT
QUICKLY AND I'M GONNA BE BLUNT
ABOUT IT. THE COVID NINETEEN
RESPONSE IN OUR COUNTRY IS
STILL DISASTER. ON HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND LIVES LOST.
WAS ONCE. ESTIMATE ON THE HIGH
END OF THE SPECTRUM. BUT THE
YEARS JUST HALFWAY OVER AND IT
IS NOW GRAHAM REALITY. WE HAVE
LOST MORE AMERICANS TO COVID
NINETEEN THEN WE LOSE TO THE
REAL EACH YEAR AND WE LOST TO
THE OPIOID CRISIS LAST YEAR AND
MORE LIVES THAN WE'VE LOST AND
EVERY AMERICAN WAR EXCEPT CIVIL
WAR AND WORLD WAR TWO. AND
DESPITE WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
CLAIMS THIS PANDEMIC IS AND NOT
FEEDING FAR FROM IT. SEVERAL
STATES ARE SEEING RAPID RECORD
SETTING INCREASES AND THE
COUNTRY JUST SAW ITS LARGEST
SINGLE DAY INCREASE TODAY. AND
WHILE THIS PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
RAGES ACROSS THE COUNTRY WE'VE
SEEN A LEADERSHIP CRISIS RAGING
IN THE WHITE HOUSE AS THE
PRESIDENT CRUZ TIME AFTER TIME
HE HEARS LAST ABOUT HOW THIS
PANDEMIC IS IMPACTING FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES AND MORE ABOUT
HOW IT MAKES THEM LOOK. JUST
CONSIDER HIS APPALLING
CONTINUED FAILURE ON TESTING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID ANYONE
THAT WANTS A TASKING GET IT
CHECKED. THEY STILL CAN'T. YOU
SAID TESTING WAS OVERRATED IT
IS NOT. HE SAID WE PRE VEILED
ON TESTING WE HAVE NOT NOW HE'S
SAYING WE SHOULD BE DOING FEWER
TESTS AND TESTING MAKES US LOOK
BAD. WELL IT CLEARLY DOES NOT
AND WE CLEARLY NEED TO BE DOING
MORE. MOST ON SPRING IS SET
ABOUT TESTING. IS THAT IT
DOESN'T TAKE RESPONSIBILITY AT
ALL AND THAT IS EXACTLY THE
PROBLEM. IT'S WHY CONGRESS
ACTUALLY TOOK BIPARTISAN ACTION
IN THE LAST COVID NINETEEN
RESPONSIBILITY TO REQUIRE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TO SUBMIT
A COMPREHENSIVE NATIONAL
TESTING PLAN IT'S WHY I'M STILL
PUSHING FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION. COULD MORE
DETAILS IN THAT PLAN AND TAKE
MORE STEPS TO RAMP UP TESTING
BECAUSE WE ARE STILL NOWHERE
CLOSE TO THE TESTING AND
TRACING CAPACITY WE NEED TO
SAFELY RE OPEN OUR COUNTRY. AND
ENDING SUPPORT FOR FEDERAL
TESTING SITES WELL SITTING ON
BILLIONS IN TESTING GROUNDS
CONGRESS PROVIDED IS NOT GOING
TO GET US THERE. THE ONGOING
STRUGGLE TO GET PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO TAKE TESTING SERIOUSLY
SHOULD BE A STARK WARNING TO
CONGRESS THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
VACCINE WE CAN'T JUST LEAVE
THIS ADMINISTRATION. TO ITS OWN
DEVICES WE HAVE TO HOLD AN
ACCOUNT. WE KNOW THIS PANDEMIC
WILL NOT END UNTIL WE HAVE A
VACCINE THAT IS SAFE. AND
EFFECTIVE THAT CAN BE WIDELY
PRODUCED AND EQUITABLY
DISTRIBUTED AND THAT IS FREE
AND EXCELLENT ACCESSIBLE TO
EVERYONE. WHICH IS WHY WE NEED
A COMPREHENSIVE NATIONAL
VACCINE PLAN FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. GIVEN THE TESTING
PLANNED WHICH CONGRESS ONLY
RECEIVED AFTER FORCING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S HAND. WAS TOO
LITTLE TOO LATE WE NEED TO TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW TO GET A VACCINE PLANNED.
EARLIER AND AVOID THE MISSTEPS.
WE'VE SEEN WITH PAST. SO I HOPE
REPUBLICANS WERE WORK WITH ME A
PRIVATE WAY. ONCE AGAIN REQUIRE
THIS MINS. TO PUT FORWARD A
PLAN WE NEED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO SHOW US HOW
THEY WILL ENSURE A VACCINE IS
SAFE AND IS A PRACTICE. I'M AS
EAGER AS ANYONE FOR A VACCINE
BUT THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT DOING
SOMETHING FAST IT IS ABOUT
DOING IT RIGHT. THAT'S WHY WE
NEED TO KNOW THE PROCESS.
HOPING A VACCINE IS RIGOROUS
IT'S INCLUSIVE IT'S TRANSPARENT
AND IT IS SCIENCE DRIVEN. BUT A
LOT OF MY DOCTORS WORKING TO
BUCKLE AND THE REMOVAL OF DR
RIGHT FROM BURNING QUESTIONING
THE ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE BACKGROUND PROVEN
TREATMENT WE CANNOT TAKE FOR
GRANTED THIS PROCESS WILL BE
FREE OF POLITICAL INFLUENCE WE
HAVE TO DEMAND SERIOUS
OVERSIGHT. IN ORDER TO GIVE THE
PUBLIC FULL CONFIDENCE. THAT
VACCINE IS SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
THE ADMINISTRATION NEEDS TO
COMMIT NOW BEING FULLY
TRANSPARENT ABOUT THE STANDARDS
ARE VACCINE WILL BE EXPECTED TO
MEET. AND RELEASING THAT CAN'T
QUIT CLINICAL TRIAL DATA THE
FDA USES TO EVALUATE SAFETY AND
EFFECTIVENESS. WE ALSO NEED A
PLAN DETAILING HOW TO PRODUCE
AND DISTRIBUTE VACCINES
NATIONWIDE AND MAKE SURE
EVERYONE CAN ACTUALLY GET THEM.
WE SONG WITH TESTING HOW A BOY
DOUBLE BOTTLENECKS CREEK
DAMAGING DELAYS WHEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REFUSES TO
STEP IN AND LEAD LIKE IT NEEDS
TO DO IN A TIME OF CRISIS. AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE SAW HOW
EXISTING HEALTH DISPARITIES ARE
EXACERBATED WITHOUT A PLAN TO
OVERCOME THEM. EVEN THE
INCOMPLETE DATA WE CURRENTLY
HAVE SHOWS BLACK LATINO AND
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS ACCESS TO
TESTING THEN RIGHT COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS AN INJUSTICE THAT WE
MUST NOT REPEAT WHEN IT COMES
TO VACCINE. WE ALSO NEED A PLAN
TO GUARANTEE VACCINES ARE FREE
SO THAT COST IS NOT. USED AND
IT'S WORTH NOTING WE STILL NEED
TO ACT TO MAKE COVID NINETEEN
TREATMENT AVAILABLE AT NO COST
YOU. AND THE PLAN MUST ADDRESS
BARRIERS LIKE VACCINE HESITANCY
AND MISINFORMATION ESPECIALLY
ONE OF THE MAIN ONE OF THE MOST
PROMINENT SOURCES OF
MISINFORMATION SO FAR HAS BEEN
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES. WELL THE DISCOVERY OF
AN EVENTUAL VACCINE MAY STILL
BE FAR OFF THESE ARE ISSUES WE
NEED THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ANSWER NOW SO I HOPE
REPUBLICANS WILL WORK WITH ME
TO REQUIRE THE ADMINISTRATION
TO SUBMIT A COMPREHENSIVE
VACCINE PLANNED AND DRESSED
MANY OF THE OTHER URGENT.
ISSUES STEMMING FROM THE
SCANDAL. OUR BUSINESSES OUR
WORKERS TEACHERS STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES DO NOT HAVE WHAT THEY
NEED TO SAFELY RETURN TO WORK
OR SCHOOL PERIOD. OUR MEDICAL
SYSTEM DOCTORS NURSES FRONTLINE
WORKERS CONTINUE TO FACE
UNIMAGINABLE RISK STRESS AND
FATIGUE THEY NEED CONGRESS TO
STEP UP TO HELP THEM CONTINUE
TO SAVE LIVES. AND FAMILIES
NEED US TO CONTINUE TO ENSURE
THEY HAVE BASIC SERVICES AND
CAN KEEP FOOD ON THEIR TABLES.
THE HOUSE PASSED THE HEROES ACT
FORTY SIX DAYS AGO TO GET MORE
RELIEF TO FRONTLINE WORKERS TO
FAMILIES AND BUSINESSES. IT IS
WELL PAST TIME FOR LEADER
MCCONNELL ON SENATE REPUBLICANS
TO SIT DOWN WITH FELLOW
DEMOCRATS AND GET TO WORK
THERE'S NO QUESTION OUR COUNTRY
IS STILL IN CRISIS. AND EVERY
DAY THAT SENATE FAILS TO TAKE
ACTION ISN'T DAY WE ALLOW IT TO
GET WORSE. I ALSO WHO IS
DETERMINED THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO HAVE ANOTHER HEARING HONEST
PRICES SOON WITH
ADMINISTRATION'S. OFFICIALS
WHOSE TESTIMONY IS LONG
OVERDUE. SECRETARIES ARE SECTOR
ROSS AND SECRETARY SCHOOL YEAH
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR WITNESSES ON
TODAY AT TECH TESTIMONY AND THE
QUESTIONS WE HAVE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MURRAY. WITH ASKING
EACH WITNESS NOW TO SUMMARIZE
HIS TESTIMONY AND FIVE MINUTES
PLEASE TO WELCOME OUR WITNESSES
EACH OF YOUR MAKING SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
GOVERNMENT'S RESPONSE THE COVID
NINETEEN HELPING US GO SAFELY
BACK TO SCHOOL BACK TO WORK
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR SERVICE
TO OUR COUNTRY OUR FIRST
WITNESS IS DR ANTHONY. FAUCI
HE'S DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF ALLERGY AND
INFECTIOUS DISEASES AT THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF HEALTH.
HE HELD THIS POSITION SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR. IS LIVE
AGENCIES RESEARCH RELATED TO
HIV AIDS INFLUENZA MALARIA
EBOLA. AND OTHER INFECTIOUS
DISEASES HIS ADVICE SIX
PRESIDENTS ON DOMESTIC AND
GLOBAL HEALTH ISSUES IS ONE THE
PRINCIPAL ARCHITECT OF THE
EMERGENCY PLAN FOR AIDS RELIEF
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN HE WAS
INVOLVED IN TREATING EBOLA
PATIENTS N. I. H. AND WORKED ON
VACCINE TRIALS FOR EBOLA. NEXT
DR ROBERT REDFIELD DIRECTOR OF
THE US CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND PREVENTION. CDC FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS HE'S
BEEN INVOLVED WITH CLINICAL
RESEARCH RELATED TO CHRONIC
HUMAN VIRAL INFECTIONS AND
INFECTIOUS DISEASES ESPECIALLY
HIV. HE WAS FOUNDING DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF RETROVIRAL
RESEARCH WITHIN THE U. S.
MILITARY'S HIV RESEARCH PROGRAM
AND RETIRED AFTER TWENTY YEARS
OF SERVICE WITH US ARMY MEDICAL
CORPS. THIRD ADMIRAL BRETT JR
WALK. ROGER WHY IS HIS SISTER'S
SECRETARY FOR HEALTH AT THE U.
S. DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES HE OVERSEES THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
PUBLIC HEALTH POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS SPECIFIC TO
COVID NINETEEN RESPONSE. AT
ROGER WHAT HAS TAKEN ON TESTING
AND FOCUSED ON INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF TESTS WE CAN DO WITH
EXISTING TECHNOLOGY IS FEDERAL
SERVICE INCLUDES DIRECTING THE
DEFENSE SCIENCES OFFICE OF THE
DEFENSE ADVANCED RESEARCH
PROJECTS AGENCY AND A VARIETY
OF OTHER IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITIES. FINALLY WE
WILL HEAR FROM DOCTOR STEVEN
HAHN DR OZ COMMISSIONER OF THE
US FOOD AND DRUG ADMINISTRATION
THE FDA. BEFORE JOINING FTA HE
HELD LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AS
CHIEF MEDICAL EXECUTIVE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS MD ANDERSON
CANCER CENTER. IN HIS CHAIR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF RADIATION
ONCOLOGY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA. EARLY IN HIS
CAREER HE WAS SENIOR
INVESTIGATOR AT THE NATIONAL
CANCER INSTITUTE AT THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF HEALTH.
HE'S BEEN COMMANDER OF THE US
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICE
COMMISSIONED CORPS IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE WE WELCOME OUR
WITNESSES DOCTOR FAUCI WELCOME
LET'S BEGIN WITH YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN RANKING
MEMBER MURRAY THE NUMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
DISCUSS BRIEFLY WITH YOU TODAY
THE ROLE OF THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH IN
RESEARCH ADDRESSING COVID
NINETEEN. AND AS YOU INDICATED
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WILL DURING
THE QUESTION PERIOD AND
ALLUDING TO IN THE PRESENTATION
ADDRESSED SOME OF THE ISSUES
REGARDING SCHOOLS. THE N. I. A.
I. D. N. I. H. STRATEGIC PLAN
FOR COVID RESEARCH INVOLVES
FOUR MAJOR COMPONENTS. THE
FIRST IS TO IMPROVE THE
FUNDAMENTAL KNOWLEDGE OF
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BIOLOGY OF
THE VIRUS. AND THE IMMUNE
RESPONSE TO THE VIRUS IN ORDER
TO BETTER INFORM US IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF DIAGNOSTICS
THERAPEUTICS AND VACCINES. SOME
OF THE WORK THAT HAS COME OUT
OF THAT PROGRAM RIGHT NOW
INFORMS VERY GREATLY HI WE WILL
ADDRESS VACCINE DEVELOPMENT
PARTICULARLY UNDERSTANDING THE
CONFIRMATION OF THE COMPONENTS
OF THE VIRUS THAT INDUCES AN
APPROPRIATE IMMUNE RESPONSE. IN
ADDITION WE WILL DEVELOP AND
ARE DEVELOPING ANIMAL MODELS
APROPOS WHAT YOU MENTIONED
ABOUT CHILDREN IN SCHOOL WE
HAVE A PROGRAM CALLED HEROES
WHICH IS HUMAN EPIDEMIOLOGY IN
RESPONSE TO SARS CORONAVIRUS
WHICH IS DETERMINING THE
INCIDENTS AND TRANSMISSIBILITY
AMONG CHILDREN. A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT OPENING SCHOOLS AND THE
IMPACT THAT MIGHT HAVE. IN
ADDITION THE DEVELOPMENT OF
DIAGNOSTICS POINT OF CARE
SENSITIVE AND SPECIFIC
DIAGNOSTICS UNDER THE RAD X.
PROGRAM INCLUDING THE RED X. UP
FOR UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS.
THIRTY TWO CHARACTERIZING TEST
THERAPEUTICS YOU MENTIONED THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS AS WE OPEN
UP SCHOOLS. THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF PROGRAMS VERY ACTIVE THAT
HAVE ALREADY SHOWN EFFICACY OR
NOT IN SOME DRUGS AS WELL AS A
NUMBER OF CLINICAL TRIALS THAT
ARE ONGOING. ONE IN PARTICULAR
WAS THE FIRST RANDOMIZED
PLACEBO CONTROLLED TRIAL
SHOWING THAT THE DRUG MENDES
VIA DIMINISHES BY ABOUT 32% THE
TIME IT TAKES TO GET TO
RECOVERY. AND PEOPLE WITH
ADVANCED DISEASE PULMONARY
INVOLVEMENT. IN ADDITION WE
HAVE ANOTHER STUDY COMBINING
THIS WITH AN ANTI INFLAMMATORY
AGENT. NEXT WE HAVE VACCINES AS
SEVERAL HAVE MENTIONED IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO HAVE
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE VACCINES
AVAILABLE FOR EVERYONE IN THIS
COUNTRY AS WELL AS GLOBALLY. IN
THAT REGARD WE PUT TOGETHER
MYSELF AND SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND PUBLISHED IN
SCIENCE MAGAZINE A FEW WEEKS
AGO. WHAT WE CALL THE STRATEGIC
APPROACH TO CORONAVIRUS
NINETEEN VACCINE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT. IT'S NOT A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN ABOUT EVERY
ASPECT OF VACCINE BUT IT IS A
STRONG PLAN REGARDING THE
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
PATHWAY. AND WHAT WE HAVE DONE
IN THIS IS THAT WE HAVE WHAT'S
CALLED A HARMONIZED EFFECT
BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE WERE MANY
VACCINES. THAT ARE IN TRIAL ON
THAT WOULD VERY STAGES. AND
WHAT WE DID AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THANKS THE
GENEROSITY OF THE CONGRESS HAS
PUT A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
MONEY. IN ORDER TO HARMONIZE
THE TRIALS OF MULTIPLE.
CANDIDATES FROM DIFFERENT
COMPANIES SO THAT WE HAVE
COMMON ENDPOINTS COMMON DATA
AND SAFETY MONITORING BOARD.
AND COMMON IMMUNOLOGICAL
PARAMETERS THAT ARE BEING
FUNDED. AND ARE BEING PURSUED.
IN ADDITION THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT PLATFORMS THAT ARE
BEING PURSUED SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ALL OUR EGGS IN ONE
BASKET. AS YOU KNOW ONE OF
THOSE IS RIGHT NOW GETTING
READY AS WE APPROACH NEXT MONTH
OF GOING INTO PHASE THREE
TRIALS AND OTHERS WILL BE
STAGGERED ALONG THE WAY IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE SUMMER AND THE
SUMMER EARLY ON. THERE IS NO
GUARANTEE THAT ANYONE HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN VACCINE ELIGIBLE
TELL YOU. THAT WE WILL HAVE A
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE VACCINE BUT
WE ARE CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC.
LOOKING AT ANIMAL DATA AND THE
EARLY PRELIMINARY DATA THAT WE
WILL AT LEAST KNOW THE EXTENT
OF EFFICACY SOMETIME IN THE
WINTER AND EARLY PART OF NEXT
YEAR. AGAIN WORKING WITH THE
COMPANIES IN THE INVESTMENT
MADE BY THIS CONGRESS.
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL BE DOSE
ISABELLA HERBAL BY THE
BEGINNING OF NEXT YEAR. THESE
ARE THINGS THAT WE FEEL
ASPIRATIONAL HOPEFUL ABOUT AND
WILL CONTINUE TO PURSUE THIS.
I'LL STOP THEM IS THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE HAPPENING AS A QUESTIONS
LATER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DOCTOR FELT SHE DR REDFIELD
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING ALEXANDER
RANKING MEMBER MURRAY AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU TODAY WITH MY HHS
COLLEAGUES THE COVID NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IS THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT GLOBAL PUBLIC
HEALTH CHALLENGE THAT WE'VE
FACED AS A NATION IN MORE THAN
A CENTURY. IN THE UNITED STATES
DAILY CASES ARE INCREASING
AFTER AN EXTENDED DECLINE WE'RE
SEEING SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
THE SOUTHEAST AND SOUTHWEST
REGIONS OF THIS NATION THE
NUMBER OF JURISDICTIONS IN
UPWARD TRAJECTORY HAS CONTINUED
TO INCREASE NOW TWENTY NINE OF
FIFTY FIVE JURISDICTIONS FALL
INTO THIS CATEGORY. THE
EVIDENCE TELLS US THAT THESE
CASES ARE DRIVEN BY MANY
FACTORS TO INCLUDE INCREASE
TESTING COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION
AND OUTBREAKS IN THE SETTINGS
SUCH AS NURSING HOMES IN
OCCUPATIONAL SETTINGS
HOSPITALIZATIONS NOW ARE GOING
UP IN TWELVE STATES N. AS OF
THIS WEEKEND DAILY DEATH NOW
HAS INCREASED IN THE STATE OF.
ARIZONA CDC IS CLOSELY
MONITORING THESE INCREASE AND
HAVE FORTY EIGHT TEAMS. WITH
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND FORTY
STAFF CURRENTLY DEPLOYED IN
TWENTY STATES AND TWO
TERRITORIES. CDC IS PROVIDING
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE TO THE
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND
EPIDEMIOLOGY CONTACT TRACING
INFECTION PREVENTION AND
CONTROL AND COMMUNICATION.
BEYOND PROVIDING THIS- CRITICAL
BOOTS ON THE GROUND CDC IS
WORKING WITH YOUR STATE'S IN
COMMUNITY IN OTHER WAYS CDC IS
SPEAKING WITH THE STATE'S
TRIBAL LOCAL AND TERRITORIAL
DEPARTMENTS ON A DAILY BASIS TO
DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO STOP
COVID. WHILE RE OPENING
BUSINESSES AND SCHOOLS INITIAL
GUIDANCE FOR INSTITUTES OF
HIGHER LEARNING WAS SHARED IN
MARCH IN THE CASE THROUGH
TWELVE SETTING WAS SHARED IN
FEBRUARY- BOTH THESE GUIDANCES
HAVE BEEN UPDATED SENSE AND
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL. MONTHS
AS MORE INFORMATION BECOMES
AVAILABLE WILL CONTINUE TO
DISSEMINATE THAT MORE BROADLY
CDC RELEASE CONSOLIDATED
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR COVID
TESTING. INCLUDING INTERIM
TESTING GUIDELINES FOR NURSING
HOMES AS WELL AS TESTING
OPTIONS FOR HIGH DENSITY
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
WORKPLACES. AFTER COVID CASES
IDENTIFIED. TESTING GUIDANCE
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION K. THROUGH
TWELVE OF THE K. L. HIGHER
EDUCATION SHOULD BE POSTED
TODAY IN K. THROUGH TWELVE.
LATER THIS WEEK. THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE CONSISTENT
WITH PREVIOUSLY PUBLISHED
TESTING GUIDELINES AND ARE
MEANT TO SUPPLEMENT NOT REPLACE
THE GUIDANCE OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. CC CONTINUES TO
ADVANCE SCIENCE AROUND THE
COVID NINETEEN IMPACT IN
CERTAIN POPULATIONS AND THOSE
WHO ARE AT HEIGHTENED RISK FOR
SEVERE OUTCOMES. OUR MOST
RECENT ANALYSIS OF THE UNITED
STATES CASE STATED FROM THE
PANDEMIC HOSPITALIZATIONS WERE
SIX TIMES HIGHER AND DEATH
TWELVE TIMES HIGHER. AMONG
THOSE WITH REPORTS. QUARTERLY
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS COMPARED
TO THOSE WHO DID NOT HAVE THESE
CONDITIONS WE'VE EXPANDED THE
LIST OF UNDERLYING CONDITIONS
WHERE THE EVIDENCE IS CLEAR
THAT THEY PUT PEOPLE AT HIGHER
RISK OF SEVERE ILLNESS THESE
CONDITIONS INCLUDE CHRONIC
KIDNEY DISEASE COPD HAVING A
WEAKENED IMMUNE SYSTEM FROM IN
SOLID ORGAN TRANSPLANT. OBESITY
SERIOUS HEART DISEASE SICKLE
CELL DISEASE AND TYPE TWO
DIABETES. ARE ANNOUNCED AT THIS
DALLAS IS ALSO PROVIDES FURTHER
EVIDENCE EVIDENCE THAT RACIAL
AND ETHNIC. POPULATIONS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THIS EPIDEMIC. WHAT DATE IS THE
BACKBONE OF THIS RESPONSE
CONTAINING THE OUTBREAK DEPENDS
ON FOUR CORE INTERVENTIONS
READILY AVAILABLE TESTING
COMPREHENSIVE CONTACT TRACING
TIMELY ISOLATION OF KNOWN CASES
IN QUARANTINE TO BREAK THE
TRANSMISSION. WE ARE NOT
DEFENSELESS AGAINST THIS
DISEASE WE HAVE POWERFUL TOOLS
AT OUR DISPOSAL SOCIAL
DISTANCING WHERE FACE COVER IN
PUBLIC. AND BE DISCIPLINED
ABOUT THE FREQUENT HAND
WASHING. IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
ALL TAKE THE PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO SLOW THE
TRANSMISSION OF COVID NINETEEN
AND EMBRACE THE UNIVERSAL USE
OF FACE COVERINGS. SPECIFICALLY
I'M ADDRESSING THE YOUNG
MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY THE
MILLENNIALS AND THE GENERATION
SEES I ASK THOSE THAT ARE
LISTENING TO SPREAD THE WORD.
BEFORE I CLOSE I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK BRIEFLY ABOUT HEALTH CDC
IS ASSISTING THE FRONT LINES OF
OUR HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO FIGHT
COVID WITH YOUR SUPPORT CDC'S
AWARDED TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS
TO SIXTY FOUR JURISDICTIONS.
DATA MONETIZATION IS UNDERWAY
PUBLIC HEALTH LABORATORIES ARE
BUILDING RESILIENCE NUMBER OF
CONTACT TRACERS OF GROUNDS
THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
PERCENT. THE DISEASE IMPACTS US
ALL. AND IT'S GONNA TAKE ALL OF
US WORKING TOGETHER TO STOP IT.
TO GATHER. I BELIEVE WE CAN
ACHIEVE THE POSSIBLE. THANK YOU
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU DR
REDFIELD ADMIRAL JR WALK
WELCOME. GERMAN ALEXANDER
RANKING MEMBER MURRAY
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S GOOD TO SEE ALL
OF YOU AGAIN FIRST I WANT TO
CLARIFY MY CURRENT ROLE ON
MARCH TWELFTH SECRETARY AIDES
ARE REQUESTED THAT I LEAD THE
COORDINATION OF COVID NINETEEN
TESTING EFFORTS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT. TO BE CLEAR
ALTHOUGH I AM ASSUMING SOME OF
MY TRADITIONAL DUTIES AS THE
ASSISTANT SECRETARY I AM
MAINTAINING MY ROLE
COORDINATING TESTING INCLUDING
NOW THE N. I. H. READ ACTS
DIAGNOSTICS PROGRAM ALONG WITH
DOCTOR COLLINS TO ASSURE THAT
INNOVATIONS OR IMMEDIATELY
TRANSLATED INTO PRACTICE. IN
ORDER TO GET BACK SAFELY TO
WORK AND SCHOOL THE OVERARCHING
MOST CRITICAL AND ESSENTIAL
ACTION WE MUST FIRST
ACCOMPLISH. IS TO CONTROL THE
VIRUS. MEETING RAPIDLY
EXTINGUISHING ANY OUTBREAKS AND
MINIMIZING COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION. ALL OF US ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT RECENT DATA
FROM SEVERAL STATES INDICATING
RISING INFECTIONS AND NOW AN
UPTICK IN HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
DEATHS EVEN AS OTHER STATES AND
THE MAJORITY OF COUNTIES OR
MAINTAINING A LOW INFECTION
BURDEN. KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW
NOW ABOUT A SYMPTOMATIC
TRANSMISSION AND THE FACT THAT
WE ARE IN A MUCH BETTER
POSITION TODAY IN TERMS OF OUR
MITIGATION STRATEGIES PP AND
TESTING. WE CAN REVERSE THESE
CONCERNING TRENDS IF WE WORK
TOGETHER. FIRST WE MUST TAKE
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY AND BE
DISCIPLINED ABOUT OUR OWN
BEHAVIOR. MAINTAIN PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. WHERE A FACE
COVERING WHEN EVER YOU CAN'T
PHYSICALLY DISTANCE WASH YOUR
HANDS. STAY AT HOME IF YOU FEEL
SICK. IF YOU HAVE BEEN IN CLOSE
CONTACT WITH SOMEONE INFECTED
OR IN A GATHERING WITHOUT
APPROPRIATE PRECAUTIONS GET
TESTED. SHIELDED THE ELDERLY
AND THE VULNERABLE OF ANY AGE.
AND FOLLOW THE GUIDELINES FOR
OPENING UP AMERICA AGAIN THE
CRITERIA OR VERY SPECIFIC AND
ARE AS RELEVANT TODAY AS WHEN
WE RELEASE THEM. IN ADDITION
THIS WEEK WE ARE INITIATING
SEARCH TESTING IN MULTIPLE
COMMUNITIES OF HIGHEST CONCERN
IN COORDINATION WITH STATE AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS. NOW BACK TO
SCHOOLS AND BUSINESSES AS DR
REDFIELD STATED THE CDC WILL
RELEASE RECOMMENDATIONS ON K.
THROUGH TWELVE INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION AND GENERAL
BUSINESS REOPENING. THESE WILL
INCLUDE CONSIDERATIONS FOR
INTEGRATING TESTING ESPECIALLY
SURVEILLANCE TESTING INTO A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY. AS YOU
ASKED ME MR CHAIRMAN IF YOU ARE
SUPERINTENDENT OF A SCHOOL
SYSTEM OR PRESIDENT OF THE
UNIVERSITY NUMBER ONE APPLY THE
CDC GUIDELINES IN CONSULTATION
WITH YOUR STATE AND LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS. SAID
THAT TESTING IS A PART OF YOUR
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN WHICH SHOULD
ALSO INCLUDE PREVENTION AND
CLEAR MECHANISMS TO ISOLATE
POSITIVE STUDENTS. NUMBER TWO I
SURE YOUR TESTING NEEDS ARE
INCORPORATED INTO YOUR STATE
TESTING PLANS. AS WE OUTLINED
IN THE NATIONAL TESTING
STRATEGY EACH STATE HAS
DEVELOPED AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BUILD UPON A CUSTOMIZED TO
STATE TESTING PLAN DEVELOPED IN
FULL COORDINATION WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THE NEXT
ITERATION COVERING JULY TO
DECEMBER IS DUE ON JULY TENTH.
THESE STATE PLANS DRIVE THE
ALLOCATION OF CERTAIN SCARCE
RESOURCES FOR EXAMPLE IN MAY
AND JUNE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS DISTRIBUTED NEARLY TWENTY
SIX MILLION COLLECTION SWABS IN
OVER NINETEEN MILLION TUBES OF
TRANSPORT MEDIA. HHS ALSO
PRIORITIZES ALLOCATION OF
CERTAIN KEY LABORATORY TESTS
LIKE POINT OF CARE TESTS
ACCORDING TO STATE SPECIFIC
NEEDS. THERE ARE ALSO
STRATEGIES PARTICULARLY
RELEVANCE TO SURVEILLANCE
TESTING ESPECIALLY IN
UNIVERSITIES AND BUSINESSES FOR
EXAMPLE PULLING OF SAMPLES
MEANING COMBINING TWO OR MORE
SAMPLES AND POSSIBLY UP TO TEN
INTO A SINGLE TEST MAKES SENSE
WHERE THE PREVALENCE OF
INFECTION IS LOW. IN SUCH
PULLED SURVEILLANCE TESTING CAN
BE CONDUCTED IN A UNIVERSITY
RESEARCH LAB OUTSIDE OF A CLIA.
BUT IF A POOLED SAMPLE IS
POSITIVE FOR COVID EVERY
INDIVIDUAL IN THAT POOL WOULD
NEED TO BE TESTED THROUGH A
HEALTH SYSTEM. I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE BY RECOGNIZING MY FELLOW
OFFICERS IN THE UNITED STATES
PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICE
COMMISSIONED CORPS THE
UNIFORMED SERVICE THAT I LIED.
FOUR THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX OFFICERS HAVE
DEPLOYED TO SUPPORT THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE EXEMPLIFYING
THE CARE AND COMPASSION. THAT
ALL OF US FEEL FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE SUFFERED DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. I THANK EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF THESE OFFICERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND ON THEIR
BEHALF SINCERELY THANK ALL OF
YOU IN CONGRESS FOR SUPPORTING
OUR TRAINING NEEDS AND
ESTABLISHMENT OF A READY
RESERVE CORPS. TO SUPPLEMENT
OUR RANKS DURING INEVITABLE
FUTURE NATIONAL EMERGENCIES
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE THESE REMARKS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AT ROGER ONE OF
WELCOME DOCTOR HYDE. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN ALEXANDER RANKING
MEMBER MURRAY AND MEMBERS OF
THE HELP COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
VERY MUCH THE SUPPORT THE YOU
ARE PROVIDED- FOR EFFORTS
DURING THIS TIME OF COVID
NINETEEN. FDA HAS A VITAL ROLE
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC ONE OF
OUR CORE MISSIONS IS TO ADVANCE
THE PUBLIC HEALTH BY HELPING TO
SPEED MEDICAL PRODUCTS THAT ARE
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE. WE HAVE
PROVIDED APPROPRIATE REGULATORY
FLEXIBILITIES TO ASSURE THAT
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC HAS ACCESS
TO CRITICAL MENTAL
PROBLEMATICAL PRODUCTS. AND
SEAFOOD IN CONFIDENCE THAT OUR
DECISIONS ARE BASED ON MEDICINE
AND SCIENCE. SINCE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY WAS DECLARED
FDA HAS ISSUED MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATIONS FOR DIAGNOSTIC
TESTS PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT VENTILATORS OTHER
DEVICES AND DRUG PRODUCTS. AND
WE HAVE ISSUED MORE THAN FIFTY
GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS TO ENSURE
THE CONTINUITY OF HEALTHCARE IN
THE FOOD SUPPLY. I AM PLEASED
TO ANNOUNCE THAT TODAY FDA IS
TAKING ACTION TO AID THE TIME
TIMELY DEVELOPMENT OF A SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE VACCINE TO
PREVENT COVID NINETEEN. BY
PROVIDING GUIDANCE FOR
DEVELOPERS WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
ON THE DATA NEEDED TO
FACILITATE MANUFACTURING
CLINICAL DEVELOPMENT AND
APPROVAL. WE RECOGNIZE THE
URGENT NEED TO DEVELOP A SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE VACCINE TO
PREVENT COVID NINETEEN AND WE
WANT TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY
WITH INDUSTRY RESEARCHERS AND
OTHER PARTNERS TO ACCELERATE
THESE EFFORTS. WHILE THE FDA IS
COMMITTED TO HELP EXPEDITE THIS
WORK WE WILL NOT CUT CORNERS IN
OUR DECISION MAKING AND WE ARE
MAKING CLEAR IN OUR GUIDANCE
WHAT IS THE DAY THAT WE NEED
THAT SHOULD BE SUBMITTED. TO
MEET OUR REGULATORY STANDARDS
OF APPROVAL THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT AS WE
KNOW THAT. THEY HAVE A STRONGLY
ENCOURAGES THE INCLUSION OF ALL
THE DIVERSE POPULATIONS IN ALL
PHASES OF CLINICAL DEVELOPMENT
INCLUDING POPULATIONS MOST
AFFECTED BY COVID NINETEEN AND
SPECIFICALLY RACIAL AND ETHNIC
MINORITIES. AS WELL AS ADEQUATE
REPRESENTATION IN LATE PHASE
TRIALS OF ELDERLY INDIVIDUALS
AND THOSE WITH MEDICAL
COMORBIDITIES. WE ALSO HAVE
INFORMATION IN THIS GUIDANCE
ABOUT INCLUDING WOMEN WHO ARE
PREGNANT AS WELL AS FOR
PAEDIATRIC ASSESSMENTS OF
SAFETY AND EFFECTIVENESS.
AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD KNOW
THAT WE HAVE NOT LOST SIGHT OF
A RESPONSIBILITY TO MAINTAIN
OUR REGULATORY INDEPENDENCE AND
ENSURE THAT OUR DECISIONS
RELATED TO ALL MEDICAL PRODUCTS
INCLUDING COVID NINETEEN
VACCINES. ARE BASED ON SOUND
SCIENCE IN THE AVAILABLE DATA.
THIS IS A COMMITMENT THE OF THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC CAN HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN. AND THAT I WILL
CONTINUE TO UPHOLD PERSONALLY.
WELL THE ACSI RESEARCH IS
ONGOING RAPID TESTING AND
THERAPEUTIC DEVELOPMENT CAN
AIDE IN THE SAFE RETURN TO
SCHOOL COLLEGE AND THE
WORKPLACE. FDA IS CONSTANTLY
EVALUATING NEW DATA WE RECEIVE
ON TESTING SO THAT WE CAN
PROMOTE THE DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
AND BETTER TESTS AND REMOVE
TESTS THAT ARE NOT RELIABLE
FROM THE MARKET. AND WE HAVE
PUT INTO PLACE IN INITIATIVE TO
ACCELERATE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
TREATMENTS CALLED THE
CORONAVIRUS TREATMENT
ACCELERATION PROGRAM OR C. TAP.
WE'VE SEEN SOME OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT PROGRAM
SUCH AS THE AUTHORIZATION OF
RAM DOES APPEAR IN THE RECENT-
INFORMATION REGARDING OTHER
THERAPEUTICS THAT MIGHT BE OF
BENEFIT TO PATIENTS WITH COVID
NINETEEN. WE ARE WORKING DAY
AND NIGHT TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE
TO AND REVIEW PROPOSALS FROM
COMPANIES SCIENTISTS AND
RESEARCHERS WHO ARE DEVELOPING.
I'VE SEEN THIS INVOLVING
CRISIS. IT IS MISSION CRITICAL
THAT THE AGENCY CONSTANTLY
EVALUATE WHETHER OUR PROCESSES
ARE MAXIMAL TO PROMOTE AND
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
THEREFORE WE ARE BEGINNING A
COMPREHENSIVE REAL TIME REVIEW
AND ASSESSMENT OF OUR ACTIONS
TO DATE TO ADDRESS THE COVID
NINETEEN PANDEMIC PANDEMIC. AND
I'M GLAD TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT THAT REVIEW. I WANT TO
THANK THE MORE THAN SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND FTE EMPLOYEES WHO'VE
BEEN WORKING NIGHT AND DAY. TO
HELP EXPEDITE MEDICAL PRODUCTS
BUT ALSO TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY OVERSIGHT WITH THE
APPROPRIATE SCIENCE AND DATA.
WE KNOW THAT THE VIRUS REMAINS
WITH US. FDA IS COMMITTED TO
DOING THE CRITICAL WORK THAT
WILL GET THE COUNTRY TO THE
POINT AT WHICH AMERICANS JUDGE
IT'S SAFE TO RETURN TO WORK AND
SCHOOL. AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
I AM INCREDIBLY PROUD OF THE
DEDICATED WOMEN AND MEN OF THE
FDA WHOSE COMMITMENT TO
DEFEATING THIS PANDEMIC HAS
BEEN UNWAVERING. I CAN ASSURE
YOU THE FDA WILL CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE LEADERSHIP EXPERTISE
GUIDANCE AND INFORMATION. AS WE
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS IS
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGE AND TO
FILL OUR MISSION TO PROTECT AND
PROMOTE PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK
YOU AND APPRECIATE LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU DR
ON AND THANKS TO EACH OF OUR
WITNESSES WILL NOW BEGIN AROUND
THE FIVE MINUTE QUESTIONS. ALL
THE CENTERS ARE PARTICIPATING
TODAY ALMOST ALL AND SO I WOULD
ASK THE SENDERS AND WITNESSES
TO TRY TO KEEP EACH SEGMENT.
WITHIN FIVE MINUTES. DR FAUCI
ASSUME I'M SUPERINTENDENT OF
ONE OF FOURTEEN THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND IN OUR COMMUNITY
WE- WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
HEALTH RISKS. FOR CHILDREN-
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL. BUT WE'VE
CONCLUDED THAT THE RISKS OF. TO
THEIR EDUCATION MENTAL HEALTH
AND SOCIAL DEVELOPMENT IS A
GREATER RISK IF THEY DON'T GO
BACK TO SCHOOL SO WHAT WOULD
YOUR ADVICE BE TO A SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENT ABOUT WHAT. HE
OR SHE SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT
AS CHILDREN GO BACK TO SCHOOL
AND A FEW WEEKS TO KEEP SAFE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
MISTER CHAIRMAN IT IS AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION BUT I THINK
WE NEED TO POINT OUT. THAT IT
REALLY WILL. DEPEND ON THE
DYNAMICS OF THE OUTBREAK IN
THAT. LOCATION WHERE THE SCHOOL
IS. AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE
WANT TO EMPHASIZE AND HAVE BEEN
EMPHASIZING. IS TO TAKE A LOOK
AT WHERE YOU ARE IN THE
PARTICULAR. AREA OF THE SO
CALLED OPENING AMERICA AGAIN
ARE YOU AT THE GATEWAY PHASE
ONE PHASE TWO PHASE THREE. THE
CDC HAS GUIDELINES ABOUT THE
OPENING OF SCHOOLS AT VARIOUS
STAGES. OF THOSE CHECKPOINTS.
THE BASIC FUNDAMENTAL- GOAL
WOULD BE. AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN
TO GET THE CHILDREN BACK TO
SCHOOL. AND TO USE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EFFORTS AS A TOOL TO
HELP GET CHILDREN BACK TO
SCHOOL LET ME EXPLAIN WHAT I
MEAN. IN OTHER WORDS IF WE
ADHERE TO GUIDELINES OF WHAT
WE'VE HEARD IN MANY OF THESE
PRESENTATIONS YOU JUST HEARD.
ABOUT THE PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
THE COMMUNITY THE USE OF MASKS
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT WILL HELP
TO KEEP THE LEVEL OF INFECTION
IN THE COMMUNITY TAB WHICH WILL
THEN. MAKE IT EASY TO GET THE
CHILDREN BACK TO SCHOOL. IF YOU
ARE IN AN AREA. WHERE YOU HAVE
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF INFECTION
DYNAMICS. THERE ARE THINGS THAT
CAN CREATIVELY BE DONE ABOUT
MODIFYING THINGS LIKE THE
SCHOOL SCHEDULE ALTERNATE DAYS
MORNING VERSE EVENING ALLOWING
UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES. ON
LINE VIRTUAL LESSONS THOSE ARE
THE KIND OF THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO CONSIDER BUT ALSO
IMPORTANTLY ALWAYS MAKE THE
GOAL THAT IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO GET CHILDREN BACK TO SCHOOL.
FOR THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
OCCUR. WE KEEP THEM OUT OF.
THANK YOU DOCTOR REGISTER THE
ONE CERN'S. WOULD BE CHILDREN
WHO WHO GENERALLY SPEAKING DAY
NEARLY AS MUCH AS- ALL. ARE
JUDGE ELDERLY ADULTS. BY THE
SPOT OURS. MY THREE BUYERS
THIRTY. STRAIGHTER OR. PARENTS
OR GRANDPARENTS AT HOME. SEEMS
TO ME THAT THE AVAIL OF TREAT
THIS MAY FOR THE ADVISER SET
THE RISK OF SICKNESS AND DEATH
COULD BE VERY IMPORTANT IN
INCREASING CONFIDENCE IN GOING
BACK TO SCHOOL. YOU MENTIONED
SOME OF THOSE IN YOUR TESTIMONY
ARE THERE OTHERS WHAT WILL THE
AVAILABILITY OF TREATMENTS BE
THIS FALL. N. SPECIFICALLY WHAT
ABOUT SO CALLED ANYBODY
COCKTAILS OF THE KIND THAT WERE
DEVELOPED FOR EBOLA AND
APPROVED BY THE FDA. WELL I
THINK THAT BE A GREAT QUESTION
ALSO FOR DOCTOR FELT SHE- GONNA
MAKE IT SMALL STATEMENT HE MAY
WANT TO ADD TO IT CLEARLY WE DO
HAVE PROTESTS OF YOURS HE
MENTIONED WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE
OF STEROIDS CAN IMPROVE.
THERAPY AND AS YOU MENTIONED-
WE HAVE- CONVALESCENT PLASMA
THAT- STEVE ON COULD COMMENT ON
THAT SUIT THE USING THE
ANTIBODIES FROM INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE GOTTEN BETTER FROM
COVID- THAT ARE CURRENTLY UNDER
EVALUATION AND POTENTIALLY BE
AVAILABLE I HAVE JUST A MINUTE
DOCTRINE FEEL AT ME GO TO
DOCTOR ON AND LET HIM ANSWER
THAT QUESTION TOO. THANK YOU.
AS A AS I MENTIONED WHEN DOES
YOUR HAS BEEN AUTHORIZED BASED
ON ITS REDUCTION IN
HOSPITALIZATION DAYS. ON THE
STEROIDS WERE MENTIONED
CONVALESCENT PLASMA WE HAVE
EVALUATED THE SAFETY THROUGH A
LARGE X. ACCESS. AT THE MAYO
CLINIC AND IT'S BEEN FOUND TO
BE SAFE. OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
PATIENTS ADMINISTERED IT WE ARE
WAITING FOR THE SAFETY DATA-
AND WE WILL BE PASSING THOSE
STATE ALONG TO BARTER WHO'S THE
SPONSOR OF THAT PROGRAM- I
THINK. THAT THE BODY DATA WILL
HELP US IN TERMS OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
SPONSORS HAVE COME IN FROM
MONOCLONAL ANTIBODY STUDIES. ON
WE'RE ALREADY WELL INTO THAT
TREATMENT- MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES ARE SYNTHETIC
ANTIBODIES. THAT WILL PROVIDE
THAT THE THEORIES WILL PROVIDE
PROTECTION AGAINST THE
INFECTION OF THE VIRUS. AND
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THOSE
STUDIES BY THE LATE SUMMER
EARLY FALL WILL PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS AND SAFETY SO
YOU'RE OF OPTIMISTIC THAT THERE
WILL BE MORE THAN ONE TREATMENT
AVAILABLE THIS FALL FOR.
TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS OLDER
ADULTS YES SIR I'M OPTIMISTIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
MURRAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
ALL OF OUR WITNESSES WE'RE ALL
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
SERVICE IN YOUR WORK I'M DOCTOR
THOUGHT SHE LAST TIME YOU TEST
FOR TESTIFIED BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE YOU WARNED US OF
NEEDLESS SUFFERING AND DEATH OF
STATE BEGIN RE OPENING TO EARLY
AND JUST OVER A MONTH LATER NOW
WE ARE SEEING A RECORD NUMBER
OF CASES. WE DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH
TASKS AND WE DID NOT HAVE
ENOUGH CONTACT TRACERS AND JUST
YESTERDAY'S CDC'S DR SCHACHTER
SAID WE HAVE TOO MUCH VIRUS TO
CONTROL IN THE U. S. ARGUING
AND I QUOTE THIS IS REALLY THE
BEGINNING. OUR STORY HASN'T
WORKED I WANT TO ASK YOU. WHAT
DID THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
THE MORE THAN THIRTY STATES
WITH RISING CASE NUMBERS NEED
TO DO TO REVERSE THIS TREND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTION- SENATOR MURRAY I AM
ALSO QUITE CONCERNED. ABOUT
WHAT WE ARE SEEING OF ALL RIGHT
NOW IN SEVERAL OF THE STATES AS
YOU KNOW. AND FOR THE STATE'S
IN FLORIDA TEXAS CALIFORNIA AND
ARIZONA. MORE THAN 50% OF THE
NEW INFECTIONS ARE IN THOSE
AREAS WE'RE SEEING SURGEONS.
THE THINGS WE NEED TO DO I
THINK YOU ALLUDED TO IN YOUR
QUESTION TO ME WE'VE GOT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN STATE'S
START TO TRY AND OPEN AGAIN. TO
FOLLOW THE LINE. VERY CAREFULLY
LAID OUT. WITH REGARD TO
CHECKPOINTS. WHAT WE SEEN IN
SEVERAL STATES. ARE DIFFERENT
ITERATIONS OF THAT. PERHAPS
MAYBE IN SOME GOING TO QUICKLY
AND SKIPPING OVER SOME OF THE
CHECKPOINTS. BUT EVEN IN STATES
IN WHICH THE LEADERSHIP IN THE
FORM OF THE GOVERNORS AND THE
MAYORS DID IT RIGHT WITH THE
RIGHT RECOMMENDATIONS. WHAT WE
SAW VISUALLY AND CLIPS AND
PHOTOGRAPHS OF INDIVIDUALS IN
THE COMMUNITY DOING ALL THE NON
PHENOMENON. WHICH IS DANGEROUS
AND BY ALL THE NINE NINETEEN
EITHER BE LOCKED DOWN OR OPEN
UP IN A WAY WE SEE PEOPLE AT
BARS. NOT WEARING MASKS NOT
AVOIDING CROWDS NOT PAYING
ATTENTION TO PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. I THINK WE NEED TO
EMPHASIZE. THE RESPONSIBILITY
THAT WE HAVE BOTH AS
INDIVIDUALS. AND AS PART OF A
SOCIETAL EFFORT TO END THE
EPIDEMIC. THAT WE ALL HAVE TO
PLAY A PART IN THAT. AND I
THINK IF YOU LOOK AT THE
VISUALS WHAT WE STORE WHERE A
LOT OF PEOPLE. WHO MAYBE FELT
THAT BECAUSE THEY- I THINK THEY
ARE IN VULNERABLE AND WE KNOW
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE ARE NOT
BECAUSE THEY GETTING SERIOUS
DISEASE. THAT THEREFORE THEY'RE
GETTING INFECTED HAS NOTHING AT
ALL TO DO WITH ANYONE ELSE WHEN
IN FACT IT DOES. BECAUSE IF A
PERSON GETS INFECTED THEY MAY
NOT BE SYMPTOMATIC BUT THEY
COULD PASS IT TO SOMEONE ELSE.
WHO PASSES IT SOMEONE ELSE. WHO
THEN MAKES SOMEONE'S
GRANDMOTHER GRANDFATHER SICK ON
GOAL. OR LEUKEMIC CHILD ON
CHEMOTHERAPY GET SICK AND DIE
WE'VE GOT TO GET THAT MESSAGE
OUT. THAT WE ARE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER. AND IF WE ARE GOING
TO CONTAIN THIS WE'VE GOT TO
CONTAIN IT TOGETHER. WELL I
ASSUME THAT WOULD MEAN THAT
ELECTED AND COMMUNITY LEADERS
NEED TO MARKET PUBLIC. I HEALTH
BEHAVIOR AND WHERE MASS. WE
RECOMMEND MASKS TO EVERYONE ON
THE OUTSIDE ANYONE WHO COMES
INTO CONTACT IN A CROWDED AREA
YOU SHOULD AVOID CROWDS WHERE
POSSIBLE AND WHEN YOU'RE
OUTSIDE AND NOT HAVE THE
CAPABILITY OF MAINTAINING
DISTANCE YOU SHOULD WEAR A MASK
AT ALL TIMES. THANK YOU- DR
REDFIELD LAST WEEK DR JULIE
GERBERDING WHO SERVED AS THE
CDC DIRECTOR UNDER PRESIDENT
GEORGE. W. BUSH TESTIFIED TO
OUR COMMITTEE THAT IF SHE WERE
IN CHARGE ONE OF HER TOP
PRIORITIES WOULD BE THE
CREATION OF A NATIONAL VACCINE
PLAN. THAT ADDRESSES THE
SCIENCE DEVELOPMENT ALLOCATION
ACTIVATE AND MONITOR YOUR
VACCINE SAYING QUOTE WE KNOW
THIS IS IN OUR FUTURE AND WE
ARE NOT READY FOR IT. I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE AND THAT
PLAN HAS TO DETAIL HOW THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL SCALE
UP MANUFACTURING COORDINATE THE
SUPPLY CHAIN SO WE AVOID
MISSTEPS WE START TESTING NEEDS
TO COMBAT MISINFORMATION AND
VACCINE HESITANCY AND MAKE SURE
THAT VACCINE DISTRIBUTION.
ADDRESS HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
A LOT MORE I'M DOCTOR. DEGREE
OF OKAY. SENATOR I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A
INTEGRATED PLANNED FOR THIS
VACCINE. WHEN CAN WE EXPECT THE
ONE. WELL I'M GONNA ASK DR HAN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO COMMENT THAT I
NOTE RECENTLY THEY HAD A
VACCINE PLANNED FOR AT LEAST
FOR THE FDA'S PERSPECTIVE CDC
IS WORKING ON THE ISSUES THAT
YOU SAID THAT I THINK IS SO
IMPORTANT IN BUILDING VACCINE
COMPANIES COUNTRY CD'S HE WILL
BE GIVING US THEIR PLANTS AND
SEE SEE WOULD BE. WRITING THE
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN WILL WE'RE
DEVELOPING A PLAN AS AS WE AS
WE SPEAK IN AGAIN TO KEEP
BUILDING ON THE EFFORTS THAT WE
HAVE TO REBUILD WHAT I CALL
BACKS IN CONFIDENCE IN THIS
COUNTRY WHICH IS REALLY
CRITICAL AND THEN ON TOP OF
THAT THEY'LL BE A VERY DEFINED
PLAN FOR DISTRIBUTION OF THIS
VACCINE PRIVATIZATION OF THIS
VACCINE. MONITORING SAFETY WILL
BE FIXING LEAKS A COUPLE MONTHS
THE END OF THE YEAR IF YOU HAVE
ANY ASKED ON THAT. WELL IT
MILLION DEVELOPMENT WITH THE
GROUP. AND I HAD A INTO. THAT
WILLS THE CAESAR PLAN IN IN THE
NEAR WEEKS HEADS HEAD SENATOR.
WEEKS NOT. DAYS RANKS IN THE
WEEKS AHEAD IT'S A COLLECTIVE
EFFORT THAT WE'RE DOING
TOGETHER WITH THE CONCEPT OF
OPERATION MORE SPEED BUT CDC
NOT BEEN WORKING ON THIS PLAN
LITERALLY FOR PROBABLY THE LAST
TEN TO TWELVE WEEKS. I'M IS
CHAIRMAN I WOULD JUST SAY WE
NEED TO SEE THAT PLAN WE NEED
TO KNOW WHAT IT IS THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC NEEDS TO KNOW WHAT THAT
IS UNITY IS NEED TO KNOW WHAT
THAT IS- SO I HOPE THAT WE URGE
ON THAT PLANNED TO BE PUBLIC AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE SO WE ALL KNOW
WHAT TO EXPECT. THANK YOU
SENATOR MURRAY SENATOR BURKE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. AFTER
WORKING ON PANDEMIC POLICY NOW
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS I'M
REMINDED THIS MORNING. TONY
FELT SHE'S BEEN DOING IT TWICE
AS LONG AS I HAVE IN MOST OF
THE YEAR AT THE TIRES HAVE BEEN
DOING THAT AS WELL. I URGE MY
COLLEAGUES PAY ATTENTION TO
WHAT EACH OF THESE INDIVIDUAL
SAY. BECAUSE SOME THINGS ARE
PREDICTABLE UP HERE. CONGRESS
IS A FULL FLEDGED PARTNER FUNDS
THINGS WHEN. THERE'S AN URGENT
NEED A THREAT THAT'S OUT THERE.
AND I KNOW TONY YOU'VE SEEN
OVER THE YEARS WHEN THERE'S NOT
THAT THREAT OUT THERE. THINGS
GET SHELVED LIKE PLATFORMS.
THAT WE COULD HAVE DEVELOPED.
AND HAVE BETTER COUNTERMEASURES
TODAY. PLATFORMS THAT. THEN
COULD ADDRESS VACCINE TO A MUCH
FASTER PACE THAN MAYBE WHAT
WE'RE DOING BUT WE SPEND MORE
TIME WITH THE BLAME GAME- THAN
WE DO WITH FOCUSES ON HOW THE
FUTURE SHOULD LOOK. WHILE ALL
OF ITS MEMBERS CONGRESS AND
PEOPLE WITHIN GOVERNMENT WISH
THAT WE COULD GET BACK TO
NORMALCY. YOUR AGENCIES AND
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE ALSO
CHARGED WITH MAKING SURE THAT
WE MAP THE FUTURE SO THAT
FUTURE GENERATIONS HAVE BETTER
PROTECTIONS IN WHAT WE HAVE AND
THAT'S WHY I APPLAUD THE
CHAIRMAN. FOR HIS WHITE PAPER
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE EVERY
MEMBER OF THAT DIES TO BE
BRUTALLY HONEST WITH US ABOUT
WHERE CHANGES NEED TO BE MADE
AND WHERE THEY DON'T NEED TO BE
MIGHT. DR REDFIELD AT I THINK
WOULD AGREE WITH ME THAT.
TESTING AND SURVEILLANCE ON
THIS HAS NOT BEEN- THE BEST
PERFORMANCE BY CDC I DON'T WANT
TO DWELL ON WHERE WE'VE COME UP
SHORT. SHARE WITH LEADS MEMBERS
AND MYSELF. WHAT CAN WE EXPECT
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS
FROM CDC THAT WILL BE DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT THE PASTORS LOOKED
LIKE. THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
YOUR QUESTION- I THINK THE CDC
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
STATE LOCAL TRIBAL TERRITORY
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO BUILD
THEIR CAPACITY. I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT FOR DECADES- THERE'S
BEEN CONSISTENT UNDERINVESTMENT
IN PUBLIC HEALTH IN THIS NATION
AND THE CORE CAPABILITIES TO DO
THAT JOB. DATED DATA
MONETIZATION PREDICTED THAT IN
THE HOUSE'S LABORATORY
RESILIENCE WORK FORCE VERY
APPRECIATIVE FOR THEIR MERGER
RESPONSE FUND THAT- CONGRESS
BUT PROVIDED THESE ARE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES THAN
REALITY. HAVE BEEN UNDER
INVESTED YOU. IS NOW PROVIDE
5270% OF ALL PUBLIC HEALTH
OPENING EACH DAY. WE NEED TO
HAVE A MOVE MORE ROPE
INVESTMENT IN THESE CORE
CAPABILITIES WHAT YOU ARE GOING
TO SEE BECAUSE OF- THE CONGRESS
ACTING. CDC HAS. PROVIDED NOW
TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS TO THE
LOCAL STATE TERRITORIAL TRIBAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO BEGIN TO.
BUILD THAT CORE CAPABILITY THAT
WE WOULD HAVE LIKED TO BUILD
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL DECADES.
ALSO THAT THERE'S ENHANCED
TESTING IS BEEN MENTIONED IT'S
COMPLICATED HERE BECAUSE OF
OUR- IS STILL A SYMPTOMATIC FOR
SO MANY SO THE TRADITIONAL
METHODS OF THE HOUSES CONTACT
TRACING ISOLATION OR GET B. ON
HIM DID FOR MANY INDIVIDUALS
THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE.
BROADER COMMITTEE BASED BEILIN
STRATEGIES ON THOSE PLANS AS
WAS MENTIONED BY THE ADMIRAL R.
WE'VE RECEIVED FOR JUNE AND
JULY WERE WORKING WITH THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE HIM IN. MIDDLE JULY
THE PLANS FOR THE REST OF THE
YEAR AND WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING
SIDE BY SIDE WITH THEM TO
CONTINUE TO AUGMENT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AS A RESPONSE TO COPE
LARRY. WITH CLEAN. IT CAN'T BE
DONE. THANKS FOR IN OUR KITCHEN
TO BEGIN TO BRING BRING. ROLL I
HOPE SOME OF THAT MY WILL BE
YOU UP THE SO A CDC. THE ARE
ERIC. SIR I AGREE WITH YOU
THERE I MEAN I THINK IT AS
THOSE ARE IN WHEN I WAS GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS JOB.
EARLY ON WITHIN A MONTH I
RECOGNIZE THAT THE CORE
CAPABILITIES OVER PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT THERE
PARTICULARLY THE ONE THAT I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF DATA DATA
MODERNIZATION PREDICTIVE DATA
ANALYSIS. AND THAT IS IN
PROGRESS- IT CAN'T HAPPEN TOO
SOON. AND WE'RE APPRECIATIVE.
OF THE SUPPORT THE CONGRESS IS
GIVEN AND I DO THINK IT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY CRITICAL TO BRING
OUR- DATA SYSTEM AND IF YOU
KNOW THE DATA PERSONNEL THAT WE
HAVE AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS THERE. AND IT WE NEED
TO. HIRE THE END OF MR. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PREMIUM PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCY IN THIS COUNTRY
HAS THE PERSONNEL ON DATA
SYSTEMS THAT IT DOES THE BUT I
WILL SAY THE BIG- ISSUE WE HAVE
TO CORRECT THIS TO MAKE SURE
PUBLIC HEALTH STATE LOCAL
TERRITORY. TRIBAL THAT IT IT IT
HEALTH. THE YOUR FORTY ON THE
POP UP THAT IF YOU KNOW
EFFECTIVE. AND THE FDA'S REAL
TO THE DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND CUTTING TAPE IN MIND THEIR
GO STANDER FOR REVIEW OF LIFE
SAVING MEDICAL PRODUCTS YOU
SPECIFICALLY MENTIONED
INNOVATIVE TRIAL CLINICAL TRIAL
DESIGNS AND THE USE OF REAL
WORLD DATA AS AREAS WHERE THE
FDA HAS GAINED GROUND DURING
THE RESPONSE TO COVID. HOW DO
YOU PLAN TO ENSURE THAT THIS
PROGRESS IS MAINTAINED LONG
AFTER ROTAVIRUS OF RESPONSES
OVER A THINKCENTRE BURGER-
CRITICAL ISSUES THAT YOU BRING
UP IN ADDITION SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING ON THE
REVIEW SIDE TO ACTUALLY
EXPEDITE REVIEW AND WORK WITH
INNOVATORS AND DEVELOPERS WE
WILL CONTINUE. PART OF OUR
REVIEW OF OUR ACTIONS TO DATE
SO AMID ACTION REVIEW WILL
INFORM HOW WE BEFORE NOPE THE
FACT WE HOLD A- IN NOT. OF
STATE SYSTEMS ARE. AROUND
SUPPLY CHAIN. INTIMATE AND
ROMANTIC THANKS BUT ALSO THE
REVIEW CYCLE THE INNOVATIVE
CLINICAL TO TRIAL JUSTICE. YOU
FOR. YOU WERE A MEMBER WILL
DOCTOR FELT SHE HAD SOME TODAY
TO MAKE A COMMENTS THE RICK OF
A NEW FLU BUT THE HAVE OF.
APPARENTLY IDENTIFIED AND HOW
MIGHT OF US IN THE FUTURE ON MR.
WELL DR FELT YOU WANTED TO DO
THAT NOW HAVE YOU. HAVE
ANYTHING TO SAY ABOUT OF SWINE
FLU. THE CHINESE OVER THE LAST
WEEK OR TWO BUT HAVE IDENTIFIED
A VIRUS IN THE ENVIRONMENT IT
IS NOT YET. SHOWN TO BE
INFECTED HUMANS BUT IT IS.
EXHIBITING WHAT WE CORY
ASSORTMENT. CAPABILITIES IN
OTHER WORDS WHEN YOU GET A
BRAND NEW VIRUS THAT TURNS OUT
TO BE A PANDEMIC VIRUSES EITHER
DUE TO MUTATIONS AND OR THE RE
ASSORTMENT OF EXCHANGES OF
GENES AND THEY'RE SEEING VIRUS
IN SWINE IN PIGS NOW THAT HAVE
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE H. ONE N.
ONE. OF THE REGIONAL NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN WHICH MANY OF OUR FLU
VIRUSES HAVE REMNANTS OF THAT
IN IT AS WELL AS SEGMENTS FROM
OTHER HOSTS LIKE SWINE WHEN
THEY ALL MIXED UP TOGETHER AND
IT CONTAINS SOME OF THE
ELEMENTS THAT. THEM SUSCEPTIBLE
TO BE TRANSMITTED TO HUMANS YOU
ALWAYS THE POSSIBILITY THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE ANOTHER SWINE FLU
TYPE OUTBREAK AS WE GET INTO
THOUSAND NINE IT'S SOMETHING IT
STILL IS IN THE STAGE OF
EXAMINATION IT'S NOT SO COLD.
WE CAN FIX. SOME NEEDED OUR ON
ON THE WAY WE DID MENTION AND
NINE WITH AMERICAN OF THIS ONE
FLU HIS CALL G. FOR IS THE NAME
OF IT. THANK YOU SENATOR
SANDERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHAIRMAN AND LET ME THANK ALL
OF OUR PANELISTS FOR BEING HERE
AND FOR THE GREAT WORK WHAT
THEY ARE DOING ON THIS PANDEMIC.
OKAY LET ME ASK A QUESTION THAT
HAS JUST BOUGHT ME LATELY. ALL
OF YOU AND I THINK MOST
AMERICANS UNDERSTAND HOW
IMPORTANT SOCIAL DISTANCING YES
WE'RE TOLD OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THE CHAIRMAN TOLD US AT THE
BEGINNING IN THIS MEETING. STAY
ON TOP OF ME SIX FEET APART IF
YOU CAN'T. ARE IN JUST THE
OTHER DAY HOWEVER AMERICAN
AIRLINES ANNOUNCED- THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO FILL UP ALL OF
THEIR PLANS. ARE AND OTHER
AIRLINES HAVE DONE THE SAME SO
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE PEOPLE GOING
FROM NEW YORK TO CALIFORNIA
FIVE SIX I WAS. SITTING INCHES
APART FROM EACH OTHER. AND THEN
YOU GOT BUSES ALL OVER AMERICA
WITH PEOPLE ARE KIND OF PACKED
IN LIKE SARDINES. BUT MY
QUESTION IS WHAT. OF THE
GOVERNMENT WEATHER'S CDC OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
YOU SHOULD GO BLINDS
PROHIBITING THOSE VIBRATIONS.
OF WHAT WE ALL KNOW TO BE.
CONCEPTS ONCE THE ABOUT YOU
WANNA SPAWNER. THANK YOU SENATE
WELL I'M- I'M NOT THE CDC BUT
I'D BE HAPPY TO MAKE A COMMENT
ON THAT AND MAYBE BOB WOULD
ALSO. I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS OF CONCERN-
I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY WHAT WENT
INTO THAT DECISION MAKING. I
WOULD HOPE THEY WOULD BE
SOMETHING TO MITIGATE. AGAINST
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW AS WE SAID
AND I CONTINUE TO REPEATED.
THAT AVOIDING CROWDS STAYING
DISTANCE AND WHEN IN A
SITUATION LIKE THAT. WHERE A
MASK I THINK IN THE CONFINES OF
AN AIRPLANE THAT BECOMES EVEN
MORE PROBLEMATIC BUT GENERALLY
I AGREE I UNDERSTAND THE MASS.
BUT DOES THAT SOUND A LITTLE
BIT SILICON A LITTLE BIT IN
VIOLATION OF THANK YOU
PRESIDENT TALK ABOUT. STUFF
PEOPLE SITTING NEXT TO EACH
OTHER FIVE OR SIX. I WAS IN AN
AIRPLANE WALK CROWDED INTO A
BUS AND MY QUESTION IS WHITE
HOUSE OKAY ON THE PRESIDENT
ISSUES A LOT OF EXECUTIVE
ORDERS. WHAT HAPPENED TO STOP-
THAT TYPE OF ACTIVITY IN ALL
THE AIRLINES AND BUS BUT THAT.
THANK SENATOR APPRECIATE WHAT
AND NINETY IT'S A- IT'S A
CRITICAL AREA THANK TELL YOU
THAT WHEN THEY ANNOUNCED THAT
THE OTHER DAY. OBVIOUSLY THERE
WAS SUBSTANTIAL DISAPPOINTMENT
WITH AMERICAN AIRLINES. NUMBER
THE AIRLINE SAID DECIDED TO
KEEP THE MIDDLE SEEK THING. I
CAN SAY THIS IS UNDER CRITICAL
REVIEW RIGHT NOW- BY US AT CDC-
WE DON'T THINK IT'S THE RIGHT
MESSAGE. AS YOU POINTED OUT.
AGAIN WE THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE. IN WHETHER IT'S A BUS OR A
TRAIN OR PLANE. OR AT. SOCIAL
DISTANCING THAT AGREED IT'S
FEASIBLE AND AT LEAST. HAVE A-
BIBLE SCHOLAR IN SO- BOOK WELL
I. I JUST HOPE VERY MUCH. OF
THAT THE CDC IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE AGENCIES BASICALLY
TELLS. THESE COMPANIES THE DOT
IS UNACCEPTABLE BEHAVIOR
THEY'RE ENDANGERING THE LIVES
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE. LET ME
GO TO ANOTHER QUESTION I JUST
HAVE A FEW MORE QUESTIONS. BUT
NOT A LOT OF TOP SORT OF PRE
SHOULD BRIEF ANSWERS. ARE AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON.
OF THE- THE TWO OF HEALTH
THEY'LL- INDICATED THAT IF 95%
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WERE TO.
MASK WE COULD SEE SOME THIRTY
THOUSAND LIVES. WELL NUMBER OF
COUNTRIES INCLUDING. FRANCE.
TURKEY AND- BUT- RIGHT. WHAT
FOR FREE MASS TO ALL OF THE
PEOPLE THAT I BELIEVE WOULD YOU
SUPPORT A AFTER TWO GREAT
INCREASE THE OF HIKE MASS IN
THIS COUNTRY AND DISTRIBUTE
THEM FREE OF CHARGE TO EVERY
HOUSEHOLD IN AMERICA. OKAY I
THOUGHT YOU ALREADY BUT HE ALSO
WANTS TO JUMP IN ON THAT YES OF
COURSE I THINK MASKS IS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. AND WE
KEEP HAMMERING HOME YEAH AND I
THINK WHAT YOU JUST MENTIONED
THIS IS IMPORTANT THERE'S NO
DOUBT. THAT WEARING MASTS
PROTECTS YOU AND GETS YOU TO BE
PROTECTED SO IT'S PEOPLE
PROTECTING EACH OTHER ANYTHING
THAT FURTHERS THE USE OF MASK
WHETHER IT'S GIVING OUT FREE
MASTER ANY OTHER MECHANISM. I
AM THOROUGHLY FAVOR OF. AND I
JUST FEEL THAT THE SET. IN MY
OPENING. I AGAIN I CALL ON. AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE HAVE BEEN
REVERSAL MASK I THINK IT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY BUT MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO.
THAT'S GREAT BUT WHEN YOU.
REFER TO QUOTE UNQUOTE
UNIVERSAL MASKS WHICH ALREADY
AGREE WITH YOU ONE. WOULD YOU
BE SUPPORTING THE INCREASE
PRODUCTION OF HIGH QUALITY
MASTS AND BASICALLY
DISTRIBUTING FREE OF CHARGE.
OCT EVERY HOUSEHOLD IN AMERICA
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S GONNA
SAVE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF LIVES
WITH GREAT. THE SENATE
STANDARDS THIS IS A BRITISH WHY
I AGREED THAT THAT THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE NEED TO
SUPPORT MASK WEARING. I WOULD
ALSO POINT OUT THE DOCTOR
CADILLAC THE ASPER ON HIS
CONTRACT FOUR HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF CLOTH FACE
COVERINGS. THAT COULD BE
DISTRIBUTED AROUND THE COUNTRY
AND THE KINDS OF PROCESSES ARE
BEING THOUGHT UP- WHEN I'M NOT
IN UNIFORM I WOULD THERE WHITE
THEY WORK VERY EFFECTIVE AND I
THINK- YOU'RE A- GREAT
INVESTMENT FOR THE- PEOPLE.
GOOD THANK YOU MY VERY LAST
IT'S AN ISSUE I RAISED UP IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS. ALL
OF US HOPE THE GUARDS. THAT A
GOOD SAFE VACCINE WILL BE
DEVELOPED AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
ABOUT THAT VACCINE MAY NOT.
MEAN ANYTHING TO A LOW INCOME
PERSON WHO MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO
AFFORD IT. I HAPPEN TO BELIEVE
YOU SHOULD MAKE THESE VACCINES
AND BY THE WAY AS YOU ALL KNOW.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OUR TAX
DOLLARS. ARE GOING. TO THE TUNE
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO
DRUG COMPANIES TO HELP DEVELOP
THIS VACCINE THAT'S OKAY. BUT
DON'T YOU DO WOULD YOU AGREE
MATE AT AFTER THAT KIND OF
INVESTMENT WHICH ACTUALLY EVERY
AMERICAN. EVERY PERSON IN THIS.
AND GET VACCINE. REGARDING.
THEIR YUP I'M NOT I'M NOT. YES
SENATOR SENATOR YES SENATOR.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL MUCH. THANK
YOU SENATOR SANDERS SENATOR
PAUL. THANK YOU FATAL CONCEIT
IS THE CONCEPT THAT CENTRAL
PLANNING WITH DECISION MAKING
CONCENTRATED IN A FEW HANDS CAN
NEVER FULLY GRASP THE MILLIONS
OF COMPLEX INDIVIDUAL
INTERACTIONS OCCURRING
SIMULTANEOUSLY IN THE MARKET
PLACE. IT IS A FATAL CONCEIT TO
BELIEVE ANYONE PERSON OR SMALL
GROUP OF PEOPLE HAS THE
KNOWLEDGE NECESSARY TO DIRECT
AN ECONOMY OR DICTATE PUBLIC
HEALTH BEHAVIOR. I THINK
GOVERNMENT HEALTH EXPERTS
DURING THIS PANDEMIC HE TO SHOW
CAUTION IN THEIR
PROGNOSTICATIONS IT'S IMPORTANT
TO REALIZE THAT IF SOCIETY
MEETS SUBMIT TWO AND BIRDIES
EXPERT IS WRONG A GREAT
POWERMATIC. ALLOW ONE POLICY
ONE GROUP OF ALL THE MEN WERE
TWO FORCED ON AN ENTIRE NATION.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE GOVERNMENT
EXPERTS WHO CONTINUE TO CALL
FOR SCHOOLS AND DAY CARE TO
STAY CLOSED. OR THAT RECOMMEND
RESTRICTIONS THAT MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR A SCHOOL
FUNCTION. FOR A TIME THERE MAY
NOT HAVE BEEN ENOUGH
INFORMATION ABOUT CORONAVIRUS
IN CHILDREN. BUT NOW THE RIPS.
THEIR EXAMPLES FROM ALL ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES IN THE WORLD
SHOW THE YOUNG CHILDREN RARELY
DEVICE. LET'S IN YOUR- TWO TWO
COUNTRIES EUROPE THEIR SCHOOLS
AND IF NO DISCERNIBLE INCREASES
IN CASES. THESE GRASS BEHIND ME
SHOW NO SURGE WHEN SCHOOLS OPEN
THE RED LINE IS WHERE THE
SCHOOLS OPENED THERE IS DATA
FROM AUSTRIA BELGIUM DENMARK
FRANCE GERMANY NETHERLANDS NO
SPIKE WHEN SCHOOLS ARE OPEN.
CONTACT TRACING STUDIES IN
CHINA ICELAND BRITAIN AND THE
NETHERLANDS FAILED TO FIND A
SINGLE CASE OF CHILD TO ADULT
INFECTION. YOUR IN HOME
CHILDCARE FOR CENTRAL WORKERS
CONTINUE TO BE AVAILABLE IN
SOME STATES THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. BROWN UNIVERSITY
RESEARCHERS COLLECTED DATA ON
DAY CARES THAT REMAINED OPEN ON
THE PANDEMIC. ANY FIVE THOUSAND
KIDS IN THEIR JOURNEY. NOT
COVID AND WHEN YOU LOOKED AT
THE CONFIRMED CASES FOR STAFF
THERE WAS ABOUT 1% OF MORE THAN
NINE THOUSAND STAFF THE YMCA
ALSO HAS PUT FORWARD STATISTICS
FORTY THOUSAND ADULT EVAN
HUNDRED SITES THERE WERE NO
REPORTS OF CORONAVIRUS
OUTBREAKS OR CALL. DR BASHAR
STEINER BOBBINS RIGHTS THERE IS
CAN BUTTONS AT THE TONE OF THE
TRACK MIDDLE PART OF THAT IT IS
A LOWER. JUST YESTERDAY THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY A FEATURE OUT
MEDIA AFTER EXAMS WE GOTTA GET
KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL WE WANT
THEM PHYSICALLY BROTHERS IN
SCHOOL. EVEN SITES ALTOGETHER
THAT RUN ON LESS LIKELY TO
CONTRACT THE VIRUS. ULTIMATELY
ALL COMES DOWN TO THE FACE
CONCERN. THAT CENTRAL PLANNERS
HAVE ENOUGH KNOWLEDGE ON HOW TO
TELL A NATION OF THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION PEOPLE WHAT THEY
CAN AND CAN'T DO. PERHAPS OUR
PLANNERS MIGHT THINK TWICE
BEFORE THEY WEIGH IN ON EVERY
SUBJECT PERHAPS OUR GOVERNMENT
EXPERTS MIGHT HOLD THEIR TONGUE
BEFORE EXPRESSING THE OPINION
WHETHER WE CAN PLAY NFL
FOOTBALL OR MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL. NOT OCTOBER. OBSERVER
EXPERTS MIGHT THINK TWICE
BEFORE TELLING THE WHOLE WORLD
THE COVID VACCINE LIKELY WON'T
PROVIDE HERD IMMUNITY WE DON'T
KNOW WHY WHY WHY IN WITH THESE
OPINIONS THAT WE HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE OF THE FORECAST THAT
MAY WELL BE WRONG. PERHAPS OUR
EXPERTS MIGHT CONSIDER THE
UNDUE FEAR THEY'RE INSTILLING
IN TEACHERS WHO ARE NOW AFRAID
TO GO BACK TO WORK. NO ONE
KNOWS THE ANSWERS TO THESE
QUESTIONS WE SHOULDN'T PRESUME
THAT GROUP OF EXPERTS SOMEHOW
KNOWS WHAT'S BEST FOR EVERYONE
AND- HIGHER CREDIT RIGHTS ONLY.
CENTRALIZED POWER IN DECISION
MAKING BASED ON MILLIONS OF
INDIVIDUALIZED SITUATIONS CAN
ARRIVE AT WHAT RISKS AND
BEHAVIORS EACH INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD CHOOSE. THAT'S WHAT
AMERICA WAS FOUNDED ON. NOT A
HERD WITH A COUPLE OF PEOPLE
WASHINGTON ALL TELLING US WHAT
TO DO AND WE'D LIKE XI BLINDLY
FOLLOW. THIS ALL BEGS THE
QUESTION WHAT ARE WE GONNA TELL
THE PEOPLE THE TRUTH. THAT IT'S
OKAY TO TAKE THEIR KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL. DR VOUCHING. J.
VIRTUALLY EVERY DAY WE SEEM TO
HEAR FROM YOU THINGS WE CAN'T
DO WHEN YOU'RE ASKED CAN WE GO
BACK TO SCHOOL I DON'T HEAR
MUCH CERTITUDE ALL I HEAR WELL
MAYBE IT DEPENDS ALL OF THIS
BODY OF EVIDENCE ABOUT SCHOOLS
AROUND THE WORLD SHOWS NO
SEARCH ALL OF THE EVIDENCE IT'S
RARE I MEAN WITH SO LITTLE SIZE
THIS MAYBE POLITICALLY
CORRECTED THE W. H. UP POLICE
IS THAT IT'S REP I HAVE A
STATUES UP THERE ARE GIVING ARE
AND WHAT HAPPENS. SHE'S FORTY
FIRST TWO TAKE IT OFF THE WEB.
WHEN YOU GO THAT THE THAT SO.
SPEECH IN YOU AND TRY TO LET ON
THE LINK THE W. H. O. HAS NOW
SCREAMED IT FROM US BECAUSE IT
SAID SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
POLITICALLY CORRECT IT GUESS
WHAT. IT'S RARE FOR KIDS TO
TRANSMIT THIS I HEAR NOTHING OF
THAT COMING FROM YOU ALL I HEAR
DR FELL JUST WE CAN'T DO THIS
WE CAN'T DO THAT WE CAN'T PLAY
BASEBALL. PEAKS IN. WE DON'T
KNOW THE COVID IS GONNA BE LIKE
THE FLU SEASON IT MIGHT WE
DON'T KNOW THAT. BUT WE
WOULDN'T WE WOULDN'T VAN SCHOOL
IN OCTOBER. YOU MIGHT CLOSE
SOME SCHOOLS WHEN THEY GET THE
FLU WE NEED TO NOT ME NO SO
FROM SOME SHOES THAT WE KNOW
EVERYTHING. BUT MY QUESTION TO
YOU IS CAN'T YOU. IT'S A LITTLE
BIT MORE ON SCHOOLS THAT WE CAN
GET BACK TO SCHOOL THE- GREAT
DEAL OF THAT. SENATE ACTUALLY
GOOD GOOD EVIDENCE BEGINS OUR
TRANSMITTING THIS IS RARE. AND
THE KIDS ARE STAYING HEALTHY
AND IT YES WE CAN OPENERS. THE
J. DRIVE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME.
TO PLUG YOU A LITTLE. THAT IS
WELL OVER FIVE MINUTES WE'LL
YOU SELL IT. PLEASE THE
COLLAPSE VERY QUICKLY SENATE
POLL I AGREE WITH A LOT OF WHAT
YOU SAY ABOUT YOU KNOW THIS
IDEA ABOUT PEOPLE. HAVING TO
PUT THEIR- CANYONS OUT WITHOUT
DATA AND SOMETIMES YOU YOU HAVE
TO MAKE. EXTRAPOLATIONS BECAUSE
YOU'RE IN A POSITION WHERE YOU
NEED TO AT LEAST GIVE SOME SORT
OF RECOMMENDATION. BUT IF YOU
WERE LISTENING AND I THINK YOU
WERE TO MY OPENING STATEMENT.
AND MY RESPONSE TO ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I FEEL VERY STRONGLY
WE NEED TO DO WHATEVER WE CAN
TO GET THE CHILDREN BACK TO
SCHOOL. SO I THINK WE ARE IN
LOCK AGREEMENT WITH THAT. THE
OTHER THING THAT I LIKE TO
CLARIFY VERY BRIEFLY. IS THAT I
WHEN THINGS GET IN THE PRESS OF
WHAT I SUPPOSE IT SAID. DIDN'T
SAY THIS WEEK PLACE THIRTEEN
SPORT. HAPPENS IS THAT. IN THE
SPORT INDUSTRY THEY COULD
EITHER BE PEOPLE FROM. IN
OWNERS PEOPLE INVOLVE IN THE
HELL OF THE PLAYS ASKED ME
OPINIONS REGARDING CERTAIN
FACTS ABOUT THE SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS. WITH THE DYNAMICS ARE. I
GIVE IT AND THEN IT GETS
INTERPRETED THAT I'M SAYING YOU
CAN'T PLAY THIS SPORT YOU CAN
PLAY THAT SPORT. I AGREE WITH
YOU I AM CLEARLY UNQUALIFIED TO
TELL YOU WHETHER YOU CAN PLAY A
SPORT OR NOT. THE ONLY THING
THAT I CAN DO IS TO THE BEST OF
MY ABILITY GIVE YOU THE FACTS
AND THE EVIDENCE ASSOCIATED
WITH I KNOW ABOUT THIS OUTBREAK
THANK YOU. FOR ON THEIR HEARING
HIS GOLF OUT NOW GONE OUT ERIC
AC. MISTER CHAIRMAN VERY MUCH
FOR THE HEARING AND I WANT TO
THANK OUR WITNESSES FOR THEIR
PUBLIC SERVICE- MR CHAIRMAN LET
ME START WITH- DOCTOR HAN
THAT'LL MOVE TO. AMARO JUROR.
DR HOT I WANTED TO ASK YOU
ABOUT VACCINES AND IS YOUR
TESTIMONY INDICATES AND AS
WE'VE BEEN. DISCUSSING
OVERTIME- AS RESEARCHERS WORK
TO DEVELOP VACCINES JR PROTECT
AGAINST COVID NINETEEN. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE FINAL FDA
APPROVED PRODUCTS. HAVE THE
FULL CONFIDENCE OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. VACCINE DOESN'T HELP
THE PEOPLE DON'T CHOOSE TO IN
FACT BE VACCINATED. SO MY FIRST
QUESTION IS GIVEN THAT WE'VE
SEEN VERY HIGH RATES OF ALL
VACCINE REFUSAL AS WELL AS
SKEPTICISM WHAT ROLE CAN THE
FDA PLAY IN THE COMING MONTHS
TO EARN THE PUBLIC'S TRUST.
THAT THE COVID NINETEEN
VACCINES ARE SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
THAT'S QUESTION NUMBER ONE WHAT
ROLE THE AFTER ALL RIGHT AND
THEN THE SECOND QUESTION IS
WHAT STEPS CAN YOU TAKE AS FDA
COMMISSIONER. AFTER PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR THE QUESTION- I COULDN'T
AGREE MORE THAT OF PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN VACCINES IS SO
IMPORTANT SO TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO USE ALL OF OUR SCIENTIFIC
KNOWLEDGE A REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK TO ENSURE THAT ANY
VACCINE THAT COMES BEFORE US
WHETHER FOR AUTHORS OR APPROVAL
BEATS ARE STRINGENT STATE
RECIPIENT EFFECTIVENESS ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT WE ISSUED THAT
GUIDANCE THAT I MENTIONED IN MY
OPENING STATEMENT WAS PROVIDE
REGULATORY COSTS THREE AROUND
WHAT FDA EXPECTS WITH RESPECT
TO THOSE DATA WE WANT TO SEE
CERTAIN PARTS OF THOSE. OF CAN
DEMONSTRATE CALLED TO. AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT WE ARE FOLLOWING ON
STANDARDS WITH RESPECT TO
SAFETY AND EFFICACY. THE OTHER
THING THAT WE'VE DONE IS JOE
VERY BRIGHT LINE BETWEEN FDA IN
OUR REGULATORY INDEPENDENCE AND
ALL THE SPONSORS WERE PUTTING
FORTH- VACCINE APPLICATIONS TO
US. THAT INCLUDES OPERATION
WARP SPEED SO WE ARE PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THOSE
SPONSORS BUT WE ARE NOT PART OF
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS AND
WE WILL MAINTAIN OUR REGULATORY
INDEPENDENCE I WILL NOT PRE
JUDGE THE AGENCY WILL NOT
PREJUDGE ANY DECISION WITH
RESPECT TO THIS BUT WE WILL USE
THE SCIENCE AND THE DATA. WITH
RESPECT TO- WHAT I CAN DO
PERSONALLY SENATOR I COMMIT TO
YOU THAT I WILL CONTINUE TO BE
A VOICE EMPHASIZING REGULATORY
INTO WE NUMBER OF. GENES
IMPROPER TO A COMMUNICATE
COMPETE. THEY ARE ROOTED IN
DATA AND THAT THEY WILL ENSURE
THAT WE MEET THE- USUAL HIGH
STANDARDS OF FTA WITH RESPECT
TO SAFETY AND EFFICACY. THANKS
VERY MUCH DOCTOR MIGHT SUBMIT A
QUESTION FOR THE RECORD- TO
DOCTORATE FIELD AS WELL BUT
JUST SO I CAN GET MY SECOND
QUESTION AND- THE ADMIRAL ADD
ON ONE ASK ABOUT TESTING AND
INSURANCE COVERAGE. TESTING IF
YOU'RE KNOWN AS WE- EMPHASIZE
IN THESE HEARINGS IS SO
FUNDAMENTAL- IN ORDER TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF COVID
NINETEEN. CONGRESS I THINK-
ACTED ON THAT KNOWLEDGE BIDEN
BEING. COVERAGE ON COVID
NINETEEN DIAGNOSTIC IN IN ABOUT
OF STATE BOTH IN THE FAMILY
FIRST BILL AS WELL AS THE
CARRIAGE ACT. WE MADE IT CLEAR
THAT AMERICAN SHOULD HAVE TO
PAY A DIME. FOR COVID NINETEEN
TESTING. OVER HEARING ALARMING
REPORTS OF PEOPLE NOT BEING
TESTED. WELL OFTEN FOR ONE OF
TWO REASONS BECAUSE THEY'RE
UNDER THE IMPRESSION THEY WILL
HAVE TO PAY FOR TESTING.
PATIENTS WHO HAVE PASSED.
SHOULD GUIDE INSTEAD APPEARED
TO BE IN CONFLICT WITH
CONGRESSIONAL INTENT AND PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE. AND SO WE HAVE
SOME CONFUSION HERE I ASK YOU A
MOVE CAN YOU ASSURE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WILL FULFILL THE INTENT. OF
BOTH THE FAMILIES FIRST BILL IN
THE CARES ACT AND ENSURE THAT
AMERICAN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WILL BE- PROVIDED WIDE ACCESS.
TO COVID NINETEEN TESTS WITHOUT
COST. OR OR LIMITATION. SO
THANK YOU SENATOR AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
EMPHASIZING. THE IMPORTANCE OF
TESTING ELIMINATING ANY
BARRIERS THAT THERE COULD BE- I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE DEPARTMENT-
I CERTAINLY SPEAK IS THE
ASSISTANT SECRETARY AND IT
ASKING ISN'T THAT WE FIRMLY
BELIEVE AND SUPPORT. ON THE
CONCEPT OF NO COST TESTING
THERE SHOULD NOT BE A
DISINCENTIVE IN ANY SINGLE WAY
OUGHT TO GET THE DIAGNOSTIC
THAT YOU NEED I TO GET TESTED
DURING. IN HER CIRCLE- A OR OF
THE SEROLOGY TESTS AS CONGRESS.
INTO INTENT THANK YOU FOR THAT
WE DO TO KEEP GETTING THAT
MESSAGE OUT IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT ONE TO HAVE ON. THANK
YOU ALL THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU SENATOR CASEY SENATOR
COLLINS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN AND I WANNA THANK ALL
OF OUR WITNESSES TODAY FOR YOUR
DEDICATION AND HARD WORK IT'S
REALLY THAT IMPORTANT. DICK
CHAIRMAN GROUP IS A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION ABOUT WHO
PAYS FOR THE TESTING WHEN A
PERSON HAS NO SYMPTOMS AND NO
KNOWN EXPOSURE TO THE VIRUS AND
I WOULD ADD ANOTHER KEY
QUESTION AND THAT IS HOW WHAT
OURS JUDGE HAS EVEN ACCESS
THESE ARE CRITICAL QUESTIONS
FOR THE RE OPENING OF SCHOOLS.
AND POURED THOUSANDS OF JOBS IN
THE TOURISM INDUSTRY UPON WHICH
MEANS A CONSUMMATE. IN MAINE
FOR TAURUS TO COMMENT AND BIZ
SAID BAD OUT OF STATE VISITORS
ONE OPTION IS TO SHOW A RECENT
NEGATIVE COVID TATS THE PROBLEM
IS THAT WHEN HOTEL OWNERS IN
MAIN SURVEY TESTING SITES IN
TEN STATES THEY FOUND THAT 90%
OF REQUESTS FOR ATTACKS FOR
TRAVEL PURPOSES WERE DENIED. A
BIT SLAG QUEBEC ACCESS TO TESS
IS DEVASTATING FOR RE OPENING
BANDS TOURISM BUSINESSES ONE
INNKEEPER TOLD ME THAT LAST
YEAR IN THE MONTH OF JUNE SHE
HAD AN OCCUPANCY RATE OF 94%
THIS YEAR IT WAS EX PERCENT SO
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE IMPACT ON
EMPLOYMENT AT THAT END. GIVEN
THE IMPACT ON RIO SCHOOLS AND-
ON JOBS INVENTORIED CEMENT AND
OTHER INDUSTRIES HOW IS THE
BEDROCK GOVERNMENT WORKING WITH
STATE TO BETTER MATCH DEMAND
FOR AS THING WITH WHY AM TO
OVERCOME GOP. VARIATIONS
ADMIRAL I WOULD DIRECT THAT
QUESTION. TO YOU. SINCE THANK
YOU MA'AM I WILL TRY TO BE
BRIEF AND NOT TO TAKE MY TIME
BUT WE WERE VERY CAREFUL IN OUR
PRIORITIZATION THAT WE DO
PRIORITIZE PERSONS WITHOUT
SYMPTOMS WHO ARE PRIORITIZED BY
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
CLINICIANS FOR ANY REASON
INCLUDING PUBLIC HEALTH
MONITORING SURVEILLANCE OR
SCREENING OF OTHER A
SYMPTOMATIC INDIVIDUALS.
ACCORDING TO STATE LOCAL
PLANNED SO THAT IS A PRIORITY
THAT IF IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
STATE DOES A SYMPTOMATIC
INDIVIDUALS. B. CAN BE. THE
SECOND ISSUE JUST AGAIN TO BE
BRIEF IS WE WORK WE WORK
INDIVIDUALLY WITH EVERY SINGLE
STATE- TO DETERMINE WHAT THEIR
STATE TESTING NEEDS ARE-
HOWEVER THE ORGANIZING IT IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE CDC ON IN WE
ARE SUPPLYING THEM WITH THE
SUPPLIES THEY NEED TO MEET THAT
SO EVERY WEEK SHIPMENTS OF THE
BASIC SUPPLIES GO TO EVERY
SINGLE STATE ACCORDING TO THE
STATE TESTING PLANS AND WE KEEP
A LITTLE BIT IN RESERVE RIGHT
BECAUSE WHEN THEY WERE OUT
SOMEWHERE WE NEED. URGES WE
HAVE THAT SO FOR EX. TEST FOR
JULY. OR SOME UP A THE COUNTRY
ABOUT THIRTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION TEST IS OUR FIRST LINE
GOALS AND WE WEEK WE WILL MATCH
THOSE STATE BY STATE. I HOPE
THAT YOU WILL HELP US GET THAT
WORD OUT TO TESTING SITES IN
STATES THAT HAVE FROM WHICH A
LOT OF TOURISTS USUALLY COME TO
MAIN. AT THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL TO US. OUR JACK JR
BELCH LET ME TURN TO YOU
EARLIER THIS MONTH HIGHER
EDUCATION LEADERS THE MAIN
ISSUE THAT FRAMEWORK FOR SAFELY
RETURNING TAKE CAMPUSES SAYS
PAUL. THAT RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF TESTING AND THE
NEED TO INCLUDE FINANCIALLY
STRUGGLING INSTITUTIONS IN
PARTNERSHIPS IN ORDER TO MAKE
SUFFICIENT TESTING PROTOCOLS
POSSIBLE. IF YOU LAST WEEK
SPOKE ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
THE DEVELOPMENT OF POOL TESTING
STRATEGIES AND AS I UNDERSTAND
THIS BUT THIS WOULD ALLOW MORE
PEOPLE TO BE TESTED USING FEWER
RESOURCES AND THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR OF STANFORD'S CLINICAL
BAYROCK VIROLOGY LAB. SUGGESTS
THAT THIS MAKES PARTICULAR
SENSE IN AREAS WITH LOW RATES
OF COVID NINETEEN WHERE YOU
WOULD EXPECT THE LARGE MAJORITY
OF TESTS TO BE NEGATIVE COULD
YOU EXPAND ON THE POSSIBILITY
OF EXPANDING HOLDS HAS THING
AND TELL US MORE ABOUT THAT YES
THANK YOU FOR THE KITCHEN
SENATOR WHAT THAT REALLY IS IF
YOU WANT TO GET A FEEL FOR THE
PANIC. OF INFECTION IN THE
COMMUNITY RATHER THAN TESTING
MULTIPLE EACH INDIVIDUAL PERSON
WHICH TAKES RESOURCES AND TIME
WHAT YOU DO AND YOU CAN DO IS
THE **** ANALYSIS OF NOT LOSE
SENSITIVITY BY PULLING LET'S
SAY TEN OR FIFTEEN OR FIVE.
YEAH SO YOU ALL THE TESTS
TOGETHER AND YOU DO ONE TEST.
IF THAT TEST IS NEGATIVE THEN
YOU KNOW THOSE TEN PEOPLE ARE
ALL NEGATIVE SO INSTEAD OF
UTILIZING TEN TESTS UTILIZE ONE
TEST. THEN YOU GET ANOTHER
BATCH OF WAS SAY TEN OR SO AND
IF YOU THEN FIND ONE IS
POSITIVE THEN YOU GO BACK TRACK
AND FIGURE OUT WHO THAT PERSON.
IF YOU DO THE MATHEMATICAL
CALCULATION YOU CAN SAVE A LOT
OF TIME A LOT OF RESOURCES AND
USED TO TEXTING. OF WRITING
ABOUT THE THINGS THAT YOU WOULD
NEED SO IT'S A REALLY GOOD
SCHOOL IT CAN BE USED IN ANY OF
A NUMBER OF CIRCUMSTANCES AT
THE COMMUNITY LEVEL OR EVEN IN
SCHOOL IF YOU WANTED TO DO. AT
THE POLL WHAT YOU STARTED
COMMON OFF WITH IT CLEARLY CAN
BE EXTRAPOLATED TO THAT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THAT SOUNDS LIKE AN
EXCELLENT TECHNIQUE FOR OUR
SCHOOLS TO USE. THANK YOU
SENATOR COLLINS SENATOR BALDWIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF OUR
WITNESSES TODAY OR JOINING US-
LIKE SO MANY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
NEW OUTBREAKS AND INCREASING
CASES CERTAINLY I'VE SEEN THEM
IN MY HOME STATE OF WISCONSIN
AND I KNOW WE'RE SEEING THAT
NATIONALLY. NOW CDC AT OSHA
HAVE ISSUED OUT RECOMMENDED
SAFETY GUIDANCE FOR BUSINESSES-
BUT THIS GUIDANCE IS NOT
ENFORCEABLE MANY BUSINESSES ARE
TRULY TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND PROTECTING WORKERS
CUSTOMERS IN THE PUBLIC AND
INTERACT WITH THOSE BUSINESSES.
I'M AND SO I WE ALSO HAD A
PREVIOUS DISCUSSION I THINK
THAT SENATOR SANDERS RACE THE
ISSUE OF A MAYOR AIRLINES
FILLING THEIR PLANES VERSUS ON
THAT ARE ALL RIGHT STILL NOT
TRYING TO PUSH TO DO SO-
BECAUSE OF SAFETY CONCERNS WE
ALSO HAD OUR I THINK IT SHOULD.
HOLD UP THE I WHEN WE CRITICAL
DIED. ALL OF THIS CREDIT GUY SO
GARDNER RENTAL SHOULD. BUSINESS
IS THAT CAN LIST CHECKER VERSE
BY FULLY IMPLEMENTING CD AT
OCEANS RECOMMENDED SAFETY
GUIDANCE. YESTERDAY YES WHICH
IS WHY THOSE BILL. NOW CAN YOU
CONFIRM YES SIR NO THAT ALL
BUSINESS HAVE A DAY AND
IMPLEMENTED THIS GUIDANCE AS
THEY OPENED UP. I THINK SENATOR
YOU KNOW THAT UNFORTUNATELY
THAT'S NOT BEEN THE CASE. SO
IT'S AN UNEVEN PLAYING FIELDS
IT HURTS BUSINESSES THAT ARE
TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING BY
VOLUNTARILY ADOPTING CDC AT
OCEAN SAFETY GUIDELINES-
BECAUSE THEIR COMPETITORS DON'T
HAVE TO AND KIRK THE SAME
SAFETY AND HEALTH COSTS. AND IF
YOU BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD BE
SUPPORTING THE GOOD ACTORS THEN
SHOULDN'T WE CREATE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD BY ISSUING AN
EMERGENCY TEMPORARY STANDARD TO
REQUIRE ALL BUSINESSES TO ADOPT
AND COMPLY WITH ENFORCEABLE
SAFETY STANDARDS. ME TOO
COMMENTS SENATOR FIRST ONE IS
SO IMPORTANT THAT WE TRIED TO
SAY. MMHM IS THAT THIS IS A
TIME THAT EVERYONE IN OUR
NATION ACCEPTED. THE DOCTOR
FELT UNITED SPOKE ABOUT TO
RECOGNIZE THEY HAVE THE
FUNDAMENTAL RESPONSIBILITY NOT
JUST TO PROTECT THEMSELVES TO
PROTECT OTHERS BY THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING HIS MASK AND HAND
WASHING. AND SECONDLY- AGAIN AS
WE LOOK AT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AGAIN TO SEE
WHERE IN FACT THAT
ENFORCEABILITY WOULD BE WHETHER
IT'S IN THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT THE STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT OF THE FEDERAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. I THINK YOU
KNOW AGAIN. WE SEE THE
COMMUNITY CAN GET BEHIND THAT
RESPONSIBILITY- THOSE
BUSINESSES THAT SUPPORT THAT
RESPONSIBILITY MAY FIND IN FACT
THEIR BUSINESS IS BETTER THAN
THOSE BUSINESSES THAT DON'T I
CAN TELL YOU THAT HE- TRIED TO
I APOLOGIZE DR REDFIELD- BUT MY
TIME IS LIMITED- D. I. THE
PANEL RIGHT NOW IS COMPOSED OF
PEOPLE REPRESENTING PUBLIC
HEALTH AND- PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTION. I'M OSHA IS OUR
LEAD AGENCY EIGHT AT PROTECTING
WORKERS D. AND HELL HAVE YOU I
HAD COMMUNICATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. SHOT OUT ISSUING
MANDATORY. ENFORCEABLE ALL.
STAY ON THAT THIS VOLUNTARY GUY.
SECRETARY SCHOOL IS MEMBER OF
THE- TASK FORCE AND HE'S IN THE
DISCUSSIONS WITH US ON THAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT- CHAIRS- THAT
SPECIFIC TOPIC YES WE HAVE NOT
HAD A DISCUSSION DIRECTLY BUT
WE HAVE HAD DISCUSSIONS AND
REVIEW OF THE GUIDANCE THAT WE
PUT TO- BUSINESSES BOTH
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND NON
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
BUSINESSES WITH THE- OCEAN. I'M
SO I. I HAVE ON LIMITED TIME
LEFT BUT I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
THE UNIVERSITY WISCONSIN
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY WILL BE RE
OPENING FOR CLASSES IN THE FALL
THEY LOOK RELEASED A PLANNED
CALLS START OUT SMART RESTART
IT CALLS FOR ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
TESTS PER WEEK ON CAMPUS
THEY'LL NEED SUPPLIES TO DO
THIS INCLUDING PP REAGENTS ON
CPOPS AT EVERY HEARING ON COVID
NINETEEN WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
SHORTAGES OF THESE FLIGHTS AND
IT'S WHY I INTRODUCED THE
MEDICAL SUPPLY TRANSPARENCY
DELIVERY ACT TO. UNLOCK THE
FULL AUTHORITY OF THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT TO INCREASE
PRODUCTION OF CRITICAL SUPPLIES
AND THE THINGS THAT ARE NEEDED
TO CONDUCT WIDESPREAD TESTING
ADMIRABLE IF YOU ARE CAN YOU
DESCRIBE HOW YOU'RE WORKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR UNIVERSITIES
AND OTHERS WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SUPPLIES NEEDED TO CONDUCT
THIS TESTING IN THE FALL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SENATOR- IT AND I
WANT TO COMMUNICATE THIS BIG
AND I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH ANY
UNIVERSITY ON WE COORDINATE
WHAT WE GIVE TO THE STATES TO
THE STATE PLAN SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT UNIVERSITY-
COORDINATE TO THE STATES AND WE
SUPPLY THOSE MATERIALS DIRECTLY
TO A SINGLE POINT OF CONTACT IN
THE STATE WHO DISTRIBUTES THEM
ON WE YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH A LOT. WE HAVE A LOT OF
SPOTS NOW- PARTIALLY BECAUSE OF
INCREASED DOMESTIC PRODUCTION
USING THE DPA WE'RE
DISTRIBUTING ABOUT TWENTY
MILLION SWAPS PER MONTH WE'RE
GONNA DO A LOT MORE THAN THAT
IT'S- SO REAGENTS WE DO NOT
PURCHASE CENTRALLY BECAUSE THE
MARKET IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
MATURE SO WE CAN TRUST WITH AN
ALLOCATION STRATEGY THAT WE
ALLOCATE WE SUPPORT THE
ALLOCATION TO DIFFERENT STATES
DEPENDING ON THEIR NEEDS. SO WE
HAVE TO EVERY SINGLE MACHINE
EVERY SINGLE EVERY SINGLE COUNT
EVERY SINGLE CITY. AN
UNFORTUNATE. AT SO WE REALLY A
MATCH GAME TO. SPECIFIC STATE
NEEDS EXAMPLE IN THE LAST. IT
IS VERY ROLL AND THERE'S VERY
LIMITATIONS TO WHAT THEY HAVE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY GET
WHAT THEY ABSOLUTELY NEED
VERSUS OTHER STATES THAT CAN BE
A LITTLE BIT MORE FLEXIBLE SO
WE DO ON. THIS IS VERY MUCH YES
I'M AFRAID WE'RE I'M SO SORRY
WELL OVER WELL OVER TIME WE
HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF SENATORS
WHO WANT TO ASK QUESTIONS SO I
WOULD RENEW MY CHESTER CHECK
REQUESTS THAT THE SENATORS AND
WITNESSES TRY TO KEEP THE
QUESTION. ANSWERS WITHIN.
WITHIN FIVE MINUTES. OUR
SENATOR CASSIDY. I THANK THE
GENTLEMAN FOR ALL THAT YOU'RE
DOING. I HAVE A COUPLE SLIDES
CAN YOU SHOULD ASK THE STAFF TO
SHOW THE FIRST RESULTS. ALSO
HERE IT SHOWS THAT. WE'RE DOING
POORLY RELATIVE TO THE
COUNTRIES THAT ARE DOING THE
BEST AND YOU CAN ARGUE THE
TAIWAN IS MUCH SMALLER THAN
WEEK THE TAIPEI AS A VERY
CONGESTED CITY. SIR CAN SET OUR
OUR CITY JUST COLLECTION OF
TAIPEI'S FOR EXAMPLE THEN OUR
SOUL CAROUSEL THREE AS IT WAS
JUST THE WORLD WE ARE CURRENTLY
DOING IS LESS- ROBUST. AND
LESS- WHATEVER ADJECTIVE YOU
WANT TO USE IN THE COUNTRIES
THAT ARE DOING THE BEST THAT I
THE NEXT LIKELY. AND SO THIS IS
THE BLOCKED OUT OF A GROUP BY A
HARVARD IN JUST SO I CAN PUT A
PLUG IN IT- THEY WILL BE
SPEAKING IN A ROUND TABLE WE
HAVE THURSDAY MORNING. AND YOU
CAN GET DETAILS MY OFFICE IF
YOU WISH BUT YOU KIND OF THAT
INTERPLAY BETWEEN COLLECT KEEP
DOING THE TESTING- TRACY THOSE-
YOU KNOW COMPILING YOUR DATA
NORMAL YOU'RE HOT SPOTS OR IN
TRACY. AND EVERYONE ON THIS
PANEL KNOWS SOUNDS DONE- AND
YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE A STRATEGY THAT'S
COMING OUT LATER ON- IT DOES
BEG THE QUESTION WHY HAS IT
BEEN SO LONG AND I'M NOT
ACCUSING JUST. SURE THIS BEEN
DEVELOPED YOU CAN TAKE A SLOW
DOWN. PLEASE SO KNOWING THAT
YOU'RE TO DEVELOP THE STRATEGY-
AND KIND OF BILLABLE AND
SENATOR BYRD MENTIONED. WHAT IS
THE GOAL OF THE STRATEGY. IS
THE GOAL OF THE STRATEGY TO
ACHIEVE SUPPRESSION- THAT'S
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO WHAT
METRICS WILL YOU USE. AND
FOLLOWING THAT CDC IS THE ONE
WHO REALLY GIVES GUIDANCE TO
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
I'M HOPING DR REDFIELD'S OF
RECORDS TO YOU. THAT I WON'T BE
UP TO THE STATES AND LOCALS TO-
PUT THIS PLAN TOGETHER. THAT'LL
BE THE CONSIDERABLE
INTELLECTUAL FIREPOWER OF THE
CDC. THEY GIVES A PRETTY
DETAILED IF YOU HAVE THIS KIND
OF COMMUNITY THIS IS WHAT YOU
DO. IF YOU HAVE THAT A
COMMUNITY THAT IS WHAT YOU DO-
BECAUSE THAT'S THE KIND OF
ROLES IF YOU SEEK TO EXPECTED.
LIKE DR REDFIELD. ANY THOUGHTS
ON THE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A
VERY IMPORTANT. FIRST ON YOUR
FIRST LIFE JUST AS A QUICK
COMMENT I'LL TRY TO BE QUICK. I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T ILLUSTRATE
BACK TO THE COMMENT THAT WE
TRIED TO MAKE OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY. TO
REALLY PRACTICE THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND THAT IS A GOOD
DIET DR REDFIELD ON ASK YOU
JUST TO GO QUICKLY BECAUSE I'VE
LIMITED TIME. THAT'S A GIVEN
BUT THERE HAS TO BE A TESTING
ASPECT OF THIS. BECAUSE PEOPLE
DON'T YOUR WAKING PEOPLE TO THE
RESPONSIBILITY IF THEY KNOW
THEY'VE BEEN EXPOSED. IF THEY
DON'T KNOW THEY'VE BEEN EXPOSED
THEY TEND TO BE MORE COMPLACENT
SO PLEASE FOCUS UPON THE
TESTING DATA AND TRACKING US
BUT YES SENATOR. AND IT THE
SECOND WAS A- EARLY CASE
IDENTIFICATION CONTACT TRACING
ISOLATION OBVIOUSLY BE A
TESTING CONTACT TRACING WITHOUT
ISOLATION HAS LITTLE ARE YOU.
THE CHALLENGE BEEN WHEN WE
LEARNED IN MARCH THAT THE VIRUS
IS SIGNIFICANTLY
SYMPTOMATICALLY- TRIPS
MISERABLE THEN THEREFORE
REQUIRING ALTERNATIVE
STRATEGIES THE. STRATEGY THAT
WE'RE- THE VALUE NOW OF A
COMMUNITY LED TESS STRESS WERE
GO INTO A BROADER K. YOU
ACTUALLY TEST A WIDE GROUP
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS. AS
OPPOSED TO WHAT YOU HAVE WHAT
METRICS ARE YOU FOLLOWING IT IS
THERE A SPECIFIC STRATEGY
THAT'S GOING TO BE GIVEN THE
STATE LOCALS HOW TO IMPLEMENT
THIS THAT'S VERY HIGH LEVEL
WHAT WE NEED IS GRANULARITY
THAT'S MY QUESTION HERE WHICH
WE DID THE INITIAL STRATEGY IT
IS A SAID WE'RE CURRENTLY
EVALUATING THIS COMMUNITY TEST
LEAD STRATEGY. IN A NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES AND- THE METRICS
ARE SIMPLE IT'S THE PERCENT
CASES THAT ARE POSITIVE. WE
WERE DOING WELL THERE FOR A
WHILE YOU KNOW THEY ASK AGAIN
START INTERRUPT THAT BUT ITS
COURSE IF YOU TAKE THE ENTIRE
CITY OF NEW ORLEANS OR
SHREVEPORT- YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE SOME THAT ARE HOT SPOTS
AND SOME THAT ARE REALLY FAIRLY
SAFE. AND SO I'M GUESS I'M
POINTED TO THE GRANULARITY YOU
KNOW SHOULD BE A CENSUS TRACT
SHOULD BE A HOT SPOT A
BUILDING. WITH MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING- EX GENERALS. JUST
BECAUSE ONE TO MY STATE LAW.
THERE NOT GET THAT GREAT. FROM
C. THAT SEEMS TO BE WHERE WE
GET TO WHERE SEOUL SOUTH KOREA
IS. AND I'VE NOT YET HEARD THAT
IS KIND OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
WE'RE SHARING RIGHT NOW AT THE-
COUNTY LEVEL THE EXACT KINETICS
WE ABOUT A HUNDRED THIRTY
COUNTIES IN THIS COUNTRY OUT OF
THE MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND. OF
MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND ARE
HAVING TROUBLE. AND CONTINUING
TO GET THAT GRANULARITY I THINK
YOU SAID IT SENATOR IT'S
CRITICAL IT'S GONNA BE A VERY
LOCAL FOCAL RESPONSE AT THE
GRAND OLE LEVEL WITH. THE DR
REDFIELD'S WHO WE HAVE
REGULARITY WE'VE BEEN AT THIS
FOR THREE MONTHS WE GOT ALL
THESE DATA SYSTEMS WE KNOW
WHERE THE PEOPLE LIVE WERE
TESTED- YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
FEDERATED SYSTEM WHICH YOU
ALLUDED TO EARLIER- IS THE PLAN
COMING OUT TONIGHT. THIS
AFTERNOON GOING TO IMPLEMENT
THAT GRANULARITY. ON OVERTIME
BUT IF YOU WOULD ALLOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR AN ANSWER THEN
I'LL ALSO USE ON ALL OF US ONE
OF. HIM IN MY COMMENT WOULD BE
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GOING WITH
THAT GRANULARITY WE APPRECIATE
SOME OF THE CHANGES REPORTING
THE CDC IN TERMS OF TESTING
THAT CONGRESS RECENTLY DID. A
WE ARE NOW LOOKING AT THE
GRANULAR LEVEL WE DON'T
DISAGREE WITH THE PREMISE
BEHIND YOU. IT'S THAT GRANULAR
RESPONSE TO CONTROL THOSE MANY
OUTBREAKS WHICH IS GOING TO BE
FUNDAMENTAL. TO GET THIS UNDER
CONTROL. THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATE CASSIDY'S. MURPHY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN. MR
CHAIRMAN. IF THIS WERE THE
POLICY OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
GUIDELINES BEING GIVEN BY OUR
PANELISTS TODAY. WE WOULD
LIKELY NOT BE IN THE SITUATION
WE ARE WITH A VIRUS BACK ON THE
MARCH SPREADING AT RAPID RATES
THROUGHOUT BIG PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY. THE PROBLEM IS OUR
FOUR PANELISTS DO NOT SET THE
POLICY OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES DOES. AND SO WELL
OUR PANELISTS TELL US ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF WEARING MASKS.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS RETWEETING ARTICLES
FOR EXAMPLE IN TITLED.
MANDATORY MASKS AREN'T ABOUT
SAFETY THERE ABOUT SOCIAL
CONTROL. HE RETWEETS. PEOPLE
THAT ARE CRITICIZING HOW FOLKS
LOOK WHEN THEY WEAR MASKS.
THERE ARE PANELS TODAY ARE
TELLING US ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING. THE PRESIDENT I'D
STATES IS HOLDING RALLIES ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN WHICH HE
DELIBERATELY PREVENTS PEOPLE.
FROM DISTANCING HIS STAFF RIPS
SIGNS OFF OF CHAIRS ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TO SEPARATE FROM EACH
OTHER. THE PRESIDENT'S ALLIES
ARE OUT THERE ON TV EVERY DAY
SAYING THAT WEARING MASKS OR
DEHUMANIZING. SOMEBODY SAID THE
OTHER DAY A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
THAT VIRUSES DO IT VIRUSES DO
THE ONLY WAY YOU'RE GONNA GET
IMMUNITY IS TO GET EXPOSED.
THESE ARE THE PRESIDENT'S
ALLIES TRYING TO CURRY FAVOR
WITH HIM. AND SO WE HAVE THESE
TWO PARALLEL MESSAGING
OPERATIONS AND I JUST THINK
IT'S WORTH STIPULATING HAPPY-
EVERYTHING WE'RE HEARING TODAY
IS RESPONSIBLE IS BASED ON
EVIDENCE. BUT THE AGENCIES
REPRESENTED HERE TODAY HAVE
SOCIAL MEDIA FOLLOWINGS OF
ABOUT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE.
RESIDENT I STATES AS A SOCIAL
MEDIA FOLLOWING OF EIGHTY TWO
MILLION. ERIC AND SO YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND WHY FOLKS ARE
CONFUSED OUT THERE THEY HEAR
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM DOCTOR
FETCHING DR REDFIELD BUT THEN
THEY HEAR THE PRESIDENT I'D
STATES CRITICIZING REPORTER FOR
WEARING A MASK BECAUSE THAT
REPORTERS BEING SOCIAL IS BEING
POLITICALLY CORRECT. I'M THAT'S
WHY WE'RE IN THE POSITION WE'RE
IN TODAY WHERE YOU SEE LARGE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE NOT COMPLYING
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS BECAUSE
THEY'RE HEARING SOMETHING VERY
DIFFERENT FROM THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE AND THEY'RE WATCHING
HIM BEHAVE IN A MANNER AND
ENCOURAGE BEHAVIOR. THAT IS
DIRECTLY CONTRARY TO WHAT WE'RE
BEING TOLD TODAY AND IT JUST
PROBABLY REQUIRE SAYING THAT
OUT LOUD AT THIS HEARING. LET
ME ASK A FEW QUESTIONS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I CAN ABOUT GLOBAL
PUBLIC HEALTH BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T COVERED THAT HERE TODAY.
DR FAUCI- THIS VIRUS GOT HERE
REALLY QUICKLY I AND WHAT WE
LEARNED IS THAT WELL TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS CAN HELP GIVE YOU
TIME THEY CAN'T FULLY PREVENTS
A DISEASE FROM ARRIVING HERE
AND SO EVEN IF WE DO. TURN THE
CORNER IN THE UNITED STATES IN
A MEANINGFUL WAY SO LONG AS
THIS VIRUS EXISTS IN LARGE
QUANTITIES OUTSIDE OF THE
UNITED STATES WE ARE STILL
VULNERABLE IS THAT RIGHT THAT'S
CORRECT SIR. I'M END SO. DR
REDFIELD I'M- WHAT IS YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY THE UNITED
STATES HAS NOT JOINS- THE
GLOBAL VACCINE AFTER WHY ARE WE
NOT IN SOMETHING LIKE SEPI- AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS WORKING
WITH OTHER NATIONS TO TRY TO
COORDINATE NOT ONLY THE
DEVELOPMENT THE VACCINE BUT-
ALSO THE DISTRIBUTION OF THE
VACCINE. WELL I THINK OF THE U.
S. IS- OBVIOUSLY DEVELOPED- AN
AGGRESSIVE COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM BUT- CENTER IT WOULDN'T
PRECLUDE BEING PART OF THESE
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
ALSO. AND FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
WE HAVE LEGISLATION PENDING
RIGHT NOW BEFORE THE FOREIGN
RELATIONS COMMITTEE THAT WOULD
PUT THE UNITED STATES INTO
THESE GLOBAL VACCINE EFFORTS IT
JUST DOESN'T MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE TO MANY OF US ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE AS TO WHY
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION. HAS
NOT JOINED I'M IN FOR ADMIRAL
I'M JUST MAYBE HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHAT OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE WHO'S
TODAY RIGHT AROUND THE TIME
THAT THE PRESIDENT DID TO
DECLARE THAT WE WERE PULLING
OUT OF THE W. H. O. NOT JUST
THAT WE WERE NOT GOING TO FUND
IN PRISON ASPEN WAS ACTUALLY WE
WERE GOING TO. SEVER OUR
RELATIONSHIP THE W. H. O. U.
ARE CONFIRMED TO A SEAT ON THE
EXECUTIVE BOARD AND SO HAVE YOU
BEEN RECALLED FROM THE W. H. O.
R. U. S. ATTENDING. MEETINGS
ARE YOU PARTICIPATING WHAT ARE
THE DETAILS SURROUNDING OUR
WITHDRAWAL FROM THE W. H. O.
WHICH BY THE WAY- IS MAYBE THE
MOST DANGEROUS THING MY OPINION
THAT THE ADMINSTRATION HAS DONE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC WHAT'S WHAT'S OUR
STATUS AND WHAT'S YOUR STATUS
AS A AS A CONFIRMED MEMBER OF
THAT BOARD. SET THANK YOU SEN
RIGHT REALLY DO A THE CALL FROM.
IS CONFIRM ON THE SEVENTH AND I
DO ATTEND EX BOARD ON MAY
TWENTY THE EGGS BOARD IT'S VERY.
I DO PURCHASE AND. IN ANY WAY
THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER EXECUTIVE
BOARD MEETING PROBABLY IN
OCTOBER AND I BELIEVE ALL OF US
ON OUR PUBLIC HEALTH STANDARDS
STILL WORK WITH THE WHL AS A W.
H. O. PARTNER FOR EXAMPLE WE
PARTICIPATE WITH THE WHL ON A
GLOBAL SICKLE CELL MEETING. I
JUST TWO DAYS AGO SO WE WORK WE
CERTAINLY WORK FROM THE PUBLIC
HEALTH ASPECTS I DIRECTION ON
THE OFFICIAL WHETHER WE'RE
GOING TO BE A MEMBER OR WHETHER
I'M NOT GOING TO GO THE
EXECUTIVE BOARD I HAVE NOT
GOTTEN THAT DIRECTION YET. OKAY
THANK YOU AT THE NELSON WAS IT
WERE TERMINATING OUR
RELATIONSHIP THE WHS ARE
PROBABLY SOME ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATION WOULD BE HELPFUL
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU SENATOR MURPHY SENATOR
MCCASKEY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. AND GENTLEMEN THANK
YOU FOR NOT ONLY YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY BUT ALL THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN DOING. I THINK I'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH EACH ONE OF
YOU ABOUT TO OF THE ALASKA
SPECIFIC ISSUES. MOST NOTABLY-
WITH REGARDS TO OUR OUR SEAFOOD
PROCESSING THIS IS THE TIME OF
YEAR WHERE- WE TYPICALLY
WELCOME. A MILLION PLUS
TOURISTS AS WELL AS AS MANY
THOUSANDS THAT COME UP FROM
FROM THE LOWER FORTY EIGHT
OTHER PLACES TO HELP WITH OUR
SEAFOOD PROCESSING. AND IT HAS
BEEN VERY ANXIOUS TIME I THINK
FOR ALL OF US IN ALASKA AS WE
SEE. OUTSIDERS COMING IN- WE
HAVE SEEN- OBVIOUSLY ELEVATED.
CASES OF CONFIRMED- COVID OUR
OUR NUMBERS- I THINK OUR
ENVIABLE WHEN OTHER STATES LOOK
AT US TO KNOW THAT SO- WE'RE
WORKING ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
ACTIVE CASES RIGHT NOW ABOUT
DOUBLE THAT IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE
PANDEMIC- BUT AGAIN WE KNOW AND
YOU HAVE STATED THAT WE DON'T
HAVE RESOURCES THAT WE CAN.
LOOK TO NEIGHBORING STATES-
WE'RE KIND OF ON OUR OWN ISLAND
THERE IN TERMS OF RESOURCING SO
WHAT YOU HAVE DONE TO HELP
FACILITATE WHETHER IT'S THE
PLANS WITH THE SEAFOOD
PROCESSORS THE GUIDANCE. THE
ABILITY TO COMMENT ON AN AS
NEEDED- IF THE SITUATION SO
DEMANDS- WE APPRECIATE THAT WE
HAVE SEEN THE BENEFIT OF HOW
THESE VERY. RIGOROUS PLANS HAVE
HAVE WORKED ON AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO COMES UP- TO WORK IN A
SEAFOOD PROCESSING FACILITY. IS
TESTED BEFORE THEY COME TO THIS
STATE THEY'RE TESTED WHEN THEY
GET TO THE STATE THEY'RE PUT IN
A FOURTEEN DAY QUARANTINE OUT
WE HAVE SEEN POSITIVE CASES
ONCE PEOPLE HAVE ARRIVED BUT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE. TO DO WHAT THE
PLAN CALLS FOR WHICH IS THAT
CONTACT TRACING AND THEN
ISOLATION KEEPING THINGS TO A
MINIMUM SO I THINK IT DOES
DEMONSTRATE THAT THESE TOUGH
PLANS REALLY CAN WORK THEY ARE
EXPENSIVE THOUGH IF YOU ARE
BRINGING IN. SEVERAL HUNDRED OR
PERHAPS A THOUSAND WORKERS AND
YOU HAVE TO PUT THEM UP IN A
HOTEL FOR FOURTEEN DAYS WITH
PAY WHEN YOU HAVE TO PROVIDE
FOR THE HEALTH PROTOCOLS- THIS
IS THIS IS COSTLY- I WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR INPUT PROBABLY AT A
QUESTION FOR THE RECORD JUST IN
TERMS OF WHICH AGENCIES. CAN
CAN BEST HELP FACILITATE THESE
SEAFOOD PROCESSORS WITH NOT
ONLY IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
SPECIFIC GUIDANCE BUT HOW WE
CAN BE DEALING WITH THE COSTS
WE DO RECEIVE SOME BENEFIT.
FROM THE DISCRETIONARY FUNDS
PROVIDED TO THE STATES BUT I
THINK WE WOULD ALL RECOGNIZE.
LIKE THE MEAT POT MEAT PACKING
FACILITIES ARE SEAFOOD
PROCESSORS ARE IMPORTANT AND
CRITICAL INDUSTRY NOT ONLY TO
ALASKA TO THE COUNTRY SO WE
WANT TO WORK TO ADDRESS THAT. I
DO WANT TO SPEAK VERY QUICKLY
THOUGH TO THE TO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE I'M TOLD
THAT IN ALASKA AS WE ARE DOING
OUR CONTRACT TASTE TRACING. IT
IS STILL A PAPER COPY. EXCEL
SPREADSHEET FAXED TO THE
EPIDEMIOLOGY LABS THIS IS HOW
WE ARE DOING OUR OUR TRACING I
THOUGHT WELL MAYBE THAT'S JUST
ALASKA AND I'M TOLD BY BY DR
ZINK WHO YOU OF ALL HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THAT WELL
THIS IS ACTUALLY GOING ON IN IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL THAT TO ME
IS NOT A CONTRACT TAKE CONTACT
TRACING SYSTEM. THAT WORKS AND
IS SUFFICIENT SO I WANT TO ASK
ABOUT. NOT ONLY YOUR VIEW OF
THE SUFFICIENCY OF CONTACT
TRACING AND THIS IS PROBABLY
YOU DR REDFIELD BUT THEN DR
FAUCI I'M GONNA ASK YOU- ABOUT
THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE WE HAD
CERTAIN CERTAIN. PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY WHERE YOU HAVE PUBLIC
MISTRUST OF VACCINES IN GENERAL.
MY FEAR IS THAT. WE MAY GET TO
THE PLACE WHERE WE WILL GET TO
THAT PLACE WHERE WE HAVE THAT
SUCCESSFUL VACCINE BUT WE STILL
HAVE THE CONCERN FOR MANY. AND
A MISTRUST AND WHETHER IT'S
VACCINE HESITATION OR VACCINE
CONFIDENCE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE BUZZ WORD IS BUT I'M
WORRIED THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
PLAN FOR HOW TO DEAL WITH THAT
SO FIRST CONTACT TRACING. AND
THEN THE VACCINE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT WHAT YOU SAID. ABOUT
THE CURRENT STATE OF DATA
SYSTEMS FOR PUBLIC HEALTH IN
THE UNITED STATES. THAT THEY
REALLY ARE- IN NEED OF
AGGRESSIVE MODERNIZATION AND
AGAIN THANK CONGRESS FOR. THE
FUNDING THERE BUT IT IS A
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENT THAT
NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF COUNTIES ARE STILL
DOING THIS PEN AND PENCIL. AS
YOU COMMENTED AND WE NEED TO
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
INTEGRATED. PUBLIC HEALTH DATA
SYSTEM THAT'S NOT ONLY ABLE TO
DO SOMETHING THAT'S IN REAL
TIME. BUT ACTUALLY CAN BE
PREDICTIVE IN AND IT WOULD BE
ONE OF THE GREAT. I THINK
INVESTMENTS- OF OUR TIME TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN ONCE AND FOR
ALL- AND THAT'S REALLY
FUNDAMENTAL TO BE ABLE TO
OPERATIONALIZE- CONTACT RACE IN
EXETER IN CONTACT TRACING IN
THIS CASE WILL BE VERY QUICK.
REALLY DOESN'T HAVE ANY VALUE
IN LESS YOU CAN DO IT IN REAL
TIME. IT DOESN'T HELP LIKE I
JUST DID WITH THE AIRLINES FOR
WE HAD PEOPLE THAT WERE FLYING
DEFECTED FROM AFGHANISTAN. WE
DIDN'T GET THE INFORMATION TO
DAY FOURTEEN DAY FIFTEEN DAY
SIXTEEN IT'S IRRELEVANT. SO
AGAIN WE LOVE THE PARTNERSHIP.
TO GET AN INTEGRATED ON PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA SYSTEM NOT JUST FOR
CDC BUT FOR ALL OF OUR
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE NATION
INTO ONE. TIMELY INTEGRATED
SYSTEM. OKAY SENATE THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION ABOUT IF YOU
COULD BE SISTERS SINK WHERE
WELL OVER TIME WILL BE QUICK WE
HAVE A COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
PROGRAM. THAT IS EMBEDDED
WITHIN THE SITES WITH THE
VACCINE TRIALS WILL BE DONE.
BECAUSE WITH THOROUGHLY AWARE
OF WHAT YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
AND IT IS A REALITY. A LACK OF
TRUST OF THE THIRTY. A LACK OF
TRUST IN GOVERNMENT AND THEY
CONCERNED ABOUT VACCINES IN
GENERAL WE NEED TO ENGAGE THE
COMMUNITY BY BOOTS ON THE
GROUND. AND GETTING COMMUNITY
PARTICULARLY THOSE POPULATIONS
THAT HAVE NOT ALWAYS BEEN
TREATED FAIRLY BY THE
GOVERNMENT MINORITY POPULATIONS
AFRICAN AMERICANS LATINO EX AND
NATIVE AMERICANS. AND WE HAVE A
PROGRAM THAT'S ALREADY OPERABLE
RIGHT NOW TO DO THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MCALLISTER
SENATOR WARREN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN DR FOUND SHE
CAME BEFORE THE HELP COMMITTEE
SEVEN WEEKS AGO TO DISCUSS THE
COUNTRY'S RESPONSE TO THE COVID
NINETEEN AND AT THE TIME YOU
TOLD ME THAT THE U. S. DID NOT
QUOTE BY ANY MEANS HAVE TOTAL
CONTROL OVER THIS OUT RIGHT.
BUT YOU ALSO TOLD ME THAT WE
WERE QUOTE GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION NOW ON THE DAY YOU
TESTIFIED BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
THAT WAS MAY TWELFTH TWENTY
TWENTY THERE WERE ABOUT TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND NEW CASES OF
CORONAVIRUS YESTERDAY THERE
WERE ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND NEW
CASES OF CORONAVIRUS. DOCTOR
FELT SHE DID THESE NUMBERS SHOW
THAT THE COUNTRY IS STILL
MOVING QUOTE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND THAT THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC IS UNDER
CONTROL. WELL I THINK THE
NUMBERS SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES
ALTHOUGH WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY TO DOING
WELL I'M VERY CONCERNED. ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW
PARTICULARLY IN THE FOUR STATES
THAT ARE ACCOUNTING FOR ABOUT
50% OF THE NEW INFECTIONS BUT
THE OTHER VULNERABLE STATES. SO
I'D HAVE TO SAY THE NUMBERS
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES I'M VERY
CONCERNED THAT I'M NOT
SATISFIED WITH WHAT'S GOING ON
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION IF YOU LOOK. AT
THE CURVES OF THE NEW CASES SO
WE REALLY GOT TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT AND WE NEED IT WOULD
QUICKLY SHORT ANSWER SOME
QUESTIONS IS THAT CLEARLY WE
ARE NOT IN TOTAL CONTROL RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN OUR CASE NUMBERS ARE
GETTING WORSE. AND OUR DEATH
RATES ARE GOING TO GET WORSE
SENATE. DURING THE SAME PERIOD
OF TIME SOME OTHER COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD HAVE CONTROL
DEVICE- THERE REPORTING FEWER
CASES EACH DAY AND THEY ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE TARGETED. OF
OUR TESTING. AND TO KEEP IT ALL
OF IT SO THAT THEY CAN TELL
WHAT'S HAPPENING- AND FOLLOW UP
IF THERE IS AN OUTBREAK IN
OTHER WORDS CONTROLLING THE
CORONAVIRUS CAN BE DONE. BUT
BECAUSE OF BAD FEDERAL
LEADERSHIP ALL WE HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO DO THIS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES. SO OUR DOCTOR
FOUND YOU THE LAST TIME YOU
WERE BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE YOU
TOLD ME THAT IF THE US DID NOT
HAVE QUOTE. AN ADEQUATE
RESPONSE THAT THE COUNTRY WOULD
QUOTE HAVE THE DELETERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES OF WARRING
FACTIONS AND MORE DEATHS. NOW I
KNOW THAT WE'VE MADE SOME
PROGRESS BUT HALF MEASURES
WON'T SAVE LIVES DR FOUND CHEAP
I'M ASKING YOU TO BE VERY
DIRECT WITH ALL OF US ON THIS.
IF WE DON'T FULLY IMPLEMENTED
WIDESPREAD TESTING CONTACT
TRACING PROGRAMS AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING PRACTICES THAT
EVERYONE SEEMS TO AGREE THAT WE
NEED. CAN WE EXPECT THE SPIKES
INSPECTION TO KEEP HAPPENING IN
DIFFERENT PLACES AROUND THE
COUNTRY. THANK YOU SENATE I'M
ALWAYS DIRECT WITH YOU AND I'LL
TELL YOU IN DIRECT ANSWER TO
YOUR QUESTION. THAT IF YOU LOOK
AT WHAT'S GOING ON. AND JUST
LOOK AT SOME OF THE FILM CLIPS
THAT YOU'VE SEEN. OF PEOPLE
CONGREGATING OFTEN WITHOUT
MASKS. OF BEING IN CROWDS AND
JUMPING OVER. AND AVOIDING AND
NOT PAYING ATTENTION TO THE
GUIDELINES THAT WE VERY
CAREFULLY PUT OUT. WE GONNA
CONTINUE TO BE IN A LOT OF
TROUBLE AND THERE'S GOING TO BE
A LOT OF HURT. IF THAT DOES NOT
STOP. AND OKAY. NO WE DON'T GET
OUR ACT TOGETHER MORE MORE
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY
ARE GOING TO SEE THESE.
DANGEROUS SURGES OF COVID
NINETEEN. EIGHTY DR FAUCI BACK
IN MARCH YOU ALSO STAND WHILE.
LOOKING AT WHAT WE'RE SEEING
NOW. YOU EXPECTED THERE TO BE
BETWEEN A HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
CORONAVIRUS DEATHS. AND
MILLIONS OF INFECTIONS IN THE
US SO LET'S FLASH FORWARD TO
LATE JUNE HERE WE ARE AT THE
END OF JUNE. WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND DEATHS WITH INFECTION
RATES RISING RAPIDLY. DR FELT
YOU BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
NOW. HOW MANY COVID NINETEEN
DEATHS AND INFECTIONS SHOULD
AMERICA EXPECT BEFORE THIS IS
ALL OVER. I CAN MAKE AN
ACCURATE PREDICTION BUT IT IS
GOING TO BE VERY DISTURBING I
WILL GUARANTEE YOU THAT.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE AN
OUTBREAK IN ONE PART OF THE
COUNTRY EVEN THOUGH IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY THEY'RE
DOING WELL. THEY ARE VULNERABLE
I MADE THAT POINT VERY CLEARLY
LAST WEEK AT A PRESS CONFERENCE
WE CAN'T JUST FOCUS ON THOSE
AREAS THAT ARE HAVING THE SURGE
IT PUTS THE ENTIRE COUNTRY. AT
RISK WE ARE NOW HAVING FORTY
PLUS THOUSAND NEW CASES A DAY I
WOULD NOT BE SURPRISED IF WE GO
UP TO A HUNDRED THOUSAND A DAY
IF THIS DOES NOT TURN AROUND
AND SO I AM VERY CONCERNED. IT
CAN YOU MAKE ANY KIND OF
ESTIMATE ON WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT OVERALL ON THE NUMBER OF
DEATHS. BEFORE THIS IS OVER YOU
MADE AN ESTIMATE BACK IN MARCH.
BETWEEN A HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND BUT WE A
LOT MORE INFORMATION AL AND
WE'RE ALREADY AT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS. I
CAN'T MAKE A- ESTIMATION
BECAUSE THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
MODELED OUT BECAUSE WHEN MODELS
ARE DONE AND THAT'S WITH THOSE
ORIGINAL NUMBERS. CAME FROM
SENATOR AS I SAID VERY OFTEN
MODELS ARE IS GOOD IS THE
ASSUMPTIONS THAT YOU PUT INTO
THE MODEL. AND THOSE
ASSUMPTIONS OFTEN CHANGED
DEPENDING UPON WHAT YOUR
RESPONSE IS. SO I WOULD REALLY
BE HESITANT TO GIVE A NUMBER.
THAT WILL COME BACK AND
CONTRADICTED OVERBLOWN OR ON
THE BLOWN. BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TELL YOU AND THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC. THAT I'M VERY
CONCERNED BECAUSE IT COULD GET
VERY BAD. ALL RIGHT I
APPRECIATE THAT DOCTOR FALCHUK.
ALL ARE GONNA BE TIME BARRED
WARNS. I JUST LIKE THE SAME
TIME THAT MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES SCOTT. BECAUSE WHEN
YOU'RE- I. WELL HE FOR WARNS.
THE HIDING JUST YET THERE YOU.
ANDREW CALLING OUT A LOT MORE
TIME. SENATOR WARREN CHAIRMAN
HOW ALWAYS TREAT YOU FAIRLY AND
I WOULD APPRECIATE YOU
RESPECTING THE CHAIRMAN'S
RESERVE YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A
CLOSING STATEMENT GO AHEAD AND
DO IT BUT I DON'T APPRECIATE
YOUR THANK YOU QUESTIONS.
JUSTIN AMID IN PRESIDING OVER
THE HEARING GOES UNDERSTANDINGS
GROUP RELEASED ON WHAT OTHERS
HAVE DONE THAT YOU ARE ALLOWING
MORE TIME SINCE WE HAD SUCH
IMPORTANT WITNESSES ON HIS
CHAIRMAN AND YOU CAN YOU CAN
MAKE THAT. YOU CAN MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS THANK YOU YOU KNOW I
JUST WANT TO MAKE THE POINT
THAT WE CAN'T KEEP PRETENDING
THIS VIRUS IS GETTING BETTER
WHEN IT ISN'T. THAT'S HOW WE
END UP WITH MET LIFE SITUATION
IN TEXAS RACING TO RE OPEN TO
EXTEND AND SCRAMBLING TO CLOSE
DOWN BEFORE THE SPITTLE GET
COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED. WE
DON'T OUR ACT TOGETHER THIS IS
OUR FUTURE SEE SAWING BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN TO YOU
RESTRICTIONS AND THEN EXPLODING
CASES IN REPEATED SHUTDOWNS IN
THIS FUTURE THOUSANDS MORE
AMERICANS WILL DIE AND OUR
ECONOMY WILL BE BROUGHT TO ITS
KNEES. WE'VE GOT TO HAVE A
NATIONAL STRATEGY THAT MAKES
HAS AVAILABLE TO EVERY SCHOOL
BUSINESS EVERY HAAS EVERY
CHURCH ANYWHERE THAT AMERICANS
COME TOGETHER WE NEED TO EXPAND
CONTACT TRACING AND WE NEED
LEADERS. PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO
HAVE ENOUGH BACKBONE TO FACE
REALITY DISTRICT OUR RESOURCES
SET OUR STANDARDS STEP TO THEM
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T. THE
RESULTS CAN BE MORE NAMIK
WRECKAGE MORE DAY. THANK MISTER
CHIP. TWO WARREN WHAT I TRIED
IN THE- IN THIS HEARING IS TO.
S. N. TO STAY WITH FIVE MINUTES
AND THAT WITHIN FIVE MINUTES OF.
THE OF THE ANSWER GO BEYOND
THAT I'VE TRIED TO BE.
RESPECTFUL OF THAT BUT TO BUT I
WOULD ASK SENATORS NOT TO ASK
THE QUESTIONS AND WELL PAST
FIVE MINS INSPECT TO MAKE A
SPEECH AT THE END SENATOR SCOTT.
I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I WILL
CERTAINLY RESPECT YOUR YOUR
YOUR TIME LIMITS A BIG WE ALSO
DO THAT AND- FRANKLY AS WE'RE
ASKING DOCTOR FOSTER FOR AN
ESTIMATE OF HOW MANY LIVES MAY
BE LOST I RECALL THE FIRST
ESTIMATES WERE BETWEEN ONE AND
TWO POINT FOUR. MILLION LIVES
SO I'M CERTAINLY GLAD THAT WE
ARE NOT BEAR AND PERHAPS ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY WE SHOULD BE
THANKFUL FOR WHERE WE ARE NOW
AND FORCE OURSELVES TO HAVE A
SERIOUS CONVERSATION ABOUT
CONTINUING TO FLATTEN THE
CURVE. IS BECAUSE THE ALL HANDS
ON DECK APPROACH IS EFFECTIVE
WE JUST NEED AS MUCH
COOPERATION FROM AS MANY PEOPLE
AS CONCEIVABLY POSSIBLE EVERY
STATE AROUND THE COUNTRY IN
ORDER FOR US TO SEE. THESE
NUMBERS CONTINUE TO MAKE A DIVE
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AS
OPPOSED TO SPIKE IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION AND I THINK ABOUT THE
OPERATIONS WARP SPEED ALONG
WITH THE CRUCIAL SUPPORT. FROM
BART AND OTHER FEDERAL AGENCIES
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS AND
ACCELERATING GROUNDBREAKING
TECHNOLOGIES THAT COULD A
RADICALLY COVID NINETEEN AND
REVOLUTIONIZE FRANKLY. VACCINE
DEVELOPMENT LANDSCAPE. BECAUSE
OF THE EXACT BY INDUSTRY. YEAH
AND COVER WORKING IN CONCERT.
WE COULD. A BIO CAN OR- IN A
MATTER OF MONTHS FOR VACCINE
AND BECAUSE OF THE GROWING
NUMBER OF LARGE SCALE
MANUFACTURING AGREEMENTS WITH
COMPANIES LIKE MADONNA. VISOR
NJ NJ PRODUCING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOSES AT RISK WHICH
MEANS IN ADVANCE. WE ARE
ALREADY WORKING TO ADDRESS
ISSUES OF ACCESS AND THIS IS
CRITICAL ESPECIALLY FOR OUR
MOST DISTRESSED COMMUNITIES
THAT SAID. AFFECTED DEVELOPMENT
AND WIDESPREAD ACCESS WHILE
CENTRAL ARE ONLY PART OF THE
EQUATION. IF AND WHEN I FEEL
OPTIMISTIC THAT IT'S WIND AND
NOT IF WE GET A VIABLE VACCINE
WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO
CHOOSE TO GET VACCINATED. I WAS
REALLY CONCERNED BUT I SAW
RECENT AP SURVEY THAT SHOWED
THAT ONLY 49% OF AMERICAN
ADULTS. PLANNED TO GET
VACCINATED ONCE THE COVID
NINETEEN VACCINE CAME TO
MARKET. A FULL 20% SAID THAT
THEY DID NOT PLAN TO GET
VACCINATED AND ONE THIRD OF
AMERICANS WERE NOT SURE. GIVEN
THE PUBLIC'S RECENT AND VITAL
FOCUS ON HEALTH DISPARITIES
IT'S WORTH NOTING. THAT AMONG
CERTAIN. THESE ARE EVEN MORE
ALARMING. JUST 25% OF BLACK
AMERICANS 37% OF HISPANIC
AMERICANS PLANNED TO GET
VACCINATED AGAINST A
CORONAVIRUS- MY AND MY QUESTION
TO THE FULL PANEL. WHAT STEPS
CAN WE TAKE AT EVERY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT AND IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. WITH HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TO ENSURE A PRO
ACTIVE EDUCATION CAMPAIGN AND
OUTREACH STRATEGY ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF GETTING
VACCINATED BOTH FOR COVID
NINETEEN AND FRANKLY EVEN MORE
BROADLY. I'LL TAKE A SHOT AT IT
PERCENT AS I MENTIONED IN.
RESPONSE TO ANOTHER QUESTION
THAT WE HAVE A COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT PROGRAM THAT
ACTUALLY OPERATES OUT OF
OPERATION WHAT SPEED THE
VACCINE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
COMPONENT OF THAT ALSO THEN
NEEDS TO BE ENGAGEMENT. OF
PEOPLE WHO THE COMMUNITY TRUSTS
PARTICULARLY INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE NOTED SPORTS FIGURES OVER
MATTER. WHEN WE WERE INVOLVED
AND CONTINUE TO BE INVOLVED IN
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT WITH HIV
WE USED TO PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY BOOTS ON THE GROUND
TO GO OUT WHO LOOKED AND LIVED
AND ARE LIKE THE PEOPLE THEY'RE
TRYING TO ENGAGE. IT'S VERY
CRITICAL BECAUSE I SHARE WITH
YOU THE CONCERN THAT WE GET TO
THE HOOP AND WE GET THROUGH IT
OF GETTING SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
VACCINE ONLY TO FIND THAT A
SUBSTANTIAL PROPORTION. OF THE
POPULATION DO NOT WANT TO GET
VACCINATED OF PARTICULAR
CONCERN IS THAT PROPORTION OF
THE POPULATION THAT GENERALLY
ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE IN THE
SENSE OF THE MINORITY
COMMUNITIES AFRICAN AMERICANS
LATINO EX NATIVE AMERICANS WHO
IN FACT. BECAUSE OF UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS MAKE IT MORE LIKELY
THAT IF THEY DO GET INFECTED
THEY WOULD HAVE A POOR OUTCOME
SO IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
ENGAGE THEM AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR NJ DOT COM TO MAKE
THIS CLOSE OF MY FORTY SECONDS
THAT I HAVE A LOT OF THE
RESPECTING THE TIME AND I. HOPE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO DO SO THE
PATENT A PANDEMIC HAS TRIGGERED
A DROP OF 6280% OF IMMUNIZATION
RATES AMONG CHILDREN. AND EVEN
NOW THAT STATES ARE RE OPENING
WE'RE NOT SEEING THE REBOUND
AND THESE RATES AS THAT AT THAT
ARE NECESSARY. THIS CREATES A
REAL RISK OF SECONDARY
INFECTIONS AND DISEASE
OUTBREAKS THAT ARE NOT ON THE
GENERAL PUBLIC'S RADAR AS WE
CAN WITH THE CHIEF CRISIS AT
HAND SO I THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE AT FOLLOW
YOUR STRATEGY. TALK ABOUT YES
RELATES TO ENGAGING COMMUNITY
LEADERS AND PERHAPS PEOPLE WITH
NOTORIETY TO CHALLENGE US TO
GET INVOLVED IN TAKING THE
VACCINES I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN I APOLOGIZE FOR BEING
FOUR SECONDS OF MY TIME. THANK
YOU SENATOR SCOTT FOR
RESPECTING THE TIME WE HAVE
EIGHT SENATORS SERVE. REMAINING
WHO HAVE QUESTIONS AND WE
SHOULD HAVE TIME FOR ALL OF
THEM THEY HAVE. A CHANCE TO
ANSWER. QUESTIONS SENATOR KAINE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN YOU TO
THE WITNESSES- DOCTOR FELT SHE
ADDS ON INTERVIEW. WITH YOU
LAST WEEK WERE YOU TALKED ABOUT
A CONCERNED. THAT THERE'S TWO
SIZABLE A PERCENTAGE OF OUR
POPULATION THAT SORTED DONE
LIKE SCIENCE AND SCIENCES. AND
ADVICE FROM SCIENTISTS. AND I
HEAR REAL EMOTION IN YOUR VOICE
AS YOU EXPRESS. CONCERN ABOUT
PEOPLE GATHERING IN LARGE
GROUPS AND- WITHOUT MASKS AND I
GATHER THAT'S THE KIND OF ANTI
SCIENCE- BIG CONCERN THAT YOU
WERE. WORRYING ABOUT WHEN YOU
HAD AN INTERVIEW LAST WEEK.
YEAH THAT IS PART OF IT SENATOR
YES BECAUSE THE DISREGARD OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COME. FROM
THE THIRTIES ONLY BECAUSE IT'S
A RECOMMENDATION I THINK THE
ATTITUDE. OF PUSHING BACK. FROM
AUTHORITY AND PUSHING BACK ON
SCIENTIFIC DATA IS VERY
CONCERNING. WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A CATASTROPHIC. OUTBREAK AND
WE REALLY DO NEED TO BE GUIDED
BY SCIENTIFIC PRINCIPLES AND
THIS COULD CAUSE PROBLEMS DOWN
THE ROAD IF WE GET TO A VACCINE
BUT PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO GET
THE VACCINE SO. WE ALL HAVE TO
MESSAGE THIS PRETTY STRONGLY-
DR REDFIELD I WANT TO THANK
YOU. I WAS GONNA ASK YOU A
QUESTION TODAY THAT I'VE BEEN
ASKING OVER FORGET. WE I JUST
C. GUY FOR. OF A- NOT A MANY
THE WORD TO. THAT IS AS TEST ON
WAS DONE ONE THIS. WEBSITE USED.
M. THERE NOW GONE. FOR AT THE
END. TO HIGHER EDUCATION. WE
FAIRLY EX UP WRECKED DACIAN.
IT'S ABOUT TEST WHICH IS IT
ABOUT SADDAM UP. ON CD'S SIDE
I'M THE THANK YOU FOR THE- YOUR
TESTING DR REDFIELD TODAY AND
SOME OF THE WRITTEN TEST TALKS
ABOUT THE THAT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH TO RELY ON TIMELY IN ACT
DATA SYSTEM BUT THAT WE'VE ON
IN. IN THEM AND THE CRISIS
QUOTE HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED TO
CONTINUE EFFORTS TO MODERNIZE
THE PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEMS LAST
YEAR I INTRODUCED A BILL CALLED
THE SAVING LIVES THROUGH BETTER
DATA ACT WAS WITH SENATOR
ISAACSON AND SENATOR KING AND
COLLEAGUES WERE HELPFUL IN THIS
WEEK WE WERE ABLE TO GET FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN DECEMBER ON
THE APPROPRIATIONS DEAL. AND
ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE CARES ACT BUT I
WOULD URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO DO
EVEN MORE BECAUSE THE REQUEST
FROM OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
COMMUNITIES IS SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE SIZEABLE I HOPE WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO GET THAT INTO THE
NEXT ON. COVID PACKAGE. I'M
DOCTOR FOUND CHEAP. THIS ISN'T
A CHALLENGING QUESTION YET
CHALLENGING HOW TO FIGURE IT
OUT THE CDC LAST WEEK SAID THAT
A NEW GROUP THAT WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER AT RISK IS PREGNANT
WOMEN AND LACTATING WOMEN. THE
NINE AIDS VAX RAMESH TO BEER
REMS OF YOUR TESTING AND
VACCINE TESTING OFTEN DOESN'T
INCLUDE PREGNANT WOMEN I THINK
FOR SOME SAFETY REASONS BUT WE
WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
PREGNANT OR LACTATING WOMEN
HAVE ACCESS TO TREATMENTS AND
ACCESS THE VACCINE SO HOW WILL
WE BE TRYING TO DO RESEARCH AND
TESTING. YEAH THAT THE WOMEN
CAN SAFELY ACCESS THAT HE'S GOT
A TREATMENT SURVEILLANCE THAT
IS A GREAT QUESTION IT IMPLIES
ALSO TWO CHILDREN SO WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH THE VACCINE. IS YOU
DO A PHASE ONE TRIAL IN NORMAL
HEALTHY ADULTS. NOT PREGNANT.
NOT CHILDREN AND YOU SHOW
INITIAL SAFETY THEN WHEN YOU
MOVE INTO THIS PHASE TWO AND
THREE STUDIES IF YOU GET EVEN
THE SLIGHTEST GLIMPSE. OF
EFFICACY AND SAFETY IN THAT
POPULATION. YOU GO BACK AND DO
A PHASE ONE. IN PREGNANT AND
LACTATING WOMEN AS WELL AS IN
CHILDREN AND IF THAT IS SAFE
THERE YOU BRIDGE THE DATA. SO
THAT YOU COULD USE THE EFFICACY
DATA THAT YOU ALREADY STARTED
TO APPLY BACK TO PREGNANT WOMEN
I SEE THAT'S HOW YOU DO IT. LET
ME ASK YOU THIS AT THIS POINT
IS THE NATION'S CALL WITH
RESPECT TO CORONAVIRUS TO.
UNMITIGATED OR SUPPRESS. YOU
KNOW VACCINES RIGHT NOW YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT VACCINE SO I'M
JUST TALKING ABOUT WHAT IS WHAT
IS OUR GOAL ARE WE YEAH. THE
INDICATOR WE TRYING TO SUPPRESS
YOU KNOW IT DEPENDS ON WHERE
YOU ARE THIS CONTAINMENT AND
MITIGATION SERVE YOU HAVE A
LEVEL OF VIRUS. THAT SLOW
ENOUGH THAT YOU CAN ADEQUATELY
CONTAINED BY THE STANDARD WAY
OF IDENTIFICATION ISOLATION
CONTACT TRACING PARTICULARLY
YOU MAKE SURE YOU LINK. THE
IDENTIFICATION WITH ISOLATION
BECAUSE IF YOU JUST DO CONTACT
TRACING WITHOUT ISOLATION IS
NOT GONNA WORK. WHEN YOU GET
INTO A SITUATION IF I IF I
COULD DOCTOR FELT SHE BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO GO OVER AND I'M I
WANT TO SAY JUST ONE THING
ABOUT TESTING REAL QUICK-
ADMIRAL DRIVE WHEN YOU WERE
HERE LAST YOU SAID WE WOULD
HAVE CAPACITY TO FORTY TO FIFTY
MILLION TESTS A MONTH IN
SEPTEMBER. THAT'S ABOUT ONE
POINT. SEVEN MILLION IT. ENTER
INTO THOUSAND. YESTERDAY WE
DID. FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND ARE WE GONNA GET TO
ONE POINT THREE TO ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION TEST TODAY BY
SEPTEMBER. SO THANK YOU FOR
ASKING THAT WE WILL ABSOLUTELY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO THAT
IT'S DEPENDING ON THE NEED AND
AGAIN. AS YOU MIGHT EXPECT A
FEW WEEKS AGO THE NEED FOR
TESTING WAS MUCH LESS THAN IT
IS NOW- WE HAD A GOOD SYSTEM
THAT IT WAS ACTUALLY VERY GOOD
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY.
POSIT THAT HE EARLY BUT
OBVIOUSLY WITH THE WITH THE
OUTBREAKS WERE HAVING NOW WE
NEED TO MASSIVELY SEARCH
TESTING IN THOSE AREAS. WE WILL
HAVE THE CAPABILITY OF ACROSS
THE BOARD YEAH WE'LL HAVE THAT
THAT'S ASSUMING NO PULLING WHEN
WE START PULLING THESE TOGETHER
THREE FOUR TASKS THEN YOU DO
THE MATH SO- I'M NEVER GONNA BE
HAPPY UNTIL WE HAVE. MORE TESTS
THAT WE HAVE TO SAY THE WORD
TEST AGAIN BUT WE'RE GONNA BE
IN REASONABLY GOOD SHAPE GIVEN
THOSE PARAMETERS THANKS. THANK
YOU SIR KAINE SENATOR ROMNEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU TO EACH OF THE
PANELISTS FOR THE SACRIFICE OF
THE EFFORT YOU'VE BEEN MAKING
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS AS WELL
HERE- AS YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T KNOW A GREAT DEAL ABOUT
THIS VIRUS. ANOTHER SCENE IN
AMERICA WE ASK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO- TO BASICALLY SHUT
DOWN A LOT. GOT BACK ON FLYING-
FAMILY REUNIONS FUNERALS CHURCH
SERVICES RESTAURANTS BARS
THEATERS EVERYTHING GOT SHUT
OUT WELL NOW IT'S THE END OF
JUNE AND HOPEFULLY WE LEARN
SOMETHING ABOUT HOW THIS
DISEASE ACTUALLY SPREADS. AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO GO
BACK OUT THERE GET A CALL BACK
OUT OF THEY ARE GOING BACK OUT
WE SUFFERING THE LAKE OF THE
OZARKS ALL THESE PEOPLE ARE
RESET ALL MY GOODNESS. THIS IS
GONNA BE A MAJOR PROBLEM BUT MY
IMPRESSION WAS BECAUSE PEOPLE
OUTSIDE OR OTHER REASONS IT
WASN'T A MAJOR MAJOR PROBLEM.
SO MY QUESTION IS THIS. WHERE
IS THE RISK GREATEST HOW IS IT
THAT IT'S SPREADING IT SPREADER
INDOORS IS SPREADING MORE AT
RESTAURANTS AND BARS IS IT OKAY
TO BE OUTDOORS AND PERHAPS NOT
SOCIALLY DISTANCE AS OUR FAMILY
REUNIONS OKAY ARE BIG HE COULD
YOU GIVE US SOME GUIDANCE BASED
ON WHAT HOPEFULLY WE KNOW AS TO
WHERE THE RISKS ARE GREATEST I
KNOW YOU KEEP SAYING SOCIAL
DISTANCING MASS. BUT YOU DON'T.
WE'RE GETTING ON AIRPLANES
THEY'RE GOING TO RESTAURANTS
WHERE IS THE RISK GREATEST AND
WHERE WE RELATIVELY SAY HELP US
THROUGH THAT FAMILY REUNIONS.
WE GET TOGETHER WITH FAMILY
REUNIONS OUTDOORS. IS A SAFER
OUTDOORS AND INDOORS. GIVE US
SOME GUIDANCE CAN YOU DO THAT
THE DOCTOR FELT SHE ABOUT TO
READ WILL. THANK YOU SENATOR I
THINK FIRST AND FOREMOST THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING IN THAT
ASSESSMENT IS KNOWING AT THE
GRANULAR LEVEL. WHAT THE
KINETICS OF TRANSMISSION ARE IN
THEIR COMMUNITY AS I MENTIONED
WE HAVE A HUNDRED THIRD ACCOUNT
IS RIGHT NOW IN THE UNITED
STATES. WHERE WE CONSIDER THEM
CALLED HOT SPOTS. WE HAVE MANY
OTHER AREAS WHERE THERE'S VERY
LIMITED TRANSMISSION SO FIRST
AND FOREMOST. IT'S SNOWING THE
IF YOU'RE IN THAT AREA OF
ACTIVE TRANSMISSION THEN
SECONDLY IT'S KNOWING WHAT YOU
DO WHEN YOU'RE IN THAT AREA OF
ACTIVE TRANSMISSION. AND WHAT
WHAT- PRECAUTIONS ONE TAKES YOU
KNOW IDENTITY GREAT THAT'D BE
GREAT AFTER I ONLY GOT FIVE
MINUTES ALL RIGHT WELL I THINK
THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS I WILL
SAY THAT- THERE'S JUST MORE
MORE DATA SHOWING THAT THE USE
OF FACE COVERINGS AND ASKED.
ARE IN EFFECTIVE WAY TO PREVENT
TRANSMISSION. IN IN IN THESE
GATHERINGS AND I THINK WE'RE
JUST GONNA COME BACK AND TELL
YOU THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
FEAR WITHIN THE COMMUNITY. WITH
LIMITED TRANSMISSION- AND
YOU'RE WEARING FACE MASK OR
THEIR SIGNIFICANT TRANSMISSION
YOU'RE WEARING FACE MASKS. AND
YOU PRACTICE THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING HANDWASHING THAT'S
THE BEST THING AS RECORD. I CAN
TELL YOU YEAH IN ADDITION SEVEN
OUTDOOR BETTER THAN IN. BALL
REALLY. REALLY NOT GONNA OKAY
AT A BAR INSIDE IS BAD NEWS WE
REALLY GOTTA STOP THAT RIGHT
NOW WHEN YOU HAVE AREAS THAT
ARE SURGING LIKE WE SEE RIGHT
NOW BUT IN ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION A LITTLE BIT MORE
GRANULAR OUTDOORS ALWAYS BETTER
THAN INDOOR IF YOUR OUTDOOR
DISTANCES BOB SAID WHERE A MASK
IF YOU CAN BUT YOU CAN HAVE
SOME SOCIAL INTERACTION THE ONE
POINT I WANT TO MAKE VERY
BRIEFLY. IS THAT WE SHOULD NOT
LOOK AT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
ENDEAVORS AS BEING IN
OBSTRUCTION TO OPENING UP WE
SHOULD LOOK AT IT AS A VEHICLE
TO OPENING UP SO THAT YOU DON'T
WANT TO JUST RESTRICT
EVERYTHING BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
NOT GOING TO TOLERATE THAT SO
YOU CAN GET OUTDOORS YOU CAN
INTERACT THEY WEAR A MASK TRY
TO AVOID. CLOSE CONGREGATION OF
PEOPLE WASH YOUR HANDS OFTEN
BUT DON'T JUST MAKE IT ALL OR
NONE WE'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO
GET PEOPLE TO GET OUT AND ENJOY
THEMSELVES WITHIN THE SAFE
GUIDELINES THAT WE HAD SO MAKE
PUBLIC HEALTH IS WORKING FOR
YOU AS OPPOSED TO AGAINST YOU.
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THOSE-
THOSE RESPONSES I THINK IT
WOULD BE EXTRAORDINARILY
HELPFUL. FOR ALL OF US IS WE'RE
GOING ABOUT OUR LIVES IF THERE
IS DATA THAT INDICATED WHERE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING INFECTED.
WHERE THEY IN A BAR WITHIN A
RESTAURANT WHERE THE OUTDOOR
OUTDOORS AT A POOL. I'VE HEARD
REPORTS THAT VIRTUALLY NOBODY
HAS BEEN INFECTED IF THEY'RE
OUTDOORS IS THAT TRUE OR NOT
TRUE WE- GET GIVEN HOW LONG
WE'VE BEEN AT THIS WEEK GOT TO
HAVE MORE GRANULAR DATA. SO
PEOPLE KNOW WHERE THERE WERE
THERE'S GREATER RISK HOW MANY
PEOPLE FRANCISCO BENEFACTOR AS
A RESULT THE FLYING ON
AIRPLANES. WE HAVE TO KNOW THAT.
IF WE GET PUBLISHED THAT
INFORMATION FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THEY WILL KNOW WHERE
THEY GET THE STEAK GO BACK OF
COURSE CONTINUING SOCIAL
DISTANCING AT WORK MASS BUT WE
NEED THAT DATA. FIND OUT THE
SEVEN ONE ANSWER WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR DISTURBING THE
VACCINE WHAT PERSON OR WHAT
AGENCY DETERMINES HOW THE
VACCINE WHEN IT'S AVAILABLE
WILL BE DISTRIBUTED. WELL
CITIZENS THANK YOU SENATOR THIS
IS A CENTRAL FUNCTION OF CDC
WHERE WE'D REALLY- HELP WITH
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION-
THROUGHOUT THE NATION CHILDHOOD
VACCINES SO THAT'S SO THAT'S
THE THAT'S THE CDC THAT'S ON
YOUR SHOULDERS THANK YOU THE
GERMAN BACK TO YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR ROMNEY-
SENATOR HACEN WELL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO
ALL THE WITNESSES FOR BEING
HERE AND FOR THE TEAMS YOU LEAD
I KNOW HOW HARD EVERYBODY IS
WORKING. ON A DOCTORATE FIELD I
WANT TO START WITH A QUESTION
TO YOU OF THE 43% OF THE DOZENS
COUNTRY HAVE BEEN IN NURSING
HOMES OR LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES IN MY STATE OF NEW
HAMPSHIRE 80% OF OUR DEATHS ARE
ATTRIBUTED TO RESIDENTS OF
NURSING HOMES AND LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES IN MID MAY THE
WHITE HOUSE URGES STATES TO
COMPLETE COVID NINETEEN TESTING
ON EVERY NURSING HOME WORKER
AND RESIDENT WITHIN FOURTEEN
DAYS A MONTH AND A HALF LATER
THAT STILL HAS NOT HAPPENED.
CDC HAS SINCE PUT OUT DIFFERENT
GARDENS ON NURSING HOME TESTING
CALLED FOR A BASELINE TEST FOR
RESIDENTS AND WEEKLY TESTING
FOR NURSING HOME WORKERS GIVEN
THE WIDESPREAD OUTBREAKS WITHIN
NURSING HOMES AND UNIQUE RISKS
POSED TO RESIDENTS WHAT IS CD'S
DOING TO ENSURE THAT STATE'S
CARRY OUT THE RECOMMENDATION
NURSE ASKING SHOULD BUT THE C.
THIRTEEN AND HOW MUCH STATES
HAVE BEEN THESE GUYS SO FAR.
THANK SENATOR. WE ARE WORKING
CONTACT WITH CMS ON ON THAT
ISSUE AS YOU SAY WE'RE NOT
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY- WE MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT BUT I'M
ASKING AND MY TIME IS SHORT I'M
ASKING WHAT WHAT YOU ARE DOING
TO KEEP TRACK OF COMPLIANCE
WITH GUIDELINES. 43% DEATH RATE
NATIONWIDE. OF ME IS HUGE ADD
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING TO DO OFFER
GRANULAR GUIDANCE HERE SO WHAT
ARE YOU DOING TO FIND OUT WHO'S
IN COMPLIANCE AND WHO'S NOT. I
WAS TRYING TO EMPHASIZE THAT
WE'RE WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH CMS WHICH HAS THAT
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT. OVER
THERE TO CONTINUE TO REINFORCE
THE GUIDANCE AS YOU MENTIONED
WHICH WE THINK IS CRITICAL- AND
WE AND WE THINK WE DO HAVE TO
GET EVERYONE'S TO SCREEN IN
THESE NURSING HOMES AND
EMPLOYEES EVERY WEEK. ONE
FORTUNATELY WE STILL THINK THAT
WE NEED TO KEEP VISITORS
ISOLATED FROM THE HOMES RIGHT
NOW CRITICALLY IN AREAS WITHOUT
YOUR SECTIONS. BUT THE
REGULATORY FUNCTION OF THIS IS
CMS BUT WE ARE REALLY MEETING
WITH THEM DAILY TO SEE WHAT
MORE WE CAN DO TO TRY TO.
ENSURE THAT SUCH GREATER
COMPLIANCE. I THANK YOU FOR
THAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING TO THE
CD. FOUR I'M NOT ONLY CLEARER
RENEWAL GUIDELINES AND YOU'VE
HEARD THAT. ALL THROUGHOUT THE
QUESTIONING- BUT PARTICULARLY
IN HOMES AND LONG TERM CARE.
FACILITIES THERE'S A LOT MORE
WORK TO BE DONE- AND WE ARE
STILL HEARING THAT THEY'RE NOT
GETTING A USABLE A PERSON
PROJECT EQUIPMENT ON TIME YOU.
I'LL YOU GO BUT NOT CALL AT THE
END IT FIVE TO WITH YOU. I'M
WE'VE- DISCUSSED ALREADY TODAY
THE DAY. IN THE US NOUS OF
MEASURES TAKEN FOR INSTANCE IN
EUROPE IN THE UNITED STATES.
THIS IS A GRAPH THAT SHOWS THE
DISPARITY BETWEEN NEW CONFIRMED
CASES PER MILLION. FOR THE
PREVIOUS SEVEN DAYS TO THE
UNITED STATES. EUROPE CANADA
AND JAPAN THE DISPARITY IS EYE
POPPING- ON SURVEYS. SUGGEST
THE THAT MASK WEARING THE
UNITED OF LESS FREQUENTLY THAN
IN YOUR- YOU AND WITNESS HAVE
BEEN. CLEAR ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF MASK WEARING IN PUBLIC
PLACES. DO YOU ATTRIBUTE THE
IMPROVEMENTS IN EUROPE TO MORE
WIDESPREAD USE OF MASKS OR ARE
THERE ALSO OTHER SPECIFIC
GOVERNMENT POLICIES OR
INDIVIDUAL BEHAVIORAL
DIFFERENCES THAT YOU BELIEVE
SHOULD BE INCORPORATED INTO OUR
NATIONAL STRATEGY. IT'S
CERTAINLY MASS PLAY THAT ROLE.
BUT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER
MULTI FACETED THINGS IN EACH OF
THOSE TO THOSE VERY DISTURBING
GRASS THAT YOU SHOW. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT BECAME CLEAR WHEN
WE SHUT DOWN AS A NATION. IN
REALITY. ONLY ABOUT FIFTY
PERCENT. OF THE NATION SHUT
DOWN WITH REGARD TO OTHER
THINGS THAT WERE ALLOWED IN
MANY OF THE EUROPEAN COUNTRIES.
185% OF ALL ACTIVITIES WERE
SHUT DOWN SO THAT IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY YOU SAW
PARTICULARLY IN ITALY. WHICH
SHUT DOWN TO A MUCH GREATER
EXTENT THAN WE DID THE CASES
CAME WAY DOWN INTO SHARP CURVE
DOWN WOULD AND THEN STATE SO
IT'S NOT ONLY MASS. IT'S THE
FACT THAT COUNTRIES IN EUROPE
AND THE OTHER COUNTRIES YOU
HAVE THERE HAD A MUCH MORE
UNIFORM RESPONSE WE'RE VERY
HETEROGENEOUS COUNTRY AND WE
HAD A HETEROGENEOUS RESPONSE.
DEPENDING WHETHER YOU ARE IN
THE NORTHEAST SOUTHERN WESTERN
WHAT HAVE YOU SO THERE'S A
NUMBER OF OTHER FACTORS
PROBABLY SOME THAT WE STILL
DON'T EVEN UNDERSTAND. WELL
THANK YOU AND I I'M GONNA MOVE
ON TO JUST ONE OTHER ISSUE AND
IT'S REALLY JUST URGED DR
REDFIELD- AND THE CDC ARE TO
ISSUE- ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE FOR
SCHOOLS IN PARTICULAR ON
REOPENING I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
ARE CONTINUING TO DO THAT- I.
APPRECIATE THAT THE CDC HAS
RELEASED FAQ FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS DOCUMENTS ON THINGS
LIKE U. SPORTS WHICH PROVIDE
MORE CONCRETE USEFUL
INFORMATION. FOR FAMILIES AND
I'M HOPING THAT YOU'LL DO THE
SAME KIND OF F. Q. DOCUMENT FOR
PARENTS AND TEACHERS. RACKLEY
ADDRESS PLAQUE QUESTION AND
CONCERNS ABOUT SCHOOL REOPENING
PLANS WE LIKED. SHOULD EASE
CPAS. IF ONE OR TWO POSITIVE
CASES COME UP IN A CLASSROOM OR
A TEACHER- WHAT SHOULD PARENTS
AND- TEACHERS EXPECT SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATION'S TO DO SO ARE
WE CAN FOLLOW LOW UP WITH THAT
I. AT THE AND DALTON. THANK YOU
SENATOR HACEN SENATOR BRAUN
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN A GOOD
TWO SETS OF QUESTIONS IN THE
LANKFORD DR FAUCI IN REDFIELD
GIVE ABOUT A MINUTE EACH TO THE
FIRST I WANT TO GET THE BROAD
NUMBERS- I THINK DR REDFIELD
YOU MIGHT'VE BEEN ON RECORD
THAT YOU THINK THERE'S TEN
TIMES AS MANY CASES OUT THERE
IS AND I KNOW THAT'S A GAS I'D
LIKE TO KNOW. BECAUSE IF THAT'S
THE CASE ALMOST ON THE
BRUTALITY RATE GOES FROM 5%
DOWN THE FIVE TENTHS OF PERCENT
TWENTY TIMES MANY CASES OF
COURSE- TWO AND A HALF OF DOWN
THE POINT TWO FIVE WHAT IS YOUR
TO START WITH YOU DR REDFIELD
HOW MANY CASES YOU THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE OUT THERE AND
THEN. HOW MANY- VACCINATIONS
AND OUR- HERD IMMUNITY
COMBINATIONS AS A PERCENTAGE OF
OUR TOTAL POP DO WE TO THE
THING BE IN A RIVER MIRROR SO
WE GOT A FEW NUMBERS KIND OF
LATE THE JOURNEY AHEAD THANK
YOU SO MUCH THE BETTER CLEAN UP
WE NEED ON THE THIS SPRING AND
RICH BRITTANY STATE'S IN IN IN
MY- AND IN BETWEEN AND THE END
OF MAY YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO DO ANTIBODY TESTING AND
THAT'S WHAT ALLOWED US TO
UNDERSTAND HOW MANY PEOPLE
REALLY INFECTED SO DURING THAT
PERIOD. IN A WAS A BAD ESTIMATE
ABOUT TEN TO ONE SO WE'RE
PROBABLY TALKING OVER TWENTY
MILLION TWENTY TWO MILLION
AMERICANS BUT TECH DID I DON'T
WANT TO SEE THAT'S TIM ON IT L.
U. IN JULY ONE FOUR WOULD BE IS
YOU THINK IT'S MORE THAN THAT
NO I THINK TO BE BECAUSE WOULD
BEEN MORE MORE TESTS OKAY. BUT
CLICK. YOUR OPINION HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS WE NEED VACCINATED
AND ARE HAVING HEARD IMMUNITY
BEFORE. THE SAYING GOES INTO
THE REAR VIEW MIRROR AT THE
TIME A COMMENT ON THAT TOO IT'S
REALLY GOT TO BE OVER 70% OF
THE POPULATION HAS GOT TO BE
IMMUNE BEFORE EVEN SEEING THE
IMPACT OF YOUR- HERD IMMUNITY.
DR PROJECT NOT YEAH I TOTALLY
AGREE GIVEN THE
TRANSMISSIBILITY WHICH IS
HIGHLY EFFICIENT. UNITY SABA
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SEVENTY AND
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT. I WOULD
SAY SEVENTY AT THE LOWEST. OKAY
SECOND SET OF QUESTIONS WOULD
BE ON THE ISSUE OF HERD
IMMUNITY BECAUSE- COURSE WE'VE
GOT- THE- WE DON'T KNOW HOW
LONG IT'S GONNA TAKE TO HAVE AN
EFFECTIVE VACCINE- AND I'M
GUESSING AND WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERD IMMUNITY.
IT'S GOT ACTUALLY CONFER
IMMUNITY IF YOU GET IT THERE
MIGHT BE SOME UNCERTAIN LET'S
ASSUME YOU DO GET. THE
IMMUNITY- IS THE- HOW DO WE GO
ABOUT THE APPROACHES THAT WE'VE
USED AT THIS POINT IS HERD
IMMUNITY GOING TO BE SOMETHING
THAT YOU THINK- WILL MARCH
THROUGH IF WE'D TAKE THE
STRATEGY OF HAVING. A DIFFERENT
APPROACH FOR YOUNGER PEOPLE
SEEM TO HAVE LOWER
HOSPITALIZATION RATES AND LESS
SIGNIFICANT CONSEQUENCES
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER
THING WE NEED TO KNOW BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S ALREADY GOING TO
BE. DONE BY EACH INDIVIDUAL ON
A WAY AS A SIZE UP THEIR OWN
PERSONAL RISK SO HOW MUCH CAN
WE COUNT ON HER COMMUNITY AGAIN
ANSWER QUICKLY ON INSURANCE TO
TONY I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REALIZE EVEN NOW WE'RE PROBABLY
LOOKING AT SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
FIVE AND EIGHT SENATOR MERICAN
PUBLIC HIS EXPERIENCES OF
PARIS. SO FOR ME HER COMMUNITY
AS BASIC STRATEGY YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A MULTI YEAR
STRATEGY THIS IS WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT THE ALTERNATE
STRATEGY IS A BIOLOGICAL
COUNTERMEASURES IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A VACCINE. ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT MIGHT BE
COMPLICATING- I DON'T THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE SOMETHING THAT
IS GOING TO BE. ANY KIND OF A
SHOW STOP WE'VE GOT TO REALIZE
N. AS SENATOR PAUL SAID WE HAVE
TO BE HUMBLE AND KNOW THERE'S A
LOT WE DON'T KNOW. AND WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW WAS WITH THE
DURABILITY IS ANOTHER WORD SO
IF YOU WANT UP GETTING HERD
IMMUNITY TO SEVENTY FIVE EIGHTY
PERCENT. WHAT WE NEED TO LEARN
AND ONLY TIME WILL TEACH US
THIS. IS HOW LONG THIS IMMUNITY
LASTS IS IT A YEAR TWO THREE
FOUR OR IS IT EVEN LESS IS IT
MONTHS WE DON'T KNOW WHEN WE
FIND OUT. THEN THAT INFORM US
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT IF YOU GET
A VACCINE HOW IF YOU NEED TO
BOOST. SO WE HAVE TO REALIZE
DON'T REALLY KNOW. THE TO YOUR-
IN ANY DEATH IN WAY. OF GIVES
SOCKS. IMPORT LET FRIENDS. SET
HACEN. EXPRESS POINT.
PROTECTING THE MOST OF ALL.
BECAUSE TO ME THE ONE THING IT
LOOKS LIKE WE COULD CERTAINLY
DO. IS TO TAKE. THAT HIGHEST
RISK GROUP. FROM THE DATA WE'VE
ALREADY GOT DIDN'T BUILD AN
ESSENCE AN IRON DOME AROUND
THEM AS THE ONE THING THAT
WOULD SEEM TO BE THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO DO WHERE YOU
GET CERTAIN RESULTS AND DOWN I
THINK THAT HAS TO BE IN PLACE
AS WE THE UNCERTAINTY. OF HERD
IMMUNITY AND WHEN WE GET AN
EFFECTIVE VACCINE ACTUALLY
CONVERGE I MIGHT ADD JUST WE
ALWAYS THINK ABOUT HERD
IMMUNITY WITH REGARD TO NATURAL
INFECTION AND OR VACCINATION.
BUT WHEN YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
PROTECTING THE VULNERABLE WE
WANT TO SEE IF SOME OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT EMPLOY
PROPHYLACTIC TREATMENT PROGRAMS
LIKE PASSIVE TRANSFER OF PLASMA
OR MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES OR
HYPER IMMUNE GLOBULIN. THOSE
ARE SOME OF THE THINGS YOU CAN
DO TO PROTECT THE VULNERABLE
UNTIL WE DO GET IT EFFECTIVE EX.
THANK YOU SHOULD BRAUN SENATOR
SMITH. THANK YOU TERRA SANDER
RANKING MEMBER MURRAY IT'S GOOD
TO SEE ALL OF YOU TODAY THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR OUR PANELISTS. SO
WE NEED ROBUST SURVEILLANCE
APPLICATION ON TESTING IF WE'RE
GOING TO SAFELY REOPEN OUR
ECONOMY AND OUR SCHOOLS ARE
NURSING HOMES IN A RESEARCH
GROUP HOMES MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT A CONDUIT FOR
INSPECTION AND WERE SEEN AS A
GOOD EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THE NEW
YORK STATE EMPLOYEES IN NURSING
TO GET A POSTED NINETEEN TEST
TWICE A WEEK. SO HERE'S THE
PROBLEM WITH YOUR WORKER FOR
THAT TEST IS THAT MY EMPLOYER
IS IT MY PRIVATE INSURANCE HAVE
INSURANCE OR DO I HAVE TO PAY
FOR IT OUT OF MY POCKET SO I'M
THINKING ABOUT THAT LOW WAGE
WORKERS WORKING IN CHILD CARE
FOOD PROCESSING OR- SECURITY-
YOU KNOW WORKER JANITOR. AND
YOU KNOW THE AVERAGE COST OF A
TRUSTED SOMEONE THAT NEEDS. IF
YOU DON'T OTHER REPORT CAN BE
CHARGED SIXTY DOLLARS TO BE
TESTED YOU CAN FIND. SO THIS IS
MY PURSE QUESTION LAST WEEK AID
POSTED ON THIS BY IN THE GUY
SAID THAT HEALTH ARE NOW REAL
TO COVER THE COST OF. FOR
SURVEILLANCE FOR OCT. REASONS
AND THE FEDERAL TESTING PLANNED
WHICH TALKS ABOUT THE VALUE OF
SURVEILLANCE TESTING AN
OCCUPATIONAL. TESTING IS
SILENCE. SO DOCTOR FELT SHE YOU.
THAT WE ARE GOING TO KEEP
BETTER ABLE TO CONTAIN THE
SPREAD OF COVID NINETEEN AND
SAVE LIVES IF WE- HAVE
SURVEILLANCE TESTING. NO DOUBT
SURVEILLANCE TESTING IS GOING
TO BE A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF
THE PROGRAM TO UNDERSTAND NOT
ONLY THE CURRENT PENETRANCE. OF
THE VIRUS SOCIETY BUT WHERE
IT'S GOING A SHORT ANSWER TO
YOUR QUESTION IS IT'S GOING TO
BE VERY IMPORTANT IN A PUBLIC
HEALTH MEASURES. AND ALSO THE
PRICE OF THESE TESTS ARE THE
ABILITY TO PAY FOR THESE TESTS
YEP PRETTY SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
TO HANG THAT SURVEILLANCE
HAPPEN. I THINK COMMON SENSE
TELLS YOU THAT IF PEOPLE CANNOT
PAY FOR IT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
DO IT THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE GOTTA FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN DO IT. WITHOUT HAVING THE
STRESS OF PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD
TO BE PART OF THAT PROCESS. AND
YOU KNOW THE WORRY OF COURSE IS
THAT THIS ABILITY TO NJ FOR THE
SURVEILLANCE TEST FOR THIS KIND
OF SURVEILLANCE TESTING. THAT
COULD REALLY TEND TO
EXACERBATE- UNDERLYING
INEQUITIES SENSE A LOT OF
FRONTLINE WORKERS AND ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WHO DON'T HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING FOR HOME
ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO BE
BLACK AND BROWN AND INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE THE COLOR IS NOT RIGHT.
AS IN ALL CASES THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE ECONOMICALLY NOT ABLE TO
ENGAGE IN SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT BENEFIT OTHERS THEY ALWAYS.
IN GENERAL THE GET A SHORT END
OF THE STICK ON THAT AND THAT'S
WE HAVE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT.
RIGHT RIGHT. WELL I'M CLUELESS
I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT PLACE WHERE WE HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO. SETTLE SURE
THAT AS WE EXPAND SURVEILLANCE
TESTING OCCUPATIONAL TESTING
LOOK AT OUR SCHOOLS OUR HIGHER
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION COMING BACK AND WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THIS AND
THAT THE ABILITY TO. TAKE THAT
TEST IS IN A VERY- SO I
APPRECIATE- SURE ALEXANDER YOU
MENTION THIS IN THE BEGINNING
OTHERS ABOUT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
MENTIONED THIS I THINK THIS IS
THE PLACE. WHERE WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER IN A IN A CONSTRUCTIVE.
WAY WHEN ASKED. THE QUESTION ON
THE SPLIT. RELATED TO VACCINES
BECAUSE BUT A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THIS A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE TRUST ZACKS SCENES THAT
THEY ARE. SAFE AND THAT THEY
WORK. AND THAT THE LONG TERM
CONSEQUENCES POTENTIAL NEGATIVE
SIDE EFFECTS WE UNDERSTAND. SO
LET ME JUST ASK MIDDLE ASKED-
YOU AGAIN DOCTOR FAUCI ON HOW
DO WE TRUST. THE VACCINE THAT
HAS ONLY HAD A SHORT NUMBER OF
MONTHS POTENTIALLY BEING TESTED
IN AGREEMENT. THERE A COUPLE OF
WAYS TO OVERCOME THAT FIRST IS
THAT YOU HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN THE TRIAL- THE TRIALS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOW
WE'RE GONNA HAVE THIRTY
THOUSAND. PEOPLE IN THE TRIAL
AND MAYBE EVEN MORE IN SOME OF
THEM YOU CAN GET A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF SAFETY DATA. BUT THEN
THERE'S A PROCESS YOU KNOW
AFTER A VACCINE MAYBE WHICH
SHOW EFFICACY TWO FURTHER
STUDIES FOLLOWING LICENSURE
AVAILABILITY I'LL LET DOCTOR
HAN MAYBE COMMENT ON THAT BOARD
BECAUSE THAT BECOMES. SOMETHING
VERY MUCH INVOLVED WITH THE
FDA'S AUTHORITY IN MAKING SURE
WE DO HAVE SAFE VACCINE SO
STEVE. AND LET ME JUST ASK IF I
COULD MAYBE PUT A FINER POINT
ON THIS QUESTION FOR YOU DOCTOR
ON. ANYTHING WHAT IS THE
MANUFACTURER TO SAY THAT THEY
CAN GET A VACCINE TO MARKET IN
JANUARY- BUT ONLY IF THEY WERE
RELEASED FROM LIABILITY WHAT'S
THE FDA POLICY ON A HOW WOULD
YOU RESOLVE THAT QUESTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR- SO WE WOULD
NOT GET INTO THE ISSUE OF
LIABILITY FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
SPONSOR. AND WHAT WE WOULD DO
AND THAT'S WHY WE RELEASED THE
GUIDANCE THIS MORNING AS WE
WOULD INSURE THAT OUR NORMAL
REGULATORY APPROACH AND OUR
STANDARDS FOR SAFETY AND
EFFICACY OR MET. SO WHILE WE'RE
ALL EAGERLY. SAID MANY FACTOR
ARE LIABLE. THAT'S NOT IT NFTA
FORTY THAT WE WOULD THAT WE-
HOW DO YOU GUARD AGAINST THE-
WE'RE RUNNING A LITTLE LATE GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR QUESTION BUT
LET'S THE WEST SHOULD BE
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE AN EASY
ONE I MEAN WHAT I'M WORRIED
ABOUT IS THAT THERE'S SOME SORT
OF OCTOBER SURPRISE AND THAT
THERE IS SOME PRESSURE PUT ON
THE DECISION MAKERS HERE TO
ANNOUNCE THE VACCINE IN OCTOBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY. DR ON CAN YOU
JUST TELL US HOW WE CAN HELP
TRANSPARENCY SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
TRUST THAT THAT ISN'T HAPPENING
CENTERS WITH A VERY GOOD
QUESTION AND REALLY IMPORTANT
AND LEADS TO THE ISSUE OF
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IT'S WHY WE
RELEASED OUR GUIDANCE TODAY WE
WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THE
STANDARDS IN THE DATA THAT WILL
NEED TO MAKE A DECISION. AND
WHAT FACTORS GO INTO THOSE
DECISIONS WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO HEAR ME WHEN I SAY WE
WILL USE THE SCIENCE AND DATA
FROM THOSE TRIALS AND WE WILL
WE WILL SURE THERE ARE HI
LEVELS OF THE STANDARDS FOR
SEEKING AFTER YOUR MEN. THANK
YOU. DISMISS FOR. JUDGE. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE- SORRY I CAN'T BE THERE IN
PERSON I WANTED TO ASK DR
REDFIELD CAN YOU OUTLINE WHAT
STEPS THE CDC IS TAKING IT TO
YOU KNOW LOOK AT AS WE PREPARE
FOR HANDLING BOTH THE FLU AND
COVID NINETEEN A SEASON
SIMULTANEOUSLY THIS FALL I KNOW
THE CDC RECENTLY DEVELOPED
TESTS THAT DIAGNOSE BOTH COVID
NINETEEN AND THE FLU ONE OTHER
ACTIVITIES IS THE AGENCY
ENGAGED IN AND ARE THERE ANY
NOVEL APPROACHES- THAT YOU SEE
IN TERMS OF IMPLEMENTING THIS-
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR ABOUT THE
AGENCY'S PROCESS. OF
APPROACHING THE SEASON THIS
FALL AND- IN YOUR THOUGHTS
THERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT- TO RECOGNIZE THAT IT
CAN BE DIFFICULT WITH THE FLU
AND COVID THIS FALL FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS TO TRY TO INCREASE
THE AMOUNT PUBLIC SEAFOOD TEAM
IS YOU LISTEN FIFTY PER AT THE-
IN. TO BEGIN TO READ. DICK THE
GROUP LIVES ON REFERENCE. TRY
THAT TOP THANKS. WE WORKED WITH
THE MENU. TO SEE THEY CAN BOOST
THE AMOUNT OF THAT WOULD BE A
THEY'VE NOW INCREASE THEIR
COMMITMENT TO ALMOST A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY NINE MILLION DOSES
CDC BOUGHT ANOTHER SEVEN POINT
ONE MILLION DOSES NORMALLY WE
BY ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
TO BE ABLE TO BE AVAILABLE TO
THE STATES AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS FOR UNINSURED
ADULTS WE'VE BEEN AND WE
INCREASED THAT TO SEVEN POINT
ONE. MILLION DOSES WE'VE
AUGMENTED OUR COMMITMENT TO THE
VACCINE PROGRAM ANTICIPATING
THAT IT WILL BE MORE CHILDREN
THAT WILL QUALIFY IN LIGHT OF
THE UNEMPLOYMENT SO THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE AREAS THAT WE'VE
GONE TO PREPARE FOR. THANK YOU.
BUT AND THIS QUESTION IS FOR
DOCTOR HALL ON- YOU KNOW THE
PANDEMIC HAS OUR
VULNERABILITIES THE MEDICAL
SUPPLY CHAIN AND BASICALLY WE
HAVE A FINANCE ON IMPORTS FROM
COUNTRY LIKE CHINA THAT CAN
QUICKLY POSE A NATIONAL
SECURITY RISK- IN THE FACE OF
AN OUTBREAK OF INFECTIOUS
DISEASE- WE NEED TO COME UP
WITH A STRATEGY TO BOOST OUR
PRODUCTION HERE OF
PHARMACEUTICALS AND SUPPLIES- I
BETTER DO SOME LEGISLATION
TITLED THE BEAT CHINA ACT OFFER
INCENTIVES TO COMPANIES THAT
BRING MANUFACTURING BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES BUT WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM YOU WHAT ADDITIONAL
STEPS POLICYMAKERS TAKEN TO
START. KEEP ABILITY TO PRODUCE
THESE SUPPLIES AND
PHARMACEUTICALS DOMESTICALLY.
F. YOU SEVERAL DIFFERENT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
I THINK ONE- ISSUE THAT WE CAN
ALL AGREE UPON IS- THE LACK OF
REDUNDANCY IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
IN THE- DEPENDENCY. THAT WE'VE
SEEN DURING THE COVID NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN A PROBLEM THE
AGENCY'S PRIMARY FOCUS HAS BEEN
ON- INSTILLING REDUNDANCY IN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN. PARTICULARLY
OF PHARMACEUTICALS BY
DIVERSIFYING THAT SUPPLY CHAIN
AND REALLY LOOKING FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENCOURAGE ON.
DOMESTIC MANUFACTURING WE OF
COURSE ON THE REGULATORY SIDE
PROVIDE GUIDANCE AS WELL AS
REGULAR PATIENTS OR ON THE- THE
MANUFACTURING. TO ENSURE
QUALITY OF PHARMACY GOES
ANOTHER VEHICLE THANKS.
CONTINUE TO DO THAT FOR TWO IN
THE ADVANCED MANUFACTURING
SPACE- IN ORDER TO ENCOURAGE
DOMESTIC MANUFACTURING WE LOOK
FORWARD VERY MUCH TO WORKING
WITH YOU AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TO SEE HOW WE CAN
CREATE THE PROPER INCENTIVES-
TO HAVE THAT REDUNDANCY AND
PARTICULARLY TO HAVE AS MUCH
DOMESTIC MANUFACTURING AS
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU DR HON NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS I'LL BUY TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR- LEFFLER
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE TODAY REALLY
APPRECIATE. YOUR TESTIMONY YOUR
CONSISTENCY OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS- IT IS GOT TO BE
SOMEWHAT DISCOURAGING TO ALL OF
YOU AS IT IS TO US TO SEE THESE
NUMBERS I WANT TO KIND OF FOCUS
A LITTLE BIT ON TOOLS- AS WE
WILL STOP PUTTING SCHOOLS UP NO
MA'AM IN AUGUST AND LET ME BE A
LITTLE CHRONOLOGY HERE. ARE
STATE ABOUT DONALD BEGAN TO
OPEN UP ITS ECONOMY MORE AND
MAY. LOOK MORE TOWARD THE END
OF MAY AND THEN END OF FOR
MEMORIAL DAY WE SAW THE
PHOTOGRAPHS AND VIDEOS A DOCTOR
FOR SHE REFERRED EVERYBODY JUST
HAVING TIME FOR MEMORIAL DAY
HOLIDAY. NOW AT THE END OF JUNE.
YOU ARE OUR HIGHEST LEVEL THE
LAST FOURTEEN OF OVER TEN
THOUSAND CASES WHICH IS TWENTY
EIGHT PERCENT. OF THE CASES
THAT WE HAVE SEEN. URGES THE
LACK FOURTEEN DAYS ARE IN AT
THE END OF THIS WEEK WE HAVE
THE JULY FOURTH HOLIDAY COMING
UP. AND WE'RE GOING TO SEE A
DELAY AND HOSPITALIZATION FROM
RIGHT NOW IF WE DO THE SAME
THING ON JULY FOURTH WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM AT
THE END OF JULY AND EARLY
AUGUST WE START OPENING SCHOOLS
ON. OUR STATE SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENT THIS WEEK SAID
THAT IT WOULD COST ABOUT ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE AVERAGE SCHOOL SYSTEM TO DO
THOSE THINGS NECESSARY. TO TRY
TO PROTECT KIDS AND A FACULTY
BUT- I HEARD SENATOR POLL IN
HIS COMMENTS AND DISCUSSING A
NUMBER OF THINGS TO WHERE YOU
WOULD GET THE IMPRESSION THAT
WILL JUST OPEN SCHOOLS BACK UP
WITHOUT SPENDING ANY OF THAT
MONEY. SO MY QUESTION PRIMARILY
TO DOCTOR FOR ALLERGY AND DR
REDFIELD. COULD YOU COMMENT ON
SOME OF THE STATISTICS AND SOME
THINGS THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT.
CHILDREN TRANSMITTING THIS
DISEASE AND WHETHER OR NOT WE
NEED TO SPEND SO MUCH
ADDITIONAL MONIES FOR OUR
SCHOOLS TO DO THINGS LIKE HELP
EX FOR PP. TO DO THINGS LIKE
HIRING POTENTIALLY HIRING
ADDITIONAL- HEALTH OFFICERS
TEMPERATURE SCREENINGS THOSE
KIND OF THINGS ARE THOSE GOING
TO BE. NECESSARY BASED ON WHAT
I'VE HEARD FROM SENATOR PAUL
AND WHAT HAPPENED ON HIS CHARTS
IN OTHER COUNTRIES DR VALJEAN
DR REDFIELD. ALL QUICKLY GET A
SHOT AND THEN HANDED OVER TO DR
REDFIELD WE DON'T KNOW
PRECISELY I THINK THE DATA THAT
WAS VERY INTERESTING THAT
SENATOR POLL SHOWED. ABOUT
SCHOOL OPENINGS AND NOT SEEING
ANY REAL OBVIOUS SURGE IN CASES
IS IMPORTANT. BUT WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW- EXACTLY WHAT THE
EFFICIENCY OF SPREAD IS FIRST
OF ALL HOW MANY CHILDREN GET
INFECTED THAT WAS THE REASON
WHY IN MY OPENING STATEMENT. I
MENTIONED THE STUDY THAT WE'RE
DOING AT THE END OF THE AGE OF
SIX THOUSAND FAMILIES LOOKING
AT CHILDREN WHAT IS THE RATE OF
THEIR INFECTION AND HOW OFTEN
DO THEY INFECT THEIR FAMILIES.
BECAUSE IF IT'S TRUE AT THE
RATE IS DOWN WE KNOW THAT THEY
DON'T GET SERIOUSLY ILL WITH
HOSPITALIZATIONS WHEN THEY GET
INFECTED. BUT AT THE RATE OF
INFECTION IS DOWN AND THEY
DON'T READILY TRANSMIT. TO
THEIR PARENTS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT'S GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT IN THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS. OF OPENING
SCHOOLS HOPEFULLY WE'RE GONNA
FIND OUT REASONABLY SOON BY
THIS STUDY THAT WE'RE DOING UP.
I'D ECHO WHAT DOCTOR VEGGIE
SAID CDC HAS A NUMBER OF WHAT
WE CALL HOUSEHOLD STUDIES GOING
ON TO TRY TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING. OF HOW DOES THE
VIRUS GET INTO A HOUSEHOLD. WHO
BRINGS IT IN WHAT HAPPENS WITH
WHEN IT'S IN THE HOUSEHOLD. HOW
DOES TRANSMISSION- VERY
DEPENDING ON HOW THE HOUSEHOLD
RESPONSE IN TERMS OF SOCIAL TO.
CENTER TIM FROM THAT WE'RE
GATHERING. I THINK- WE DON'T
KNOW THE IMPACT THE CHILDREN
HAVE YET ON THE TRANSMISSION
CYCLE SO I THINK WE SHOULD JUST
DIG KNOWLEDGE THAT- IN THE
GREATER THREAT OBVIOUSLY IS
AGAIN THOSE CHILDREN TO THE
VULNERABLE BUT I THINK ONE CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE SOCIAL BEHAVIOR
THAT CAN PREVENT THAT. AND SO I
THINK THAT WOULD BE- JUST TO
EMPHASIZE- I THINK IT'S A-
REALLY IMPORTANT HAS BEEN SAID
ALREADY THAT WE MOVE FORWARD
AND WORK TO RE OPENING SCHOOLS
IN A SAFE WAY. I THINK IT'S OF
NO TO CDC NEVER REALLY
RECOMMENDED CLOSING SCHOOLS.
IT'S SORT OF JUST HAPPENED AS
YOU KNOW. WE CAN DO TARGETED
SCHOOL CLOSINGS IF WE HAVE TO
IN A PARTICULAR REGION LIKE
WE'VE DONE FOR OTHER VILE
PIECES. BUT I THINK WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD NOW. I WORKED AT A
REAL SCHOOLS. THANK YOU M. O.
ARE OF JUST I WANT TO MAKE SURE
YOUR WE'RE IN AND WE TALKED
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT WE GONNA BE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
BACK. DISTRIBUTED THE BALL.
BECAUSE THAT'S- WHERE SO MUCH
IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN THE
ROLL SOUTH- AND ARE YOU MAKING
SPECIFIC PLANS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THAT. INTO THE
RURAL AREAS. SET THE SET THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO WE ALL WORK ON
PARTS OF THIS PROBLEM RIGHT SO
THE CDC ACTUALLY CONTROLS THE
DISTRIBUTION BUT WHAT MY OFFICE
DOES RUNNING THE NATIONAL
VACCINE PROGRAM. DOES THINGS
LIKE THE MORE HOUSE- GRANT THAT
WILL A COOPERATIVE AGREEMENT
THAT WE THAT WE ANNOUNCED LAST
WEEK. THAT REALLY REACHES ON
INTO THE ROLL INTO HISPANIC
INTO AFRICAN AMERICAN TO
REALLY. HAVE THE COMMUNITY THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THAT
COMMUNITY NOW I DON'T THINK THE
SERVICES LIKE LIKE TESTING BUT
TODAY THE GROUNDWORK FOR
EXCEEDING. BECAUSE WE KNOW. THE
BURDEN THE HE'S- MENTALLY BIRD
I HOPE ALL THESE INDIVIDUAL SO
THE PEOPLE ASSUMING THE PAINS
WERE. ONE TO GET VACCINATED FOR
FIRST TIME GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SENATE OWNS AISLE WITNESSES
NEED TO LEAVE ONE GOING TO TRY
TO RESPECT THAT SENATOR. THANK
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. MORNING I WILL TRY TO- IS
QUICK AS I CAN TALKING ABOUT
ANTIBODIES THIS MORNING THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN ALEXANDER RANKING
MEMBER MURRAY ALL OF OUR
WITNESSES FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AS OUR COMMUNITIES FOCUS ON A
HOUSE SAFELY GET BACK TO WORK
AND SCHOOL JUST LIKE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WE KNOW WE HAVE
TO FOLLOW SIGN THE DAPT
INFORMATION. BE SURE TIME. GET
IT AND SOUGHT. IT WAS. WIVES
AND- SO DOCTOR FOUND THE LAST
TIME YOU WERE WE TALK ABOUT THE
MONOCLONAL ANTIBODY TREATMENTS
AND I'D LOST LIKE TO FOLLOW UP
ON THAT CONVERSATION IS. AS IF
WE AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
VIRUS HOW IT FUNCTIONS HOW IT'S
DIFFERENT FROM OTHER
RESPIRATORY ILLNESSES WHAT
UPDATES CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF PREVENTATIVE
TREATMENTS AND BLOCKED THE
VIRUS FROM ATTACHING. TO THE
CELLS THAT IT'S TARGETING. BUT
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SENATOR YOU MENTIONED
MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES.
MONOCLONAL ANTIBODIES ARE GOING
INTO TRIALS RIGHT NOW AND A
NUMBER OF TRIALS SPONSORED. BY
A NUMBER OF GROUPS- HOPEFULLY
WITHIN A REASONABLE PERIOD OF
TIME WILL GET INFORMATION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S AFFECTED
BOTH. IN THE PREVENTION AS WELL
AS IN THE TREATMENT THOSE
ANTIBODIES DIRECTED AGAINST A
COMPONENT OF THE VIRUS. THAT IS
WHAT'S CALLED THE SPIKE PROTEIN
AND THAT PROTEIN IS THE ONE
THAT BINDS TO THAT NATIONAL
WELL ESTABLISHED. RECEPTOR BY.
FOR THE NEXT RELEASE ACE TO
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER
STUDIES THAT ARE NOT
NECESSARILY ANYBODY STUDIES.
BUT STUDIES THAT HAVE A AFFECT
ON THE VIRUS ITSELF AND ITS
INITIAL REPLICATION IN ANSWER
TO A QUESTION. THAT THE CHIP
IN. THE MAIL IN JUST A BIT AGO
IS THAT THEY WILL BE THERAPIES-
WE WILL ACCEPT THE TREATMENT ON
AND FOR PROFILE. AND AS WE HOPE
AS WE GET INTO THE FALL AND
WINTER WE'LL HAVE EVERYTHING
FROM SMALL MOLECULE TREATMENTS
AND PROPHYLAXIS FOR THE KINDS
OF ANYBODY'S THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. SO THERE'S A LOT
OF ACTIVITY GOING ON TO DO THAT
EARLY IN DISEASE BOTH FOR
PREVENTION AND FOR THE
TREATMENT OF EARLY DISEASE. I
KNOW THAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING A
LOT OF SEROLOGY TESTING AND
THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE
PRESENTING- WITH ANTIBODIES SO
OUT OF THE FIVE TYPES. OF
ANTIBODIES SET UP PEOPLE ARE
MOST LIKELY TO HAPPEN WHICH
ONES DO MOST RECOVERS PATIENTS
OUT WHICH ONES ARE THEY SHOW.
AND IF ONE OF THESE SPECIFIC
ANTIBODIES ARE PRESENT DOES
THAT MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND IF
THE PATIENT CAN BE RE INFECTED
OR NOT. OR NOT ARE THEY
EFFECTIVELY A NEW LEASE FOR
SOME PERIOD OF TIME. WHAT KIND
OF ANSWERS DOES THIS GIVE US IF
YOU DO HAVE THE PRESENCE OF
CERTAIN ANTIBIOTICS. NO I I'D
LIKE I'D LOVE TO GIVE YOU A
REALLY PRECISE SCIENTIFICALLY
BASED DANCER BUT THE FACT IS.
WE DON'T KNOW STANDARD WISE
WHEN YOU GET AN ACUTE INFECTION
YOU GET AN I. G. M. ANYBODY. AS
YOU GO UP THERE IN TIME TO
DEVELOP A MORE TO MATURE.
IMMUNE RESPONSE IF IT COMES IN
I. G. G. THERE IS SUPPLE
SUBCLASSES OF I. G. G. SOME
MORE PROTECTIVE THAN OTHERS THE
THING WE DON'T KNOW SENATOR.
THAT WE WILL- WE WILL KNOW IN
TIME BUT IT'S GOING TO TAKE
TIME TO KNOW IT. IS WHAT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
NEUTRALIZING ANYBODY AND
BINDING ANTIBODIES THAT DON'T
NEUTRALIZE. WHAT IS THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
TIGHTER AND THE DEGREE OF
PROTECTION AND WHAT IS THE
DURABILITY OF PROTECTION WE
SEEN SOME PUZZLING THINGS.
WE'VE SEEN PEOPLE RECOVER FROM
COVID INFECTION AND FIND OUT
THEY DON'T HAVE VERY HIGH
LEVELS OF ANYBODY COULD BE A
CELL MEDIATED RESPONSE THAT GOT
THEM THROUGH THE ILLNESS. AND
SOME OTHER INDIVIDUALS HAVE
VERY HIGH LEVELS AND WE KNOW
HOW LONG THOSE LEVELS LAST SO
WE'RE GETTING THERE WITH REGARD
TO OUR KNOWLEDGE. BUT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE SEVERAL MORE
MONTHS TO A YEAR TO REALLY BE
ABLE TO DEFINITIVELY SO YOU'RE-
ABOUT THE ROLE OF ANYBODY. IN
PROTECTIONS FOLLOWING THAT
INFECTION. BUILDING UPON THAT
I'D TO ASK QUESTION AND WE KNOW
THAT THIS VIRUS ON BACKSTOP
MOLD IS MULTI ORGAN IT CAN
AFFECT YOUR KIDNEYS YOUR LUNGS
OR HEART. REDUCING STROKES ALL
KINDS OF THINGS YOUR DIGESTIVE
SYSTEM YOUR SENSE OF SMELL. SO
ON THE SCIENCE THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE ANTIBODIES IS
THE SCIENCE OF STOPPING THE
VIRUS FROM CAUSING HARM. THE
SAME REGARDLESS OF WHICH
WORKING IN A TAX AND HOW DO. WE
HELP DIRECT FUNDING FOR THE
KIND OF RESEARCH THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO NEED TO LOOK AT THIS
MULTI ORGAN. ON AT THIS. WILL
THIS IS A VERY FLEXIBLE BECAUSE
IT'S A RESPIRATORY VIRUS AND IT
GETS INTO THE RESPIRATORY TRACT
IF THE VIRUS STAYS IN THE
RESPIRATORY TRACT AND DOESN'T
GO SYSTEMIC TO INVOLVE OTHER
ORGANS THAT'S GOOD NEWS BECAUSE
YOU DON'T GET VERY SICK. THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE COIN IS YOUR
ANYBODY RESPONSE IS NOT AS
POTENT BECAUSE WHEN YOU GET
SYSTEMIC INVOLVEMENT INVARIABLY
YOU WILL HAVE A MORE POTENT AND
ROBUST IMMUNE RESPONSE. SO MANY
PEOPLE AND PROBABLY THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE THE A SYMPTOMATIC
CARRIERS THEY HAVE A REASONABLE
TIGHTER OF VIRUS IN THEIR NASAL
PHARYNX BUT THE VIRUS DOESN'T
GO ANY OTHER PLACE IN THEIR
BODY. PEOPLE WHO GET MULTI
SYSTEM DISEASE THAT GET
TRIGGERED BY THE VIRUS THOSE
ARE THE ONES THAT UNFORTUNATELY
GETTING SICK. BUT ALSO THE ONES
THAT MAKE A MORE POTENT IMMUNE
RESPONSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOU ALL BEING HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR ROSE
VERY INTERESTING QUESTION
SENATOR MURRAY DO YOU HAVE
CLOSING REMARKS. I HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL QUESTION IF I MIGHT
AND THEN CLOSING REMARKS THANK
I WANT ACT AND WILL DRIVE ON
QUESTION. YES MA'AM. I THANK
YOU ON IT AND DESPITE SOME
LIMITED DATA WE DO KNOW THAT
COVID NINETEEN IS ACT INFECTING
AND KILLING BLACK LATINO AND
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE AT A
MUCH HIGHER RATE THAN WHITE
PEOPLE I WANT TO ASK YOU HOW
HHS IS GONNA JUSTICE RESPONSE
TO REDUCE CASES AND DEATHS AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
SPECIFICALLY CAN YOU COMMIT TO
REDIRECT SOME OF THE FOURTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS THAT IS AND I'M
SPENT FINDS CONGRESS PROVIDED
TO ADDRESS THOSE DISPARITIES.
ON THE ANSWER THE TWO PARTS OF
THE QUESTION- FIRST THE AT IS
YOU KNOW AND REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT. WE'VE TRIED TO
FOCUS OUR TESTING INTO HIGH
SOCIAL VULNERABILITY COMMUNITY
SAYS 70% OF OUR OVER SIX
HUNDRED- THE PHARMACY SITES.
ARE IN HIGH S. V. I.
COMMUNITIES THAT MEANS RACIAL
AND ETHNIC MINORITIES LANGUAGE
TO- DISPARITIES- SOCIOECONOMIC
ON FQHCS WE MADE A MAJOR PUSH
THAT- THE FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS THAT TAKE CARE
OF ONE OUT OF THREE THOSE IN
POVERTY. OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED
THOSE ARE NOW OFFERING STING
AND OF COURSE WE'RE- CITED
ABOUT THE AWARD TO MOREHOUSE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE LAST WEEK.
THAT HAS A LARGE COALITION
CREATED NATIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
TO REACH TO REACH MINORITIES
AND UNDERSERVED SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE REALLY DOING YOU KNOW MY
OFFICE THIS IS WHAT WE DO ON A
ON A DAILY BASIS. THEY EVEN
WITHOUT A PANDEMIC YOUR SECOND
QUESTION IS I DON'T COMMIT THE
MONEY- SO- I CERTAINLY THINK WE
NEED CONTINUED INVESTMENT. IN
THIS CONTINUED SIGNET. FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS AS A DOWN
PAYMENT ON HOW WE COULD BEST
REACH THE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY
BUT YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO TALK
TO AND BE ABOUT HOW THE MONEY
IS SPENT- WELL ACTUALLY HHS
OVERSEES THAT SO WE WILL ASK
THEM BUT I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION ON. KEEP
FOLLOWING UP IN TRACK YEAH IT'S
ME. OUR MAN I APPRECIATE ON
OVER WE- TAKING THE TIME TO
JOIN US TODAY TO. OUR COMMITTEE
ON. THE COURSE OF THIS PANDEMIC
AND ALL OF OUR EFFORTS TO
RESPOND TO IT. I HOPE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE FROM ALL OF YOU. AS WELL
AS OTHER KEY ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
THE ABSOLUTE WORST THING. WE
COULD DO RIGHT NOW IS TO
PRETEND THIS CRISIS IS OVER.
WHEN IT IS PAINFULLY OBVIOUS.
NOT TRUE. THE REALITY IS THAT
THE WHAT IS IN THIS PANDEMIC SO
FAR NEARLY UNTHINKABLE AND IN
FURTHER DELAYS OUR RESPONSE.
EARLY UNACCEPTABLE. WE TAKE
THIS PRESIDENT TO TAKE THIS
CRISIS SERIOUSLY AND WE- AND WE
NEED A CAR. TO ACT I HOPE WE
CAN ALL GET BACK TO WORK. SOON
AS POSSIBLE WE NEED. BORDER
AMERISERV FRONTLINE WORKERS ARE
THIS IS OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITIES.
WE NEED TO GET TESTING WEREN'T
USED TO BE. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE MAKING. TOWARDS
STATE ACTIVE WHY WE HAVE ON THE
VACCINE. WE NEED. ON OUR. I
THEM SO THERE'S A LOT LEFT. IT
WOULD BE WOULD BE HONEST THANK
YOU SENATOR MURRAY A NEW WOULD
IT IS HAVE MEETING THE NEED TO
GO TO SO I BREATHE MY ROOM BUT
THING I TO ASK YOU PERHAPS YOU
CAN EACH DO IT IN. A MINUTE OR
LESS. I'VE PUT OUT A WHITE
PAPER. IN RECOGNITION OF WHAT
SOME OF YOU HAVE SAID WHICH IS
A IN BETWEEN PANDEMICS WE HAVE
FOUND IT DIFFICULT TO DO SOME
OF THE THINGS WE NEED TO DO TO
PREPARE FOR THE NEXT PANDEMIC.
SO THERE WERE ONE OR TWO THINGS
THAT YOU THOUGHT WE SHOULD TRY
TO DO NOW IN ORDER TO BE
PREPARED FOR THE NEXT PANDEMIC.
WHAT WOULD THOSE ONE OR TWO
THINGS B. DR FAUCI. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IS AN APPRECIATION ON THE PART
OF OUR ENTIRE NATION OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF RESPONDING AS A
NATION AS A WHOLE AND NOT HAVE
A SITUATION WHERE WHEN YOU HAVE
A CHALLENGE SUCH AS WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW WE ARE VERY DESPERATE
RESPONSE. WE'VE GOT TO DO IT IN
A COORDINATED WAY BECAUSE WE
ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER. THE
OTHER THING I'D LIKE TO DO NOW
IS TO CEMENT IN OUR MINDS AS WE
BRIDGE TO THE FUTURE. THE FACT
THAT WE CANNOT FORGET THAT WHAT
WAS THOUGHT TO BE UNIMAGINABLE
TURNED OUT TO BE THE REALITY
THAT WE'RE FACING RIGHT NOW SO
RELATES TO THE KIND OF
APPRECIATION THAT OUTBREAKS
HAPPEN AND YOU HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THEM IN A VERY AGGRESSIVE
PROACTIVE WAY. DOCTORATE FEEL.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I THINK
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT I
CAN SAY IS THAT WHEN IT COMES
TO PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS OUR
NATION NEEDS TO BE OVER
PREPARED NOT UNDER PREPARED AND
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE DECADES
OF UNDER INVESTMENT INVESTING
INVESTMENT IN THE CORE
CAPABILITIES OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DATA MODERNIZATION LABORATORY
RESILIENCE WORK FORCE. MERGES
RESPONSE I THINK IT'S
FUNDAMENTAL WE'VE REALLY- BEEN
HIT WITH THIS SIMPLE VIRUS- AND
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY
IT'S GOING TO COST OUR NATION
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS. I THINK
OF A MOMENT IN TIME. WHERE I
THINK PEOPLE ARE ATTUNED AND I
WOULD SAY NOW'S THE TIME TO
MAKE THE NECESSARY INVESTMENT
IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH AT THE
LOCAL TERRITORIAL TRIBAL STATE
AND FEDERAL LEVEL SO THAT THIS
NATION FINALLY HAS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM NOT ONLY THAT IT
NEEDS BUT THAT IT DESERVES.
YOUR WALLS. OF COURSE I AGREE
COMPLETELY WITH MY COLLEAGUES
AND WE'RE ALL SINGING FROM THE
SAME HYMNAL HERE- ALL SAY THREE
THINGS NUMBER ONE DATA
INFRASTRUCTURES REALLY
IMPORTANT. WHEN WE CAME INTO
THIS WE DIDN'T KNOW HOW MANY
VENTILATORS WERE IN USE HOW
MANY TESTS WERE OUT THERE WHERE
THE TEST POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE
WHO IS BEING TESTED I MEAN THE
COMPLETE SOUP TO NUTS.
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE DECISIONS YOU NEED THE
DATA TO MAKE DECISIONS TO
ALLOCATE RESOURCES AND THAT WE
BUILT THIS ON THE FLY BUT WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO INVEST IN
THAT. SECONDLY IT'S A RISK AND
SEE THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM YES
WE NEED TO ATTACK COVID BUT
WHAT HAPPENED EVERY ELSE WE'VE
SEEN CANCER SCREENINGS GOT OUT.
SHOT MINUTES. JUST ABOUT EVERY
OTHER THING IN HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM WITH SAP AS FAR COVID
RESPONSE SO IT'S NOT JUST THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE BUT IT'S
EVERYTHING UP I NEED TO DO. AND
THE THIRD THING I WOULD SAY IS
WE CONTINUE HALF THE FOLKS
HEALTH IS. ARE YOU EVERYONE WAS
HEALTH THIS COUNTRY IF WE
TESTED INTO THE AT TO HYPER.
DIE OBESE. ALL THE THINGS THAT
COULD BRING THE GENERAL HEALTH
UP YOU WOULD NOT SEE IS
HORRIBLE OF OUTCOMES AS WE
HAVEN'T HAD ANY PANDEMIC. SO
WORKING ON HEALTH DISPARITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN HERE FOR DECADES
IS I THINK CRITICAL TO RATE ARE
IN GENERAL HEALTH AND PREPARES
FOR. WHATEVER'S GOING TO HIT
US. DR HAN YOU CAN HAVE THE
LAST WORD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN FIRST OF ALL THANKS
FOR YOUR SHIP ON YOUR WHITE
PAPER. IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
THIS CONVERSATION. THIRTY
THINGS EMPHASIZE ONE IS THE
DATA MODERNIZATION BUT FROM AN
FDA PERSPECTIVE TO VERY ANNUAL
PROCESS TO ONE. COLLECT ON
DEMAND AND- ALSO SAID THE
SUPPLY CHAIN WE NEED OF A ROBOT.
SYSTEMS WE NEED A BUS REAL
WORLD EVIDENCE WHICH SO THAT
WHEN WE DECISIONS IN REAL TIME
DURING HER. DOCTORS DO THAT ALL
THE TIME AGENCIES DO THAT
PARTICULAR DURING PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES WE HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
TO COLLECT REAL WORLD EVIDENCE.
AND FEEDBACK INTO OUR DECISIONS
AND THEN REVISE THOSE DECISIONS
AS NEEDED CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
FOR THE AGENCY. AND THE SECOND
THING IS LINKED AND THAT IS. IN
MY PREVIOUS COMMENTS THE CENTER
LEFT LAST ABOUT. ABSOLUTELY
NEED REDUNDANCY IN THE SUPPLY
CHAIN WHEN YOU'RE DONE SAID
MANUFACTURING AND WE NEED TO
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF TIM.
THANK YOU. THE KEY DANGEROUS
VIRUS HAS REMINDED US IS THAT
THERE WILL BE ANOTHER SNEAKY
DANGEROUS VIRUS ONE DAY AND WE
KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE THAT IT
MAY BE EASIER TO TAKE THE STEPS
YOU'VE JUST DESCRIBED WHILE OUR
EYES ON THE BALL RATHER THAN
BETWEEN PANDEMICS BECAUSE WE
GET INTERESTED AND OTHER ISSUES.
RIGHT FOR TO THE WEB AS FOR
YOUR TIME THANK THE SENATORS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE FOR.
REALLY CAREFUL INSIGHTFUL AND
COURTEOUS QUESTIONING- THE
HEARING RECORD WILL REMAIN OPEN
FOR TEN DAYS MEMBERS MAY SUBMIT
IT IF IT'S DIGITAL INFORMATION
THEN THAT TYPE OF THEY WERE
LIKE THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
THE COMMITTEE WILL STAND
ADJOURNED.
UHHUH.